Drei, zwei, eins.
Mobile Max.
Willkommen.
Ausgabe Nummer 30.
Hallo, wir sind's wieder.
Die drei von der Tankstelle.
Die drei von der Datentankstelle. Nachdem ich meinen Powernap hinter mich gebracht habe. Jetzt komm ich auch langsam wieder.
Du warst total downpowered.
Ich war total verpeilt, aber wäre ich nicht jetzt... Das musste ich jetzt einfach eingehen, das Risiko, weil sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich dauerunkonzentriert, da keine Energie mehr. Ich hab irgendwie gerade so ein Podcasting-Marathon hinter mir. Ich war auch auf Reisen und ich war auch zum Zwecke des Aufnehmens neuer Sendungen auf Reisen. Und dann war ich auch noch auf so einer Podcasting-Veranstaltung in München. Da liefen ganz viele Podcasts darum. Ja, ne, ohne Kopfhörer.
Aber mit Mikro?
Manche. Aber im Wesentlichen wurde da so geredet. Das war halt so eine... Das Podcaster halt so machen. Naja, die haben sich halt so getroffen und geredet. Dabei wurde dann auch geatmet. Also es wurde unter anderem darüber geredet, wie man ordentlich redet, wie man ordentlich sitzt, wie man so einatmen sollte und so weiter. Ganze Sätze sprechen, das übliche.
Schaffen das nicht so viele?
Ganze Sätze sprechen?
Naja, das ist nicht unbedingt immer so garantiert. Ich war. Und so Schmatzereien und so Undeutlichkeiten zu vermeiden und all das. Aber das wollte ich jetzt hier gar nicht so in den Mittelpunkt stellen, sondern in den Mittelpunkt dieser Sendung stelle ich unsere Hörerpost.
Ja, bei wem müssen wir uns eigentlich bedanken?
Erstmal müssen wir uns glaube ich beim Zollamt bedanken, dass sie hier diese Sendung haben auch durchgehen lassen, aus dem fernen Ausland.
Mit zwei Kisten?
Ja, wir haben gleich zwei.
Von zwei verschiedenen Leuten?
Von zwei verschiedenen Leuten, die auch beide am selben Tag ankamen.
Zwei nur?
Aus Zürich und?
Ein Guetta us die Schweiz. Das sollte für mehrere Sendungen reichen. Macht weiter so. Grüße aus Schaffhausen.
Schaffhausen, da war ich sogar schon mal.
Döxli, ja Schaffhausen, das da wo das Wasser runterfällt.
Genau, die Rheinfälle sind da, ne?
Genau, aber diese Kiste ist definitiv kein Rheinfall. Wie bestellt, ja, also hier. Lindt Double Lay Muesli Crisp.
Schmeiß alles hin.
Ja, dann haben wir hier auch noch eine Packung. L'Enfinie Fondant. Endlich zart schmelzen.
So ein bisschen twitpicken. So ein bisschen vielleicht so...
Genau, twitten sie doch mal. Twitten sie doch mal pick. Ich mach hier mal das Licht an, dass wir das ordentlich sehen können. Hier, da bin ich ja ganz dafür zu haben. Uwe und Martine, würde ich sagen, ist im Wesentlichen auch wirklich eine der kulturellen Hochleistungen der Schweiz.
Des Schweizers im Allgemeinen.
Ja. Also die haben's erfunden und dafür gehört ihnen einfach Kredit. Genau. Hier ist was, was ich noch nicht kenne. Das ist irgendwie Nougat-Honig-Schokolade. Honig-Nougat, Milch-Schokolade mit Honig-Nougat. Rayon oder vielmehr Cahier. Was ist da jetzt die Marke und was ist das Ding, wie auch immer? Gehört am Ende sowieso alles Nestle oder Nestlé. Dann gibt's hier noch mal Cahier. Dann hier heißt es Frigoire. Das ist Mandelnoisette, sieht auch sehr schick aus.
Wie wird das eigentlich ausgesprochen? Noisette? Noisette.
Noisette. Noisette. Was heißt das? Donkel-Schokolade. Noisette ist ja die Nuss, also mit X, Neu-X. Nuss-Nou. Noisette, kann ich dir jetzt gerade gar nicht sagen, was das jetzt grammatikalisch bedeutet, nussig halt.
Tourist.
Und genau, das ist Tourist und Mensch, da kommt ja noch die dicke, fette Turblavone.
400 Gramm Turblavone.
400 Gramm, also ist jetzt keine, ist nicht die 4 Kilo-Ausgabe.
Aber ist schon ganz schön ordentlich.
Genau. So, und dann haben wir noch das zweite Paket.
Das sieht ja aber noch.
Hier geht der Dank an.
Hast du den Namen überhaupt schon gesagt, von wem das ihm gerade war? Oder ich hab ihn wieder vergessen. Der alte Schafhausen.
Ed Bergsley, sprich auf Twitter, B-O-E-G-G-S-L-Y. Und hier...
Bergsley, wie schreibt man das?
Steht jetzt ein komischer Absichter drauf, aber das ist meines Wissens hier von der Heidi.
Die von dem...
Genau, die. Direkt von der Alm. Genau, das ist auch ganz nett eingepackt. Hier haben wir eine ganze Kiste voll mit kleinen Schoki, Vollmilch, schnickes Klem-Bim. Da waren auch noch ein paar kleinere Toblerone-Teile zwischendurch. Da musste ich allerdings ein paar auch schon an meinen Sohn opfern.
Das scheint eine totale Spezialität zu sein.
Ja, das einzige, was ich jetzt so vermisse, ist... Hier haben wir dunkle Schokolade. Das war das, was ich vermisst habe. Das gibt es aber auch. Naja, dann sind hier noch ein paar Gold-Barren. Nicht wahr? Das ist ja auch sehr angemessen, so bei der Schweiz. Das ist natürlich kein Gold, sondern eine Praline.
Das hab ich auch schon mal bekommen, ein Gold-Taler.
So, ja, und das ist es. Und was sagen wir dazu?
Danke, Mami.
Danke, sagen wir dazu. Ganz echt total nett, total süß.
Man merkt, dass er einen Sohn hat.
Wir werden danach auf jeden Fall...
Man merkt, dass er einen Sohn hat. Da sagt er auch mal, wie heißt es?
Naja, genau. Ich kann das hier auch einfach mal so ausschütten, so, ah, herrlich, dann müssen wir hier nicht die großen Kisten haben. Also ich würde sagen für die...
Omnomnom.
Genau.
Ich mach hier mal so einen großen.
Als nächstes sammeln wir dann bei den Hörern für unsere Zahnarztrechnung.
Wo ist das Fotoprogramm in 3.0 besser geworden, wenn man so live ein Foto macht?
Was ist denn da besser geworden?
Man hat dieses richtige Fotoprogramm. Wenn man im Programm, ich bin jetzt gerade im Twitter-Phone, wenn man da Schoki...
Weißt du, gibst oben Schoki ein und dann...
Und dann kommt unten Schoki raus. Nein, bei Programm hat man öfters die Möglichkeit...
Den Kamera-Picker.
Genau, den Kamera-Picker. Entweder ein Bild aus dem Fotoalbum zu nehmen oder ein Bild sofort aufzunehmen. Dieses Bild sofort aufzunehmen, hat man so ein Bild gehabt, oben so ein Rahmen und unten so einen schwarzen, überlegenden Rahmen und man konnte es nicht querstellen und so. Und jetzt sieht das eigentlich genauso aus wie dieses Foto-Programm.
Ich zeig das mal kurz, ich weiß jetzt überhaupt gar nicht, wovon du redest.
Wenn ich jetzt hier sage, mach mal Foto.
Ja, dann gehst du auf Kamera.
Dann sage ich Take Foto.
Ja, das war ja auch vorher schon so.
Und jetzt sieht das aus wie das Kamera-Programm.
Ja, wieso, wie war es denn vorher?
Und man kann es drehen. War das nicht vorher so, dass da irgendwie so ein... Wenn man in Programm auf...
Nee, das war schon immer so, mein Freund. Jetzt kommen wieder diese ganzen Sachen, wo man denkt so, oh ist das geil? Dabei war das schon immer so.
Das war schon immer so.
Und das war, glaube ich, definitiv schon immer so. Ich kann ja mal deinen Kanal ausschalten, Dennis. Ja, ich meine, damit haben wir dann sozusagen auch schon das erste Thema, ist ja wohl ganz klar. Und das Thema lautet unsere Erfahrung mit iPhone 3.0. Wir waren ja ganz brave Apple-Kunden und haben uns schon die Golden Master Raub kopiert und schon irgendwie eine Woche länger ausprobiert, damit wir jetzt hier auch genug Vorlauf haben.
Genau.
Das ist die Freiheit der Presse, würde ich sagen. Das ist einfach die Pressefreiheit, die nehmen wir uns.
Miran sind sie jetzt ja alle auch auf der Straße.
Gegeben bekommt man ja nur keine mehr. Da muss man sie sich halt einfach nehmen. Ich bin jetzt auch schon viel gereist und muss sagen, grundsätzlich finde ich, ist das einfach ein signifikanter Fortschritt, oder? Also es gibt so einige Funktionalitäten, wo ich jetzt schon wieder einen echten Schmerz hätte, wenn ich da zurückgehen müsste.
Also ich habe ja so ein altes 2G und ich finde da ist jetzt nicht so richtig doll viel Neues, aber so viele tausend Kleinigkeiten, dass es trotzdem Spaß macht.
Zum Beispiel? Was fällt dir denn als erstes auf?
Also was mir ganz am Anfang schon als erstes aufgefallen, und jetzt darf ich ja darüber reden, ich war ja eigentlich unter NDA als Developer, weil ich hatte die Dinge ja schon vorher, aber jetzt hatte ja jeder. Jedenfalls ganz am Anfang ist mir schon gleich aufgefallen, dass man SMS einzeln löschen kann.
Ja.
Vorher konnte man nur das gesamte Gespräch löschen, aber nicht einzelne SMS, wenn du halt so eine Unterhaltung hast, die auch über Tage immer so gehen kann, weil man das, ich bin so ein, ich heb immer alles auf, und wenn dann aber die Person auch mal anruft und du bist nicht rangegangen, dann kriegst du eine SMS, dass die Person angerufen hat, und das kommt dann halt mitten in deinem Dialog, und das sieht natürlich total scheiße aus und nervt, und die kannst du jetzt einzeln rauslöschen, zum Beispiel oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die du da nicht, vielleicht dann doch nicht dauerhaft gespeichert haben willst.
Ja, das funktioniert, das finde ich super.
Das funktioniert auch so ein bisschen mehr so, wie man sich das so denkt.
Habe ich aber noch nicht gebraucht bisher.
Nicht? Ich schon. Und muss auch sagen, das ist so auch wieder eins der Sachen, wo ich ja auch lange Zeit dachte, dass ich das jetzt nicht so wirklich vermisse, aber jetzt würde ich es schon vermissen. Also es hat mir dann zum Beispiel schnell ermöglicht, mal in meinen Notes ein bisschen aufzuräumen, weil man dann so Sachen, die man in zwei Notizen hat, dann doch vielleicht mal zusammenfassen will. Das geht einfach nicht anders als mit einem ordentlichen Copy und Paste. Vor allem mit einem Cut und Paste, ganz wichtig. Und naja, so Sachen wie Stream-URLs aus irgendwelchen Bereichen rauskopieren und dann woanders machen. Wobei...
Einen Mail, obwohl da kann man auch eigentlich gleich klicken oder nicht?
Ja, du kannst gleich klicken, aber du kannst halt nur dann klicken, wenn das eben auch wirklich eine URL ist, wo dann ein Schema drauf ist, wo dann auch das richtige Programm gestartet wird. Aber was weiß ich, wenn du jetzt so einen MMS-Link hast, ja so ein WMA-Streaming, den willst du dann irgendwo in so ein anderes Programm reinwerfen, also das ist schon ganz sinnvoll, dass das jetzt dabei ist.
Ich hatte das Musterbeispiel, ich musste ein Stück HTML-Code an jemanden verschicken, der hatte mich gefragt und ich war gerade im Zug. Und diesen HTML-Code musste ich von einer Website runterladen, wo ich aber das Passwort nicht hatte, das hatte ich aber in einer Mail und das hätte ich mir nicht merken können, also ich hab das Passwort kopiert, eingesetzt, mich eingeloggt, hab den HTML-Code kopiert und dann wieder in eine Mail reinkopiert und dann losgeschickt. Wäre vorher schlicht und ergreifend nicht möglich? Möglich gewesen. Also ich weiß, dass ich fast zwei Jahre ohne Copy and Paste ausgekommen bin, aber es ist jetzt schon ein bisschen die Frage, wie?
Ja, also das stimmt. Man kann einfach mehr Dinge tun, wofür man sonst ein Rechner gebraucht hätte und es macht einen einfach noch mal einen Zacken unabhängiger. Und ich finde, dass sie auch ansonsten so im Detail eine ganze Menge Sachen verbessert haben. Zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt im Safari ist und auf den Link draufklickt, dann konnte man ja derzeit so auf den Link draufklicken und den so halten, dann konnte man ihn halt sehen, ohne dass man ihn auslöse. Wenn man wissen wollte, wo was hin ist, wenn man das jetzt macht, draufdrückt, dann kommt halt dieser Dialog hoch, der einem erstens noch mal die URL als solche anzeigt, dann kann man sie halt auch einfach öffnen, aber man kann halt auch eine neue Seite aufmachen.
Oder kopieren.
Oder eben kopieren, wobei das jetzt auch so eine Art, das so eine Funktionalität ist, wie ich es mir auch schon eigentlich von Anfang an dachte, ja, dass man einfach bestimmte Elemente, und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das in Zukunft noch ein bisschen weitergeht, insbesondere bei so komplexen Objekten wie Bildern und noch komplexeren Objekten, die jetzt Bestandteil irgendwelcher Programme sind, sodass du halt wirklich click and hold machst und dann so ein Kontextmenü bekommst, und dass eben eine der Möglichkeiten in diesem Kontextmenü die Möglichkeit ist, ein Kopiervorgang ins Clipboard durchzuführen. Weil du kannst ja nicht immer, ist ja nicht immer alles nur Text.
Also ich finde es besonders schick, wie das, also das geht ja in, also bei Bildern geht das ja, mit diesem Click and Hold schon, sehr gut und bei SMS ja auch.
Also in den Bildern, das ging noch schon in den vorherigen Versionen.
Ja.
Kopieren? Nein.
Nein, kopieren halt nicht, jetzt kannst du es halt auch kopieren. Du kannst es halt sichern in deinen Dingsbums.
Was mir übrigens aufgefallen ist, wenn man ein Bild wirklich mal in hoher Qualität, also wenn man ein Bild sagt verschicken aus dem Fotoalbum, dann wird das ja, wird ja die Qualität runtergerechnet. Wenn man es mit Copy nimmt und in der Mail einsetzt, dann wird es nicht runtergerechnet. Dann hat man die volle Qualität. Kann man vielleicht manchmal gebrauchen. Wenn du ein Bild mit Copy and Paste, also gehst ins Fotoalbum rein, drückst ein bisschen auf das Bild, dann bis der Copy-Button kommt, dann klickst du drauf. Dann gehst du in den Mail rüber, nachst eine neue Mail auf, sagst da Paste, dann wird es nicht runtergerechnet.
Und wann wird es runtergerechnet?
Wenn ich jetzt hier einfach sage, wenn ich jetzt hier auf den Versenden-Button klicke, check.
Und dann auf Attach und dann auf Bild?
Und dann per E-Mail versenden, dann wird es runtergerechnet. Und wenn ich einfach nur hier lange drauf drücke und Kopieren auswähle, dann nimmt er die dicke Version. Dann nimmt er die dicke Version.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen, Gewinner und ich finde es auch, muss auch sagen, da war es wahrscheinlich sogar echt gut, dass sie sich da ein bisschen Zeit gelassen haben. Soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, war es einerseits nicht ihre Top-Priorität, weil sie hatten ja genug auch andere. Andererseits ist es natürlich jetzt auch schon eine signifikante Änderung in der Art und Weise, wie man so mit dem mit dem OS umgeht, weil wenn man jetzt in so einem Text-Editor ist, dann explizit Paste zu aktivieren, das passiert einem ja zwischendurch immer mal wieder, dass man irgendwie, was weiß ich, du willst halt positionieren, so mit Lupe und dann machst du doch irgendwie mal so ein Doppelklick und dann kriegst du halt dieses Menü, also dieses Copy und Paste, diese Menüdinger, diese Bubble-Action-Bubbles, die kommen ja schon einem immer mal wieder so auch dazwischen, auch wenn man jetzt eigentlich gerade gar nicht damit arbeiten wollte.
Die sind auch ein bisschen optimierungsfähig.
Ja genau, bzw. sind unter Umständen sogar schon gelungen, da einiges zu optimieren, dass es eben einfach nicht so nervt, weil das macht die Sache natürlich auch komplexer. Ja und wie ist denn das bei Android realisiert?
Ganz und gar furchtbar natürlich, wie sich das gehört. Also da ist, ob ich das jetzt überhaupt so auf Anhieb hinkriege.
Ich esse erstmal eine Toblerone.
Genau, ich gucke mir das mal an.
Die letzte kleine, danach müssen wir die große schlagen.
Zum einen gibt es dieses, also ein SMS-Programm zum Beispiel ist genauso wie auf dem iPhone, da hältst du eine Weile lang drauf, dann kommt da Nachrichtentext kopieren. Und jetzt gucken wir mal irgendwo in Notizen oder z.B. in der Mail. Ich mache mal eine neue Mail auf. Oder ich nehme mal eine bestehende Mail so. Kann sein, dass es schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht geht. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Ich suche, ich suche, ich suche, ich suche, ich hab noch nichts gefunden.
Oh, ich hab einen.
Angeblich gibt es ja 6 Millionen Leute, die das Update runtergeladen haben. Von aber irgendwie wie viel Millionen, die jetzt ein iPhone haben?
Was? 6 Millionen?
Achso, ich suche immer noch übrigens.
6 Millionen Downloads.
Das waren noch irgendwie 20 Millionen iPhone OS, davon waren irgendwie ein Drittel war iPod Touch, oder? Also so 13, 14 Millionen, sagen wir mal vielleicht inzwischen 15 oder so.
Ich hab kein blassen Schimmer, wie man hier aus einer...
Jungs, wir haben noch hier 2000 Hörer, die jetzt alle auf euch warten.
Genau und ich bin gerade noch am Gucken, wie man aus einem Medien-Text rauskopiert. Ich glaube gar nicht am besten. Gehen wir noch mal auf Spiegel, was die so sagen.
Push-Notifications.
Ups, viel zu wenig.
Entschuldigung, ich war gerade etwas abwesend, weil unser Stream nämlich gerade etwas abwesend war, weil ich hier ein Recording-Fail hatte.
Okay, ich hab hier kein Netz, aber es ist auf dem Android nicht halb so schön gelöst wie auf dem iPhone. Und es ist auch auf dem Panpre, wenn man das so durchlässt, wo man dann so mit einer orangenen Taste gedrückt haben und dann übers Glitch-Fail drüber gehen und so. Das klingt auch nicht so ganz nach dem Waren. Also ich find's beim iPhone eigentlich doch mittlerweile ziemlich gut gelöst. Gerade so das Absatz kopieren in Safari. Also wenn du nur einen kurzen Text auswählst, dann kannst du buchstabenweise ja selektieren. Aber wenn du dann irgendwie über die Absatzgrenze hinausgezockt hast, ach, der will da bestimmt einen ganzen Absatz kopieren.
Genau.
Passt ja auch in den meisten Fällen.
Ja, gut, aber wenn du da wirklich mal eine URL aus einem Absatz herausnehmen willst, im Safari, da wird es dann halt schwierig.
Ne, das geht auch. Solange du nicht den gesamten Absatz auswählst, sondern nur einen Teilbereich, geht das Problem los.
Ja, aber ich habe dann so gemerkt, dass es relativ schnell auf diesen ganzen Bereich expandiert. Also wenn du sozusagen einen Satz haben willst, der über einen Absatz hinausgeht, dann kannst du eben nur ganze Absätze machen. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach eine sinnvolle Ökonomie, nicht wirklich ein Problem. Also wir halten mal fest, Copy und Paste ist gelungen. Das ist jetzt glaube ich auch ein bisschen sinnlos, da jetzt viel Zeit zu mit vergeuden, weil es gibt ja andere Features, die eigentlich noch sehr viel pfiffiger sind.
Kleines Zufriedener-Detail, die Data-Detectors, sind die jemand aufgefallen?
Ehrlich gesagt sind die mir noch nicht aufgefallen. Jetzt wo du es sagst...
Ich hab mir heute mal eine Test-Mail geschickt mit verschiedenen formatierten Telefonnummern in allen erdenklichen Formatierungsstarten, wie sie mir eingefallen sind.
090?
Genau, 0900, alles. Und egal, in welchem Format ich die formatiert habe, er hat es immerhin gekriegt, dass mir die korrekt angezeigt worden ist.
Was kannst du dann damit machen?
Druftippen und dann anrufen.
Nee, nicht.
Zum Beispiel.
Kannst du click and hold machen und dann kannst du sagen...
Ah, jetzt kann ich auch eine Nachricht hinschicken, als neuen Kontakt erstellen, zu Kontakt hinzufügen.
Nachricht im Sinne von SMS. Das heißt, man merkt auch, dass er weiß, dass es eine Telefonnummer ist. Geht das eigentlich auch mit Kalendereinträgen? Hast du das auch probiert?
Mit Kalendereinträgen? Es soll noch mit Adressen gehen. Muss man mal gucken, ob es auch mit europäischen Adressen klappt. Hab ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht. Und ich hab es auch noch nicht mit Kalendereinträgen gemacht.
Ich hab das auch noch nicht ausprobiert. Das ist ein guter Hinweis.
Ich bin ja einmal da saß, eine Mail bekommen hatte, wo eine Telefonnummer drinne stand. Und dann das Problem hatte, ohne Kopier und Paste die hin und her zu kopieren.
Jetzt ist es sogar noch ein bisschen einfacher, weil er eben schon meint, zu glauben, zu wissen, was da am Start ist. Jaja, das ist echt prima. Für Kalendereinträge muss man das nochmal ausprobieren. Ist euch eigentlich, habt ihr eigentlich verstanden, das heißt ja, dass jetzt die Kalender auch Webkall unterstützen.
Ach, das hab ich noch kein bisschen ausprobiert.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt nicht mehr sünden, das iPhone mit meinem Rechner, um deine Einträge für unsere Podcasts zu kriegen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Ob der jetzt sozusagen, wenn ich auf meinem Rechner die habe, dass der die auch sünkt, hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Weil eine URL eingeben auf dem iPhone, wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Es sei denn, man klickt vielleicht auf so einen Webkall-Link. Hab ich auch noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber den Webkall-Link selbst kann man doch, aber den kann man doch raufsünken oder nicht. Weiß ich, ich mach das auf meinem Rechner, trage ich den ein, der wird dann rübergesüngt aus Telefon und ab dann holt er sich auch automatisch immer die Updates oder nicht.
Naja, keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt so ist. Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Sehen wir gleich, ich schieb nur gerade jetzt irgendwie meinen Backup wieder drauf, weil ich hab gerade mal einen 3.0 sauber draufgespielt, dann den Red Snow benutzt. Kommen wir später zu. Und schieb jetzt meinen Backup wieder drauf und müsste dann irgendwie ein iPhone ungeloggt, aber ohne Jailbreak haben. Weil ich will keinen Jailbreak.
Müssen wir nochmal ausprobieren.
Und ich mach gerade Krypto-Backup, hier ist voll toll. Und jetzt machen wir iTunes 8.2.
Wieso eigentlich nicht?
Ich mach nur legale Sachen.
Ich will auch keinen Jailbreak haben.
Du willst keinen Jailbreak haben?
Nee, ich will das OS so fahren, wie es von uns heiliges Steve geweiht ist.
Genau, das ist sonst entweiht.
Genau, ohne Transplantation.
Seit wann ist der Jailbreak jetzt da? Seit Sonnabend, oder?
Freitag.
Seit Freitag schon? Okay, ich hab einen Sonnabend installiert.
Also ein anderer Jailbreak, das ist Pornistuhl, war irgendwie Mittwoch oder Donnerstag schon da. Red Snow kam am Freitag.
Reden wir einfach gleich über die Jailbreaks. Also es gibt jetzt einen Jailbreak für 3.0. Für welche Geräte?
Na alle außer das ganz neue. Also fürs 3GS noch nicht.
Auch für den aktuellen iPod Touch?
Nee, dafür glaub ich auch nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht, ob sie das schon fertig haben. Das war Yellow Snow, ne? Yellow Snow ist glaub ich noch nicht so weit.
Und woran arbeiten sie noch? Ich hab irgendwas mit Ultra Snow gelesen. Red Snow hab ich jetzt noch nicht gelesen.
Ultra Snow ist der Unlock für die aktuelle Firmware-Version.
Es gibt ja für diese 3G.
Für das 3G gibt's zwar einen Jailbreak, aber es gibt ja, wenn man die neueste Firmware drauf hat, noch kein, also auch eine 221er oder so was, oder wenn man jetzt in den Laden gehen würde und sich ein Gerät kaufen, es gibt keinen Unlock dafür. Und Ultra Snow soll genau das machen. Ultra Snow ist der Unlock für 3.0. Der dann vermutlich sogar auf dem 3GS funktionieren wird, wenn der Jailbreak einfach wird.
Es ist der Unlock für das 3G.
Wer ist das Unlock für 3G?
Nicht für 3.0. Für das Telefon.
Es gibt einen Jailbreak für 3.0. Und dann gibt es jetzt einen Unlock für das 3G-iPhone. Und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das auch unter der anderen von den Usern funktioniert.
Das ist die Frage unabhängig von der Versionsnummer. Oder was ist der Unlock?
Naja, es ist ja immer beim Unlock, sie sind ja nicht so tief drin, wie sie im iPhone der ersten Generation drin waren, wo ja Apple mittlerweile machen kann, was sie wollen, sie wären das Team nicht mehr los, sind sie ja beim 3G-iPhone noch nicht so tief drin. Sondern da sind sie immer auf eine Sicherheitslücke innerhalb des Basebands angewiesen. Und mit anderen Worten, die Aussage von denen ist jetzt mit dem Baseband, was mit 3.0 ausgeliefert wird, dafür haben wir einen Unlock.
Beziehungsweise gibt's noch nicht, sondern ist angekündigt.
Das soll noch diese Woche kommen. Sie haben schon eine Demo gemacht und sagen, wir wollen das bloß noch mal testen. Und das ist auch vernünftig funktioniert alles. Und dann wirst du den kriegen, aber dann wird er kommen.
Hoffentlich. Naja, bin ich mal gespannt. Also ich meine, so ein Jailbreak, es gibt eine Funktionalität, die mich für dich interessieren würde. Und ich glaube, du hast vorhin schon angedeutet, dass das auch so ist, dass man Autorotation ausschalten kann.
Genau, da hat jemand vorhin noch, wer war das? Ich hab's dann sofort mal installiert. Also, es ist ein kleines Programm namens SB Settings. Das ist, wenn ich hier oben mit dem Finger so über die Status-Leiste drüber wische. Super-Waffel-Effekt.
Ihr seht das jetzt alle?
Ihr seht es jetzt alle. Jetzt habe ich zärtlich mein iPhone gestreichelt. Und es kommt davon so oben so eine Leiste runter, wo ich so ein paar Einstellungen mitmachen kann. Also, wo ich Bluetooth schön schnell einschalten kann, wo ich die Helligkeit wechseln kann ohne irgendwelche großen Umwege.
Immer überall, egal wo man ist oder was? Auch wenn ich mir gerade ein Video angucke?
Auch egal wo du gerade bist, klar. So, und da ist die kleine Klosebox dafür. Wi-Fi ein, SSH ein und aus. Und es gibt eben auch ein...
Ah, man kann Bluetooth...
Also es gibt da haufenweise Plugins für alles Mögliche.
Und das geht aus allen Programmen, wo man die Status-Bar sehen kann, ja?
Das geht aus allen Programmen, genau.
AutoCorrect, 3G an und aus.
Man kann das auch ziemlich...
SSH, den Server an und aus, ja? Und Rotation, on, off. Das heißt, er ist dann immer...
Im Hochkant-Modus.
Und man kann ihn aber nicht, sozusagen, überhaupt keinen Landscape-Modus mehr überhaupt jemals erzeugen, falls man ihn haben wollen würde.
Außer du schaltest den Button wieder an.
Aber dann hab ich immer nur Rotation. Oder ist es sozusagen, ich hab ihn in Landscape-Modus und dann schalt ich die Auto-Rotation aus und dann bleibt er auch da?
Ich hab's auch erst seit...
Das geht ja nicht, bestimmt nicht.
Ich hab's auch erst seit 10 Sekunden. Insofern probier ich jetzt einfach mal aus, was passiert.
Die fragen das dann halt nicht nach, ob er quer ist.
Jetzt bin ich so in dem Modus. Und jetzt mach ich's hochkant. Ah, da dreht er sich zurück.
Aber ist es jetzt an oder aus?
Jetzt hab ich Rotation ausgeschaltet, das heißt er bleibt immer in diesem Modus.
Also wenn man es ausschaltet, er kann sich schon zurückdrehen, wieder ein Portrait.
Aber nicht wieder hin.
Genau, also er bleibt im Portrait.
Ihr sollt einfach mal einfügen, dass man immer gefragt wird und dann wär alles prima.
Das hilft mir auch nicht weiter.
Für bestimmte Leute wär's cool.
Was ich haben will, ist eine Geste. Also ich möchte gerne eine Geste haben. Und zwar, was weiß ich, so mit zwei Fingern eine Kreisbewegung machen. Dass ich sozusagen einfach das Telefon nehme und als würde ich so eine Schraube in das Telefon reindrehen. Einmal so und dann soll es sich drehen. Weil manchmal will ich das Teil unbedingt im Quermodus haben und manchmal will ich es unbedingt im Hochgartenmodus haben, egal, wieso ich es halte. Und insofern ist iPhone OS 3.0 für mich eine echte Verschlechterung, weil zum Beispiel im iPod...
Ist das zitierfähig?
Was?
iPhone OS 3.0 ist eine echte Verschlechterung.
Natürlich ist das zitierfähig.
Insgesamt?
Wie ich schon sagte, insofern ist es für mich eine Verschlechterung, weil ich halt jetzt im iPod-Modus, wo vorher, wenn ich nämlich ein Video über Videos abgespielt habe, dann war das immer im Landscape-Modus. Und nur wenn ich es aus Podcasts herausgemacht habe, dann hatte es autorotiert. Jetzt rotiert es halt auch automatisch im Videos-Bereich, womit du dir einfach nichts mehr angucken kannst im Bett. In groß. Es sei denn, du musst halt wieder wie so ein Idiot da so liegen und das irgendwie so festhalten. Bitte was?
Bei mir macht das nicht.
Ach so, das hängt dann noch vom Content ab. Wenn es ein Movie ist, dann bleibt es glaube ich immer so. Und wenn du aber eine TV-Show hast, dann rotiert es. Das heißt, wenn du dir eine Fernsehserie anschauen willst, dann hast du irgendwie den Scheiß. Es ist auf jeden Fall unvorhersagbar, inkonsistent, nervig, nicht abschaltbar und überhaupt, dafür kommen sie in die Hölle. Also das geht einfach nicht. Und da erwarte ich auch noch Verbesserung. Steve, hast du es gehört? Steve, ich weiß, dass du wieder da bist.
Steve.
Er hat ja wahrscheinlich nur wegen uns eine neue Lever gebraucht.
Er ist wieder da. Ihr habt es gelesen. Heute gab es eine Pressemitteilung. Sie haben bekanntgegeben, dass sie 1.000.000 3GS-Telefone losgeworden sind.
Was sie letztes Jahr auch schon gemacht haben in den ersten drei Tagen. Aber letztes Jahr sind es halt in 22 Ländern gestartet. Dieses Jahr erst mal nur in 8, weil die anderen Länder ein bisschen später kommen.
29, 29 wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall weniger und...
Wie weniger?
Länder.
Also so gesehen eigentlich mehr verkaufte Telefone. Was eigentlich schon ein bisschen wundert, weil man könnte jetzt denken, jetzt haben sie vielleicht alle eins und so weiter, aber nee, ist nicht. Haben jetzt doch viele Leute noch gedacht, naja, warten wir mal, bis das Neue kommt, und dann schlagen wir zu.
Also die Zahlen, da muss ich sagen, da muss man erstmal mal gucken, was da wieder gefälscht wurde. Weil wie viel Prozent dieser Telefone gehen sowieso in den USA weg? Also ich denke, das war ein Großteil davon, diese Zahlen.
Ist schon klar, aber letztes Jahr haben sie ja auch geschummelt. So ist es ja nicht.
Meinst du, sie haben dieses Jahr einfach nicht ganz so viel schummeln müssen?
Nee, die schummeln jedes Jahr und deswegen kann man die Zahlen miteinander vergleichen, weil die alle sozusagen den gleichen Schummelanteil haben.
Okay, ich fand die Nachricht mit der Million hat mich jetzt nicht besonders in den Sand gelegt, weil entscheidend ist für mich auch nicht, wie viel am ersten Wochenende verkauft wird, sondern wie viel sie so in den ersten drei Monaten wegtickern. Und ich würde schon erwarten, dass das 3GS erfolgreicher ist als das 3G. Trotz dem, dass viele sozusagen schon eins haben und Upgrade-Möglichkeiten schwierig sind, blablabla, das übliche, denke ich mal, dass es trotzdem abgeht, insbesondere weil jetzt sie ein paar interessante Lücken geschlossen haben, die für manche Leute auch echt noch so ein Dealbreaker waren. Video, die bessere Kamera zum Beispiel, das war definitiv ein Grund, ein iPhone nicht zu kaufen, weil es halt eigentlich nicht getaugt hat. Und die Kamera, wenn ich jetzt die ersten Ergebnisse, also ich hab jetzt noch keine 3G S in der Hand gehabt, ihr?
Nee.
Genau, wir haben sozusagen eigentlich überhaupt gar keine Ahnung, aber ich hab mir natürlich diese ganzen Vergleichsdinger angeschaut und was halt sehr auffällig ist, ist der Speed, zum Beispiel das Webbrausen und Scrollen, doch deutlich verbessert. Dieser Effekt, wenn du schnell durchscrollst und das immer warten musst, bis du dann wieder...
Also alles mögliche, also OpenGL ist ja auch bis zu viermal schneller, berichten die Leute, und das ist noch nicht mal optimiert für dieses OpenGL 2.0.
Viermal schneller, ich hab doppelt so schnell.
Aber nur OpenGL Geschichten, weil der Graphic Chip ja nochmal einander ist.
Da hab ich doppelt so schnell gelesen.
Echt? Ne, da gibt's hier einen, der irgendwie so ein... Was hat der gemacht?
Gut, das hängt dann auch immer von den freiligen Tests ab, aber es ist definitiv alles schneller.
Und was jetzt auch neu raus ist, ist, dass halt auch Sinken ordentlich flotter ist. Also ich glaube hier bei F-Check irgendwie Dingens, der hat was geschrieben von 150 MB, die waren vorher irgendwie in 45 Sekunden gesüngt und jetzt geht das in 25 durch.
Also Sinken mit iTunes.
Also geht wesentlich schneller durch die Daten durch und schiebt es da rüber. Wahrscheinlich auch dieses Prepare Backup und weiß ich nicht, was der da alles macht, geht das alles ein bisschen flotter.
Ob das jetzt wiederum so viel von dem Prozessor abhängt?
Oder vom OS, aber dann wird es ja mit den alten Telefonen auch schneller gehen.
Also ich hab da noch keine richtigen Erfahrungen. Also mein erster Eindruck war, dass es ewig dauert, aber das kann halt auch einfach sein, dass das erste Backup einfach ewig dauert. Und seitdem ist mir jetzt auch wieder nichts besonders eingefallen. Also keine Ahnung, das will ich gar nicht bewerten.
Was ich ja doof finde, dass beim neuen iPhone an der Rückseite keinen Handschlag gemacht haben und das, wo die Rückseite ja vom alten auch schon echt eine Schwachstelle ist mit diesen ganzen Rissen und so was, die sich da bilden.
Eine Änderung.
Eine Änderung, genau. Dass sie da nichts gemacht haben.
Und den Plus.
Was war da jetzt falsch?
Weil das so gut einreißt hier mal und so schön klein.
Das ist deins auch eingerissen?
Meinst du es ist auch an mehreren Stellen eingerissen?
Echt? Ich hab da nie geguckt, ob es eingerissen ist.
Und entweder ist es beim Weißen schlimmer oder man sieht es einfach nur beim Weißen besser?
So eingerissen. Ach so, so ein richtiger fetter Spalt.
Naja, und hier oben so hier an den Kopfhörern eingängen und da wo der SIM-Card-Slot ist, da ist ein bisschen eingerissen und so.
Ah, tatsache.
Vielleicht ist das weiße Plastik einfach nicht so gut, weil Schwarze, da hört man die Berichte nicht so viel von.
Ja, aber vielleicht sieht man es beim Schwarzen auch nicht, weil da sammelt sich natürlich bevorzugt...
Doch, das würde doch mal aussehen.
Ich hab ja sowas nicht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Heißt jetzt aber auch nichts, aber man müsste jetzt mal so insgesamt die Statistiken kennen.
Also ich hab's auch schon bei Schwarzen gesehen.
Hier könnte es ein Riss sein, aber weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt noch ein Kratzer ist, aber es hält sich eigentlich in... in Grenzen, wenn du mal schauen möchtest.
Und von denen hört man auch schon wieder bei der neuesten Generation.
Gut, also, wir halten fest...
Na doch, hier hast du auch einen schönen.
Das Ding verkauft sich. Was aber jetzt sozusagen die eigentliche interessante Nachricht war, ist, dass in dieser Pressemitteilung His Holiness, His Stiefness persönlich zitiert wird. So nach dem Motto, ja wir gewinnen und überhaupt und danke.
Ach, es hat zitiert worden, das hab ich gar nicht...
Genau, er ist zitiert worden.
Ende Juni hat er gesagt, ist er fertig.
Ja, und jetzt kommt er wieder.
Unser großer Führer ist so...
Der muss halt auch mal updaten.
Ah, du meinst, jetzt macht er noch Backup noch eine Weile und dann geht er live?
Ja, bis die Batterie voll ist und dann ist er wieder da.
Ich denke, sie würden ihn da jetzt nicht reinschreiben, wenn wir ihn nicht demnächst wieder auf der Bühne sehen würden für irgendwas. Tja, jetzt geht sie wieder los, die Gerüchteküche. Was bedeutet das? Kommt morgen das Tablett? Ein Netbook?
Nee, jetzt müssen sie erstmal aus... Jetzt müssen sie erstmal den News für das 3GS auskosten. Man muss ja bedenken, dass irgendwie so die Vorortzeitung von so einem 5000-Seelen-Dorf, die berichten ja auch und die machen es aber erst in zwei, drei Wochen und es dauert ja eine Weile, bis irgendwie die Nachrichten alle durch sind. Und dann können sie wieder mit der nächsten Sache kommen.
Ja, also ich denke auch, dass wir dieses Jahr keine neuen Geräte mehr sehen werden. Sondern es wird einfach das kommen, was... Also wir werden aktualisierte Geräte sehen, aber wir werden keine neuen Geräte sehen. Wir werden iPod Touch, dritte Generation, mit demselben Professor...
Oh, wir haben aber schon öfter im Oktober mal was Neues vorgestellt, oder? Also vor Weihnachten, neue iPod.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass sie noch nie was Neues vorgestellt haben. Ich sag nur, ich erwarte in ihrer... Ich erwarte Modellpflege, aber ich erwarte keine neuen...
Komplett?
Irgendwas Neues. Also neu im Sinne von ein Gerät, was es so vorher noch nicht gab.
Ich denke mal, die werden wieder Neuerungen im iPod-Bereich im Oktober bringen oder so in dem Zeitraum. Aber vielleicht wieder nur... Vielleicht ist jetzt der Touch wieder mal ein Stück anders.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie keine Festplatten mehr verbauen.
Dass die Reihe oben rausfliegt.
Dass sie die Classics jetzt irgendwie droppen.
Obwohl es noch ein bisschen früh vielleicht.
Oder sie bauen halt einen mit Flash.
So groß, mit so viel Flash? Zu teuer.
I don't know. Da stecken wir nicht so drin.
Ich glaube, die großen bleiben noch ein bisschen. Aber die restlichen werden aufgewertet. Und beim Shuffle könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sie sich auch schon wieder was Neues haben einfallen lassen. Aber ist ja noch nicht so weit.
Bleiben wir dann noch mal ein bisschen beim OS 3.0 und bei den wirklich großen, wichtigen Features.
Was hat übrigens geklappt hier alles mit meinem Updaten? Alles wieder da, kein Jailbreak und ich kann telefonieren.
Also, womit ich schon jetzt gerade auch auf meiner Reise nochmal neue Bekanntschaft gemacht habe, ist diese Hotspot-Login-Feature. Und mir ist immer noch leider wenig Zeit gehabt, da mal ein bisschen hinterher zu recherchieren. Von daher ist mir noch so ein bisschen unklar, wie sie das eigentlich machen. Aber das iPhone OS 3.0 erkennt mit ziemlicher Sicherheit, wenn du an so einem Hotspot bist und beim ersten Zugriff aufs Web...
Ich überlege, ob ich dich jetzt schon auflaufen lasse?...
den Redirect bekommst. Wieso?
Mit der Eingabemaske, ne?
Ich hab gehört, dass das laut C-Mobile erst im September kommen soll.
Das was kommen soll?
Dieses Auto-Login.
Das ist nochmal was anderes.
Ich rede jetzt erstmal nicht von Auto-Login, sondern ich rede davon, dass das Telefon selber feststellt, dass es an einem WLAN-Hotspot ist. Du weißt doch, wie das ist. Man macht irgendwie einen URL-Redirect, und dann kriegt man so einen temporären Redirect, oder es gibt komische IP-Adressen oder beides. Also bei T-Mobile kriegst du so 1111-Adressen und so.
Du verbindest dich mit einem WLAN-Hotspot, und dann wirst du beim ersten Aufruf erstmal umgeleitet auf eine blöde Webseite, wo du deine Daten eingeben musst.
Genau, und das erkennt das iPhone. Woran kann ich dir jetzt nicht sicher sagen? Es mag da irgendwelche Konventionen geben und vielleicht auch mehr als eine. Was mich aber total umgehauen hat, ist, dass ich war in so einem kleinen Hotel, wo es noch nicht mal einen Fahrstuhl gab, in die zweite Etage.
Wow, in die zweite!
Oder auch in den ersten Stock.
In den ersten Stock, kein Fahrstuhl, unglaublich!
Naja, in einem Hotel ist das jetzt nicht unbedingt unüblich.
Es gab nur ein kleines Hotel.
Du, wenn du dicke Koffer hast und ein Kind an Bord, dann willst du einfach einen Fahrstuhl haben.
Wie, da ist so ein Page da?
Page, sowas hatten die da schon gar nicht. Ist doch auch nun wirklich völlig egal. Auf jeden Fall hatten sie da auch irgendeine komische Hotspot-Lösung, die ich noch nie gesehen habe. Und mein iPhone, nachdem ich diesen WLAN gejoint habe, kam einfach sofort mit diesem Screen hin. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du dich da anmeldest, geht nicht sozusagen einfach nur diese Webseite auf, sondern dann scrollt von unten nach oben noch mal so eine extra Pane hoch, wo er dann wirklich sagt, hier, ich weiß nicht, was drüber steht, Hotspot tralala, keine Ahnung, mit noch mal einem extra Abbruchfeld.
Sah die ungefähr so aus?
Und in dem, da das, genau, anmelden steht da. Genau, hier ist ein Screenshot bei FSCK-Log. Und dann hast du da sozusagen noch mal einen Browser über dem Browser. So ist das bei T-Mobile gewesen. Da hab ich einen richtigen Log-in-Screen bekommen. Also jetzt nicht eine Webseite, sondern hab ich leider keinen Screenshot gemacht in dem Moment. Aber ich könnte schwören, dass das Telefon mich nach einem Log-in gefragt hat.
Na ja, aber das kann ja auch daher kommen, dass dir einfach so eine alte Routerlösung kam, die das über einen HTTP-Login macht.
Ja eben, und das erkennt halt das iPhone und präsentiert das so, dass man da nicht irgendwie reinzoomen muss und erst mal die richtigen Log-in-Feels findet.
Es gibt eine HTTP-Passwort-Abfrage.
Das war das aber nicht. Das ist ein Hotel-Hotspot. Dumme Leute klicken da drauf. Das ist ein normaler Web-Redirect, der da erst mal stattfindet.
Und der findet statt auf einer anderen Seite und die macht eine HTTP-Passwort-Request.
Nein, die macht keine HTTP-Passwort-Request. Das sieht anders aus. Es war was anderes. Ich kann es dir nicht sagen, ich war so perplex in dem Moment und hatte auch keinen Login und war auch zu doof, da irgendwie einen Screenshot zu machen. Tatsache ist, ich denke, das OS hat ein oder mehrere Strategien. Bei T-Mobile ist es mir nicht gelungen, damit vorwärtszukommen. Ich hab dann mit Copy und Paste meine ewig langen Login und Passwort-Kredentials da irgendwie reingepastet. Und dieser Overlay ging nie weg.
Super.
Also totaler Fail eigentlich an der Stelle wieder. Und was hat die Telekom gesagt, dass sie das demnächst dann auch mal kompatibel machen?
Ja, irgendwann am September.
Na großartig. Ist ja nicht so, dass sich in keiner schon seit Monaten gesagt hätte. Hallo?
Ja.
Habt ihr auch gelesen, dass Apple irgendwie 30 Dollar-Gutscheine rausrückt, weil AT&T das mit Anmeldung verkackt hat?
Mit der Anmeldung von was?
Man konnte sich doch 48 Stunden lang nicht anmelden. Der Anmeldeserver war doch irgendwie total belastet.
Der Anmeldeserver, das war von Apple überlastet, oder?
Ja, der war von Apple.
Aber dass einige Geräte auch nach längerer Zeit noch nicht aktivierbar waren?
Aktivierbar, meine ich ja.
Jetzt gibt es Kohle zurück, oder was?
30 Dollar-Gutscheine.
Aber lass uns mal bei den Features bleiben.
Das ist total toll. Da müssen wir jetzt aber auch ein bisschen ausholen. Find ich.
Ausholen? Na dann holt mal aus. Ich lehne mich mal zu.
Hol mal aus.
Also, es gibt...
Ich werde so lange schockieren.
Genau. Ach so, hier gibt es übrigens auch noch...
Ach, die hast du schon geöffnet, ohne uns vorher, ja?
Ja, nee, die musste ich hier vorhin schon spenden. Aber ich hab den ja nicht gegessen. Aber ich mache jetzt hier nochmal die Ovo-Martine auf. Weil ich bin großer Freund von Ovo-Martine Schucki in allen Formen und Farben. Also, Tethering, im Volksmund auch Modem.
Wer ist eigentlich auf diesen Namen gekommen?
Tja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, das ist der Begriff, wie er im amerikanischen Telco-Bereich schon immer verwendet wurde. Bloß hat es der so noch nie hierher geschafft. Aber mit den iPhone News ist das sozusagen jetzt hier auch opportun. Ich betreibe jetzt mein iPhone auch auf Englisch, von daher weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, wie sie das übersetzt haben.
Das kann ich mal gucken.
Grundsätzlich muss ich feststellen, funktioniert das wunderbar. Wie machst du das per USB oder per Bluetooth? Sowohl als auch. Sowohl als auch. Also es funktioniert bei mir beides. Das kannst du auch einfach einschalten.
Das geht bei dem zweiten nicht.
Ach so, weil du ja überhaupt keinen UMTS hast. Genau.
Und über Edge machen sie das auch nicht.
Genau, sie machen es nicht. Und zwar deshalb nicht, weil sie nicht Telefone und Daten gleichzeitig machen können. Und das ist auch ein bisschen eklig.
Und das hast du schon probiert?
Ja, das kann GSM einfach nicht.
Hast du es schon probiert mit UMTS?
Ich mach das jetzt nur noch so.
Du surfst und kannst aber telefonieren.
Ach so. Ja, doch, doch, doch. Funktioniert. Und, ja, so. Wie hat Apple das jetzt gemacht? Weil es gibt ja einen entscheidenden Unterschied. Früher, also früher im Sinne von...
Nokia 6310.
Genau, Nokia, naja, weiß nicht, hat das 6310 schon Datenmodems Funktionalität gehabt. Gut, also alle Telefone eigentlich, die ich vor dem iPhone in der Hand hatte, machen es halt so, dass sie über PPP angesprochen werden wollen. Das heißt, sie sind im eigentlichen Sinne wirklich so ein Modem. Sie verhalten sich wie so ein normales Datenmodem, wie man das kannte.
So mit 14,4 oder 28,8. Und Modems hatten ja früher eine serielle. Und deswegen haben diese alten Handys, Telefone wie auch immer, haben per Bluetooth eine serielle an den Rechner weitergeleitet.
Genau.
Eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Genau. Da gibt es im Bluetooth-Standard entsprechende Protokolle, dass du da eben so Serialkommunikationen machen kannst und das ist alles ein bisschen eklig. Das führte dann schon häufig zu komischen Dialogscreens, wo man allen möglichen Scheiß eingeben kann und wenn man halt irgendwas falsch eingestellt hat, war sie dahin, deine Kommunikation.
Und es dauerte ewig, das Einwählen.
Ja klar, und zwar, wenn man sich mal klar macht, wie es funktioniert. Dein Rechner hat einen PPP-Client. Du musst dann für dieses Telefon die richtige Art von Bluetooth Serialkommunikation einrichten. Sozusagen so ein virtuelles Device in deinem OS. Dann, die PPP-Software muss dann dafür konfiguriert werden. Dann musst du noch einen Modem-Script einstellen, sodass du dann eben mit dieser Modem-Art richtig redest.
Die dann auch wirklich so per Dialogkommunikation. Ich schicke dir einen Befehl hin, warte drei Sekunden, ob ich dann eine Antwort habe.
Richtig elend, genau. Und vor allem das Absurde ist, was mir auch erst später klar geworden ist, dass dieser ganze Aufwand wird nur gemacht, um deinen Rechner mit dem Telefon zu verbinden. Es ist ja nicht so, dass du dich im Netz einwählst. Also wenn du damals deinen Modem an dem Computer hattest, dann ist ja der PPP-Server bei deinem Provider gewesen. Das heißt, du hast deinen Modem instruiert zu wählen und dann hat der über das Telefonnetz bei deinem Provider angerufen und dann hast du mit dem geredet und du hast dich dort eingeloggt.
Jetzt nochmal ganz kurz, man hat die AT-Befehle, hat man tatsächlich an sein Modem geschickt früher?
An das Telefon, ja.
Das tust du auch heute noch?
Jaja, naja, so. Dann hat man die AT-Befehle ans Telefon geschickt, dann hat das Telefon die Nummer gewählt und dann fing der PPP-Stack an, in deinem Computer an, über das Modem mit der anderen Seite zu sprechen.
Genau.
Und bei der Variante?
Beim Provider.
Beim Provider. Und bei der Variante ist es jetzt so, dass der PPP-Stack in meinem Rechner nur noch mit einem virtuellen PPP-Server in meinem Telefon kommuniziert?
Also, die Telefonnummer, die du anrufst, in diesem PPP-Dialog auf deinem Handy, Wie ist ja öfters auch einfach Internet oder sowas. Ist keine Telefonnummer, weil es gibt da keine Telefonnummer.
Das hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, es gab noch diese alte, dieses CS-irgendwas, da war es noch eine richtige Telefonnummer.
So weit wollte ich jetzt. Da hast du dann, okay, dünnes Eis, weiß ich nicht, damit habe ich keine Erfahrung. Ich will jetzt einfach nur beschreiben, wie sozusagen der Stand prä-iPhone war. Und das Ding ist, du wählst halt irgendeine bekloppte Stern 99-was-weis-ich-Nummer und das ist sozusagen für dieses Telefon eine Dummy-Nummer, die nicht wirklich irgendwo anruft und irgendeine Datenverbindung macht und darüber die AT-Kommandos rüberschaufelt, sondern du verbindest dich eigentlich mit so ein Proxy auf dem Telefon selber und die PPP-Verbindung ist nur dazu da, damit dein Rechner sich mit dem Telefon überhaupt erstmal auseinandersetzen kann und ihm sagen kann, was du willst. Und dann setzt das Telefon das eben um in das, was es sowieso kann, nämlich Datenpakete an deinen APN schicken und von dort gehen sie ins Internet. Also APN, der Access.
Also schon ganz schön von hinten.
Von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge und vor allem mit vielen, vielen Nachteilen gesegnet. Also erst diese unsinnige Komplexität, sodass du dann auch noch unterschiedliches Verhalten hast bei den Telefonen mit diesen Modem-Skripten und das, was man halt schon damals bei Modem immer so gab.
Jedes Modem brauchte sein eigenes Skript.
Ja, und komische Initialisierungsoptionen und diesen ganzen Kack. Dann dauert es halt ewig lange und dann vor allem keinerlei Kontext für diesen Link. Also ob dieses Telefon jetzt wirklich gerade eine Verbindung zu dem Netzwerk hat oder nicht, konnte über diese PPP-Leitungen so nicht abgebildet werden, sondern kamen dann entweder Daten oder sie kamen keine und irgendwann hat dann das Telefon beschlossen, hier geht es jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr weiter, jetzt baue ich diese PPP-Verbindung ab. So, wir spulen vor, 2009, das iPhone ist da.
Naja, also du willst jetzt auf Pan hinaus, oder?
Nicht nur auf Pan, sondern es ist in beiden Fällen, egal ob du das Telefon über USB oder über Bluetooth anschließt, ein anderes Konzept, es gibt kein PPP mehr, sondern in beiden Fällen wird eine Netzwerkschnittstelle bereitgestellt, die äquivalent ist zu den in deinem Rechner eingebauten Netzwerkschnittstellen, sprich dein normales Ethernet oder dein normales WLAN und genauso hast du, wenn du das iPhone anschließt oder dich mit Bluetooth connectest, eine äquivalente Schnittstelle. Wenn wir jetzt mal erstmal Bluetooth nehmen, bei Bluetooth ist es so, du musst halt dein iPhone, wenn du jetzt Tethering benutzen willst und wie wir das einschalten, da kommen wir gleich noch dazu, aber gehen wir jetzt erstmal davon aus, es ist sozusagen, die Funktionalität ist schon eingeschaltet auf dem iPhone. Dann machst du halt erstmal das typische Pairing. Du gehst in diesen Bluetooth-Assistenten, sagst, find mal ein Telefon, dann taucht das iPhone da auf und dann la la la, mit Nummer eingeben auf dem iPhone und dann sind die halt gepairt und dann kennen sie einander sozusagen über die Mac-Adresse, über die Bluetooth-Mac-Adresse.
So wie man das schon früher kannte.
Und dann hast du eben im Bluetooth-Menü, also wenn du da oben das Bluetooth-Menü einblendest, dann taucht dein Telefon unter den Devices auf, unter den Geräten in dem Bluetooth-Menü. Und du hast dafür dann eben so ein Kontext-Menü und das heißt Connect to Network. Das heißt, an der Stelle weiß der Rechner...
Das heißt, wobei da Tutor Phone steht, so heißt dein iPhone.
Genau. Mein iPhone als Tutor Phone. Und dann gibt's dafür nur genau eine Option in dieser Liste, nämlich Connect to Network bzw. Disconnect, wenn er gemacht ist. Das heißt, an der Stelle weiß er A, das ist ein Bluetooth Personal Area Network.
Das Ding kann mir Netz machen.
Das Ding kann mir Netz machen. Und in dem Moment, wo ich mich verbinde, ist das Äquivalent zu reinstecken von Ethernet-Kabel in deinen Rechner.
Und dieses Pan, wie es ja wohl heißt, das heißt, das könnte auch ein anderes Gerät sein. Das heißt, dass auch das OS, also Leopard in dem Fall, jetzt grundsätzlich mit allen Pan-Geräten sich von dem Netzwerk holen könnte.
Das geht vielleicht schon ein bisschen länger. Also ich hab bei Sony Ericsson-Telefonen geht dieses Pan schon ewig. Ich weiß nicht, ich hatte es glaube ich beim K800 damals.
Es ist halt erst bei Leopard eingebaut worden.
Das ist ja auch schon seit zwei Jahren. Nee, das war schon bei Tiger ziemlich sicher.
Der Pan-Support? Oder kam das mit irgendeinem 10-4 irgendwas ab?
Ich kenne so eine Webseite namens mobilemax.de, da habe ich mal nämlich über Pan mal einen langen Artikel geschrieben.
Ja, interessant.
Ewigkeiten und...
Schön, wenn es so interessante Webseiten gibt, wo so Sachen draufstehen. Ich bin mir jetzt auch gerade nicht mehr so sicher, ob es bei... Ich glaube, es kann auch sein, dass es bei Tiger irgendwann...
Okay, aber der kann sich dann da connecten und dann macht das Telefon halt über dieses Pan über Bluetooth relativ stromsparend.
Naja, vor allem was jetzt eigentlich passiert ist, in dem Moment, wo du dein Telefon mit dem Rechner perst, dann wird auf dem... in der Netzwerkkonfiguration von dem Mac ein neues Interface eingerichtet.
Verstehe.
Das heißt, als hättest du einen neuen Ethernet-Port, taucht in deiner Liste von Network-Settings einfach ein weiteres Interface auf.
Was bei dir Tutafone Pan heißt.
Das, was ich so genannt habe, ja. Das heißt dann erstmal bei Default, wenn du da jetzt nichts eingibst, dann würde das einfach nur Bluetooth heißen. Was ja für die meisten Leute dann ausreichend ist, aber ich wollte schon genau wissen, worum es jetzt hier geht. Und dasselbe auch über USB. Das heißt, du hast da im Prinzip wie eine Ethernet-Schnittstelle zwei weitere und zwar egal. Die taucht auch immer so als normale Ethernet-Schnittstelle auf, egal ob es USB oder Bluetooth ist. Genau, er ist nämlich irgendwie not connected. Das Bluetooth-Kabel ist nicht drin. Das ist lustig, ne?
Das heißt, da kann man sich auch noch so Sachen einstellen, wie ein Proxy oder einen anderen DNS-Server.
Genau, alles. Und vor allem, du kannst eben auch die Network-Order, also die Service-Order, noch mit einstellen. Komme ich gleich nochmal auf diesen Netzwerk-Dialog. Mit USB ist es ähnlich. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt mit deinem iPhone Internet haben willst, dann verbindest du dich entweder über Bluetooth, also machst einmal das Pairing, und im Rahmen dieser Konfiguration sagt das iPhone, hallo, ich stelle unter anderem diesen Dienst Netzwerk zur Verfügung. Genau, und in dem Moment legt er die neue Schnittstelle an, und dann kommt auch so ein Dialog hoch, der dich fragt, möchtest du das jetzt in deinen Netzwerk-Settings abspeichern? Und das möchtest du. Da muss man aber echt vorsichtig sein. Weil, gut, für die meisten Leute ist es kein Problem, weil die benutzen einfach automatic dieses Default-Setting, aber man kann ja verschiedene Location-Settings machen in diesem Netzwerk-Control-Panel. Und er haut das Teil halt da rein, was eben gerade aktuell ist. Das heißt, wenn du gerade irgendein anderes eingestellt hast, dann landet das da eben vielleicht nicht genauso drin.
Da ist immer noch ein bisschen Wirr mit diesem Location. Ich hab's noch nicht immer so ganz verstanden, wo man welches Interface hinschiebt. Man muss die echt verdoppeln und so weiter und so fort, ne? Na, hier diese... Okay, kann man die Hürde jetzt nicht sehen, aber wie du gerade schon sagtest, wenn du in einer falschen Location bist und du machst das mit dem iPhone, dann hast du es halt in einer falschen Location als zusätzliches Device, aber nicht in der anderen, wo du es eigentlich eventuell haben willst.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Ding, ne? Und dann musst du das nämlich auch unter Umständen nochmal nachschieben. So. Oh, jetzt hab ich hier... Hoffentlich ist jetzt nicht wieder der Stream weg irgendwie.
Ja, ist jetzt gerade am Netz rumgepuppelt. Hat da wieder nicht nachgedacht.
Hab mich von dir gerade verleiten lassen und...
Solange du nicht auf Apply klickst, passiert da gar nichts.
Also ich meine, ist immer noch da.
Okay.
So.
Womit mach ich weiter? Soll ich mal kurz was zu sagen zu diesem Netzwerksettingsfall? Das ist ja generell auch immer so ein bisschen so ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln.
Beim Fernsehring, was fehlt denn noch?
Einfach zu verstehen, wie das iPhone integriert ist. Dass es halt einfach eine Netzwerksschnittstelle ist, ist klar. Und es taucht halt in deinem Setting auf. Aber wenn du es eben in das falsche Setting reingeschmissen hast, was du normalerweise eigentlich nur in Ausnahmefällen benutzt, musst du unter Umständen nachträglich das Interface nochmal da rein konfigurieren über den Bluetooth-Pan. Also du sagst dann halt plus hier ein neues Interface.
Macht man es in anderen Locationen nochmal oder nicht? Macht man es in anderen Locationen einfach nochmal?
Ja genau, aber du machst das ja dann irgendwie nicht unter Umständen über deinen Bluetooth-Assistenten, mit dem du das vorher gemacht hast, mit dem du dann einmal discoverst und Pairing machst, weil das brauchst du ja in dem Sinne nicht nochmal machen. Aber du kannst halt dann einfach in die andere Location wechseln und sagst dann eben bei den Interfaces links unten klickst du auf dieses plus und dann kannst du eben so ein Bluetooth-Pan-Interface anlegen. So, warum ist das überhaupt alles wichtig hier mit diesem Interface? Was halt viele Leute nicht verstehen, ist, dass die Reihenfolge, in der die da drin stehen, relevant ist für wie so deine Kommunikation läuft. Nämlich das oberste in dieser, also da gibt es ja hier dieses Kontext-Menü, da kannst du hier die Service-Order setzen.
Ja, na das ist halt wichtig, wenn man zum Beispiel WLAN und Ethernet hat. Man hat ja bei sich zu Hause manchmal beides, hast halt Kabel drin und hast trotzdem auch WLAN. Dann willst du natürlich nicht, dass da für alle Hauptverbindungen, die du auch rausgehend machst, weil reinkommen tut sich über beide, kannst ja nicht bestimmen, über welches Interface es reinkommt, aber welches es rausgeht, ist ja schon wichtig. Dann willst du natürlich, dass das schnelle Ethernet benutzt wird. Und deswegen macht man es in der Priorität, das Ethernet nach oben und das WLAN da drunter.
Genau. Es sei denn, du hast irgendeinen besonderen Fall, dass du es genau nicht so haben willst. Dass du es genau so nicht haben willst, sondern dass für dich das Ethernet überhaupt gar kein Internet liefert, sondern du hast über das Internet wirklich nur ein lokales Netz, aber dein Default soll sozusagen das sein. Weil das ist nämlich auch das, was von Apple so nicht immer gesagt wird.
Ich finde, es haben es auch ein bisschen verschlechtert. Das war bei 10.3 oder 10.4 ein bisschen besser gelöst. Also optisch erstmal. Kann sein, dass es jetzt mächtiger ist oder so, aber vorher war es irgendwie ein bisschen übersichtlicher.
Sie haben es halt so ein bisschen aufgeräumt und Sie haben diese ganzen Advanced-Settings so ein bisschen verborgen da in diesem Advanced-Button. Ich glaube, das ist schon ganz sinnvoll. Du musst jetzt explizit dieses Kontextmenü mit der Service Order aufrufen, um die Service Order zu bestimmen. Du kannst direkt einfach in der Liste reinklicken und hoch- und runter schieben. Aber das haben wahrscheinlich viele Leute immer nicht verstanden. Und dann Accidentally da so ein bisschen Oh, I accidentally your network settings. Oh, the whole network settings. Und dann waren sie halt irgendwie braun. Und damit kann man sich halt schon einiges kaputt machen. Wo das zum Beispiel sehr wichtig ist, ist, wenn man eine VPN-Konfiguration hat.
Ja, die muss dann ganz nach oben.
Und die muss dann eben ganz nach oben, sodass, wenn die aktuell, also wenn die sozusagen... On ist.
Dann muss sie auch benutzt werden.
Dann schiebt die sich ja dann auch nochmal tot, dass sie dann sozusagen auch über deinen anderen Interfaces liegt. Und das ist ganz wichtig. Und ich hab das dann zuerst auch für das iPhone so gemacht. Ich hab gesagt, na, wenn ich Tethering habe, dann will ich auch... Also wenn ich das eh schon einschalte, dann ist das quasi auch so mein Default. Nur noch meine VPN-Sachen sind da drüber. So hab ich mir das dann irgendwie eingestellt. Da ist mir aber schnell ein Ei gelegt mit der Art und Weise, wie Apple halt jetzt das Tethering gemacht hat. Denn das Problem ist USB. Beim Bluetooth sagst du ja explizit, ich will jetzt Netz. Und dann connectest du dich und es ist gut.
Dann hast du dein Telefon geladen mit Bluetooth und dann hat er automatisch irgendwie natürlich das Telefonnetz genommen. Du hast es erstmal gar nicht gemerkt und hast schon stundenlang rumgeflucht, warum die Scheiße jetzt so langsam ist, stimmt's? Und dem Dreh.
Genau, du hast nämlich keine Möglichkeit, wenn du das iPhone ansteckst, das Tethering nicht zu benutzen, sondern wenn es konfiguriert ist und du schließt dein Telefon an und du hast halt 3G, dann geht er sofort in diesen Tethering-Modus.
Das ist total geil.
Das ist überhaupt nicht fies. Du bist unterwegs, steckst das Kabel ran und hast Netz. Das ist recht sagenhaft.
Ja, aber du bist unterwegs, hast eigentlich WLAN, steckst dein Kabel ran und dein WLAN ist nicht mehr so interessant.
Und deine ganzen Verbindungen sind im Arsch. Wieso unten?
Wenn man die Reihenfolge so lässt, wie es ist, ist doch alles beim Alten.
Nein.
Doch. Ich mach das jetzt mal?
Ja, wenn. Aber wenn du das halt sozusagen als Default gemacht hast.
Ja, man macht es nicht kaputt.
Aber dein Blutfluss ist doch ganz unten. Du hast es ja gar nicht oben in der Liste.
Wie ist das denn jetzt sogar rausgeflogen?
Wie dein Blutfluss.
Ja, ist es drinnen?
Nein, sein Pan ist ganz unten. Das ist gar nicht oben. Er hatte einen Airport hier ganz oben in der Liste. Dann wird natürlich weiter ein Airport als Default.
Genau. Ich hab's einfach alles so gelassen, wie es war.
Also ist kein großes Problem für Leute, die einfach nur Zack, Return machen, weil der Liste ist einfach unten.
Bumm, Zack, Return?
Genau.
Aber ich hatte das noch so aus meiner früheren Nutzung mit meinem Nokia. Da war es halt so, wenn ich damit verbunden bin, dann war das einfach mein Default-Mode. Deswegen hatte ich das ganz oben. Und was ich halt nicht bedacht habe, ist, wenn ich das iPhone ran mache, dass er eben dann sofort Tethering macht und dann hat er mir halt, obwohl ich darüber in dem Moment gar kein richtiges, ordentliches Netz bekommen hab, einfach meinen lokalen Traffic irgendwie weggehauen. Also das muss man einfach bedenken. So, jetzt ist natürlich die große Frage, wie kriegt man das eigentlich eingeschaltet? Das Tethering.
Also darf ich noch mal kurz sagen, meine rein lebenspraktische Erfahrung ist, ich setze mich irgendwo hin, stecke das Kabel rein, das USB-Kabel und habe auf der Stelle extrem schnelles Internet. Und zwar so schnelles, dass ich, als ich es zu Hause ausprobiert habe, mir am Anfang nicht mal glaubte, also wirklich noch der Meinung war, ich muss jetzt noch irgendwie übers WLAN verbunden sein, weil ich habe es vorher noch nicht erlebt, dass ich so eine schnelle Datenverbindung hatte über Mobilfunknetz.
Na was ist denn schnelles, sag doch mal.
Das waren 180 Kilobyte pro Sekunde, die ich als iPhone hatte.
Und mehr, also mit HSDPA.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, das war das, was ich bisher gesehen habe und das ist die Pinkseiten und sowas sind so kurz, dass du hast einen extrem schnellen Seitenaufbau. Ich hab jetzt keinen Stopp.
Du hast halt einfach das rausgeholt, was aus dem Netz rauszuholen ist. Du hast eben bei langsamen reiten Telefonen einfach nochmal eine Verlangsamung, dadurch, dass diese Telefone so langsam die Daten durchmachen.
Ich weiß, muss man sich mal überlegen, 180 Kilobyte, ja das ist, ich weiß gar nicht, wann ich mit DSL zu Hause angefangen hab. Haben wir mit einer oder mit zwei Ambit angefangen damals?
Mit 168 Kilobit pro Sekunde war das.
Ja ich glaube, ich bin eingestiegen, gab es dann schon ein Ambit, aber ein Ambit sind auch nur 128 Kilobyte, also Max. Das heißt, das ist jetzt schon schneller als irgendwie DSL von 2002 oder so?
Naja, du kriegst halt mit HSDPA 3,6 Megabit Brutto.
Das ist schon ganz schön krass schnell.
Ja und das ist krass schnell. Und mit dem neuen iPhone GS hast du halt auch doppelt HSDPA, das heißt, da kannst du theoretisch bis zu 7 Megabit kriegen. Brutto. Also wie viel da jetzt übrig bleibt. Aber du hast da unter Umständen einfach 400-500 Kilobyte pro Sekunde. Leider hat das 3GS ja keinen HS-UPA, also im Upload ist es lahm. Und das dürfte dann eben, wenn du das saturierst, auch schnell mal deinen Download bremsen, das alte Light mit steckenbleibenden Acknowledge-Paketen.
Und wie viel ist Upload?
Das ist halt die normale UMTS-Transferleistung und das sind dann so 46 Kilobyte pro Sekunde ungefähr. Ja, aber weißt du, wie das ist? Wenn du halt ein Upload machst, dann kannst du einfach nicht mehr deinen Download richtig nutzen. Das ist halt einfach bekloppt. Also genau die gleiche Beobachtung hab ich auch gemacht. Es ist einfach wirklich rasant. Und das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal cool. Aber ich würde gerne auch die Möglichkeit haben, das USB-Tessering auch auszuschalten. Weil ich kann ja immer noch über Bluetooth da rangehen, wenn ich will, sodass ich das sozusagen selektieren kann. Aber darauf haben sie irgendwie verzichtet. Das war jetzt irgendwie nicht so ihre Interesse.
Jetzt nützt aber noch erzählen, weil ich hab ja so eins der ersten Generation, ich hab das ja sowieso nicht. Aber ihr habt das Tessering ja schon, aber eigentlich dürftet ihr das ja auch nicht haben. Also wie habt ihr denn das hingekriegt, das zu haben? Weil der normale User da draußen, der irgendwie nicht an seinem Telefon rumbastelt, der hat das ja erstmal nicht. Weil die Telekom da extra Geld haben will. Muss man ja auch mal dazu sagen.
Also mit dem extra Geld, das ist echt nochmal so ein Ding. Lass mal das vielleicht erstmal raus und bleiben wir mal bei dem, wie es technisch funktioniert. Also die Funktionalität ist im iPhone OS 3.0 einfach da.
Wenn man ein UMTS-Telefon hat.
Wenn man ein UMTS-Telefon hat. Davon mal jetzt ausgegangen. Aber die Option, das einzuschalten, taucht so erstmal nicht auf. Weil es einfach bei Default so ist, dass du ein Profil hast, in dem drin steht, dass das nicht unterstützt wird. Profil heißt, es gibt so ein Provider-Setting, in dem dieser ganze Klimmbimm drin steht, wie heißt das Netz, was ist das Logo vom Netz, was für Features hat es, hat es die Voice-Mailbox und so weiter. Wie geht es mit e-Directed-Call, was ist die Webseite dazu?
Wie sind die Edge-Einstellungen?
Genau, und das sind diese IPCC-Dateien. Das ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als eine dicke, fette P-List, wie man sie im Mac OS überall findet, also so eine XML-Property-List. Und da stehen die ganzen Sachen drin. Wenn du jetzt von Apple das iPhone Configuration Utility runterletzt, und ich kann jetzt nur für die letzte Version sprechen, seit gestern gibt es irgendwie eine 2.0, da habe ich noch keine Gelegenheit gehabt, die zu testen, was sich da jetzt geändert hat, dann kannst du eben dir solche Profile auch selber machen. Du kannst die Profile sozusagen konfigurieren, tippst sie ein, abspeichern, kannst sie dann an dein Telefon mailen und da aktivieren.
Das mit dem Mail noch mal kurz, muss ich noch mal nachhaken, weil bisher war es ja so, dass man diese IPCC-Datei, also dieses Profile per iTunes, irgendwie so auf dein Telefon laden konnte, indem man beim Restore irgendwie Alt gedrückt hat, dann kommt wieder der Datei.
So wie man auch seine Firmware auswählen könnte.
Genau, und dann hat man die IPCC-Datei reingeschmissen und hochgeladen. Das geht wohl mit 8.2 nicht mehr, außer es gibt jetzt so ein Default, mit dem man das irgendwie wieder einschalten kann, dass es doch wieder geht. Aber das mit dem Mail-Senden ist noch mal ein anderer Weg, um die da drauf zu kriegen. Das heißt, das iPhone erkennt die IPCC-Datei und saugt die auf.
Du kannst es dir einfach per Mail zuschicken lassen. Also es gibt viele Möglichkeiten, das zu tun. Es gibt halt dieses Defaults-Kommando, da schreibst du Defaults write com.apple.iTunes, dann irgendwie Leerzeichen Carrier-Testing, Leerzeichen minus Bool, Leerzeichen tro. Und damit hast du das dann eben gesetzt. Und bei Windows gibt es auch irgendwie so ein komisches Setting, wo du dem iTunes einen Präf mitgibst und dann geht das auch. Also es lässt sich sowohl auf Mac als auch unter Windows mit iTunes 8.2 einschalten, dass man es so macht. Man kann es aber auch per Mail machen. Es gibt mittlerweile mehrere Webseiten, wo du dann eben das auch gleich ausfüllst und dir mit fertigen Settings schicken lassen kannst.
Man muss aber die Leute auch ein bisschen davor warnen, oder wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, wenn man da zum Beispiel die falsche APN eintritt, gerade bei T-Mobile kann es sein, dass man eine kostenpflichtige erwischt, richtig? Also man muss da schon ein bisschen lesen, was man da tut und nicht einfach blind jede nehmen.
Genau, genau. iphonenotes.de/mobile-configisteine von diesen Seiten, die so eine Webseite aufgesetzt haben, wo du im Prinzip deinen Provider auswählst. Da gibt es auch so mehrere Möglichkeiten, deswegen muss man da schon mal genau hinschauen und sicher sein, was man da auswählt.
Und Jungs, denkt dran, T-Mobile gibt es inzwischen nicht nur in Deutschland, also nehmt nicht die Mobile Amerika oder so, sondern den lokalen.
Ja, ich glaube, da waren eh nur jetzt für europäische Provider, ich glaube, es waren nur Deutschland, Österreich, Schweiz.
Mir passiert, dass ich für O2 immer halt einsuche und dann lande ich natürlich immer bei dem irischen, weil da gibt es ja auch O2. Das kann ich natürlich hier nicht gebrauchen.
Also was ich jetzt noch mal sagen wollte ist, mit dem iPhone Configuration Utility kannst du dieses Tethering nicht einschalten. Also zumindest jetzt, keine Ahnung, ob sich in der 2.0 irgendwas geändert hat, aber ich wäre überrascht.
Natürlich nicht, weil...
Klar, aber du kannst halt einfach in deinen P-List, Property-List-Editor reingehen und das einfach da reinbauen. ZB nutzt halt einfach die Dienstleistung von diesen Webseiten. So, und dann kriegst du das zugeschickt und dann ist das da. Dann kannst du das halt in deinen Netzwerk-Settings einschalten, sagst Tethering an und ab dem Moment funktioniert die Scheiße. Für Leute, die jetzt eh andere Netze benutzen, wie für mich mit O2, war das ohnehin mal Zeit, ich bin da irgendwie nie zugekommen, mir mal so eine IPCC-Datei einzuspielen, weil dadurch haben sich auch noch ein paar andere Sachen verbessert. Also, okay, der zeigt mir jetzt ein O2-Logo ein, wenn er eingeloggt ist, anstatt dass es da steht. Da hätte ich jetzt auch noch drauf verzichten können, spart ein bisschen Platz. Aber ich hatte auch noch so diese, der kam so mit den Rufweiterleitungs-Settings irgendwie immer durcheinander und wenn ich irgendwo angerufen habe, kam er hoch und hat mir gesagt, dass jetzt irgendwas weitergeleitet wurde und so.
Ja, das hab ich auch.
Genau, das ist damit dann weg.
Gibt's einen Jailbreak-Hack seitdem? Geh weg halt dafür.
Es geht auch ohne.
Es geht halt auch ohne Jailbreak. Ich will, ich will, ich will.
Gib mir, gib mir, gib mir.
Suche ich dir gleich raus. Es gibt irgendwie diese eine Webseite...
iphone.com.de/mobileconfig.
Okay, so war ich auch schon mal, glaube ich.
Das ist aber nicht die Seite, wo diese ganzen IPCC-Dateien...
Die haben mittlerweile auch eine ganze Latte.
Na, Max sucht mir das raus und du erzählst mir noch irgendwie weiter.
Okay. Wo waren wir denn eben?
Die haben schinesische Netzwerke mittlerweile drin.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was bedeutet das? Also erstmal ist mir nicht ganz klar, wie sie das jetzt eigentlich mit diesen Bezahlen machen wollten. Ich tippe mal.
Indem sie halt dann von Apple die IPCCs liefern, die die User brauchen. Weil jetzt, ihr hackt euch das ja alle zusammen.
Ja gut, aber was heißt liefern? Wenn ich jetzt einen Vertrag, also erstmal ist es ja sowieso, T-Mobile eiert hier mal wieder rum. Die haben irgendwie fünfmal ihre Webseite editiert, ob sie es jetzt anbieten oder nicht. Und letzter Stand ist, sie bieten es nicht an. Und sie haben mal wieder total Angst. Und für mich war also die vage Idee, dass ich vielleicht unter Umständen doch, um jetzt ein neues Telefon zu bekommen, dann doch vielleicht mal in so einen T-Mobile-Vertrag eingehe. Das habe ich dann gleich wieder verworfen, weil so eine Firma, die sich einfach noch nicht mal entscheiden kann, so und offensichtlich haben die ja auch wirklich bekloppte Vorstellungen. Vor allem, es ist ja so doof. Ich meine, bis vor kurzem haben sie mir noch eine zweite SIM bereitgestellt, die du in so einen USB-Stick reinsteckst und dann nutzt du auf demselben Datenkonto das. Und jetzt soll das auf einmal nicht gehen. Und vor allem, warum nur beim iPhone, bei allen anderen Telefonen, die sie verkaufen, gibt es diese Möglichkeit.
Wenn ich einen Vertrag über 200 Megabyte oder 1 Gigabyte im Monat habe, dann kann es denen doch eigentlich wurscht sein, wofür ich dieses Gigabyte draufgehe.
Ob man das nur mit seinem Telefon versurft oder mit dem Rechner, ist doch völlig egal. Das macht wirklich überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Und das ist wieder so ein weiterer Grund, warum man Telcos verachten sollte.
Aber gleich Zwischenfrage. Du hast jetzt hier so ein iPhone irgendwie aus dem Süden, nämlich aus Italien, wo das ja mit Unlock, also du hast das ja offiziell mit Unlock, nichts gejay-breakt und gar nichts richtig teuer bezahlt dafür, dass du irgendwie I'm a free man sagen kannst. Genau. Und so warum hast du jetzt noch kein Tethering?
Hab ich.
Offiziell? Ohne IPCC-File irgendwie dran rumzubuppen oder?
Na, weil das bei Default eben nicht freigeschaltet ist.
Aber du hast ja ein Unlock-Phone, warum ist das bei dir nicht freigeschaltet?
Das hat nichts mit dem Unlock zu tun.
Sollte aber eigentlich.
Sollte, sollte nicht, es ist so.
Du meinst, das gibt's eigentlich noch gar nirgends.
Was?
Tethering. Also das ist noch nirgends von Apple freigeschaltet. Also weder, also es gibt auch noch kein Phone.
Das weiß ich, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber meines Wissens sollten alle Telefone, die jetzt einfach nur ein 3.0-Update haben, out of the box keinerlei Tethering-Optionen bieten.
Ja, weil eigentlich, wenn's dann irgendwann mal kommt, solltest du das ja auch machen dürfen, ganz einfach so. Weil hast ja n Unlock-Telefon.
Das hat bei dem Lock gar nichts zu tun.
Warum nicht?
Das hat was damit zu tun, ob, ich weiß, dass das jetzt eine bekloppte Denke ist, aber so ist die Denke, ob du einen Vertrag hast, bei dem dein Provider es dir erlaubt, das zu tun.
Das weiß Apple in deinem Fall nicht.
Nein, und meine, ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wie sie diesen Gedankengang zu Ende führen, aber stell dir einfach vor, Apple sitzt da und da sitzen dann diese bekloppten Telekom-Hinies. Ja, die mit einem mitverdienen wollen, mit irgendwie Blah und Fase und mit dem Einschalten von Funktionen, die jeder für selbstverständlich erachtet und sie wollen dir auch noch Content verkaufen und sie wollen dir auch noch deinen Skype blockieren und so weiter. So, und warum hat Apple MMS eingeführt? Weil die Telcos gesagt haben, wir wollen das.
Wir wollen Geld verdienen.
Die User wollen das nicht. Sag ich jetzt mal so.
Weißt du, wie oft ich dich schon MMS jetzt verschickt habe in der einen Woche? Na? Dreimal.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Ist wahr.
Ist geil, oder?
Total geil.
Jetzt mit dem iPhone wird es jetzt nämlich erst mal endlich durchsetzen.
Okay, lass uns bei dem Tellering sagen. Die Frage ist ja, wie handeln sie das? Und meiner Meinung nach planen sie das so. Also angenommen, T-Mobile würde jetzt morgen sagen, oder AT&T in den USA, ja, ab jetzt auch Tethering. Kostet dich, keine Ahnung, 9,95 Euro pro Monat extra.
Aber dafür hast du auch 100 Megabyte Inklusive.
Ja, vielleicht noch mit irgendeinem anderen Inklusivvertrag. Das kann ja auch alles sein, dass dann sozusagen auch noch mehr...
Läuft doch nur 24 Monate.
Wie auch immer. Die Frage ist, wie schalten sie es dann auf deinem Telefon frei?
Ich nehme an, die schicken dir genau so eine Mail mit so einer Tethering, mit so einer IPCC-Datei zu.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie dir eine Mail schicken. Weil, es könnte auch sein, dass sie dir sowas MMS-mäßiges schicken.
Na, es gibt doch schon jetzt einen Unlock, den sie ein paar iTunes rüber schieben. Es ist doch, wenn du in der Schweiz ein iPhone kaufst.
Ja, aber warte, warte.
Das ist deswegen, weil die das auf ihrem Server irgendwo freischalten. Weil die Aktivierung geht ja schon übers Netz. Und die haben dann bei sich im Server eingetragen. So, das darf jetzt auch unlocken.
Warum sollen die nicht bei der E-Mail-Nummer genau das Gleiche haben? Dass wir dann einfach für dieses Gerät haben, wo die und die Tethering-Settings da liegen und du kriegst gar nichts davon mit.
Das kann auch sein.
Und hast plötzlich dein Tethering freigeschaltet.
Das kann auch sein. Also kann ich mir alles vorstellen, dass sie das mit MMS machen, dass da irgendwie einen Hidden-Feature gibt, dass man darüber die IPCC-Sachen übertragen kann. Es kann sein, dass sie dir eine Mail schicken und du da draufklicken musst. Und es kann sein, dass sie das über iTunes machen. iTunes wäre eigentlich The Apple Way to do it. Und da es eben diesen Backchannel, wie du schon richtig sagst, gibt, ist das auch durchaus vorstellbar.
Ja, dann kommt hier, wenn man sich jetzt hier so einen IPCC schicken lässt, dann kommt das so richtig schön, wenn man draufklickt. Also der erkennt das richtig und zeigt das in so einem richtigen schicken GUI an. Die Developer werden das so ein bisschen ähnlich kennen von ihren Install-Profiles und dann sieht das halt hier so aus.
Genau.
Und es steht knallrot unsigned daneben. Damit man auch weiß, dass man jetzt gerade was ganz, ganz Böses tut.
Verstehe. Und signiert gibt es ja was.
Na signiert ist dann von der Telekom irgendwie.
Ja, es kann sein, dass wir irgendwann auch wieder einen OS-Patch rausschicken und keine unsigniert mehr annehmen.
Ja, es kann auch sein, dass du irgendwie Spam kriegst und dann sind da Sachen drin mit einem anderen APN.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist schon... Man sollte nicht jedem IPCC trauen, was da kommt.
Das ist schon sehr sinnvoll, dass das geht. Aber wenn du weißt, dass du es dir selber geschickt hast, dann ist ja alles super. Naja, also so funktioniert das mit dem Tethering. Es funktioniert gut, es funktioniert sehr... Ne, es funktioniert nicht sehr zuverlässig, es funktioniert gut.
Wieso nicht sehr zuverlässig?
Ja, ich hab auch schon so meine Issues gehabt. Jetzt muss ich kurz mal ein bisschen über nachdenken. Also erstens ist es ein bisschen knifflig, wenn du Wackelnetz hast. Also wenn du an einer Stelle bist, wo permanent zwischen 3G und GSM hin und her geschaltet wird. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass dir halt das Tethering dann auch ausgeht, wenn du eben in GPRS zurückfällst. Wobei, und jetzt fehlt mir noch so ein bisschen Erfahrung, ich hatte den Eindruck, dass ich manchmal auch mit GPRS noch Netz bekommen hab. Und manchmal aber dann eben auch nicht, das ist jetzt so noch etwas schwierig wiederzugeben.
Da gibt's Leute im Chat, die sagen, sie haben schon Tethering, ohne dass sie da irgendwie rumfummeln mussten.
Mit einem neu gekauften Gerät oder geupdateten?
Bist du da sicher, dass es bei dir dadurch einen Unlock hast, dass es nicht schon einfach so gegangen wäre?
Es ging nicht, der Menü-Eintrag war nicht vorhanden.
Es war einfach nicht vorhanden, sonst hätte ich die Aktion nicht machen müssen.
Also wir haben ja sogar am Anfang, da gab's ja diese Website noch nicht, da hab ich noch irgendwo eine iTunes 8.2 Beta aufgetrieben.
Hier beschwert sich einer im Chat. Mobile Max, guckt mal in den Chat. Wenn ihr wollt, dass wir auf den Chat reagieren, dann müsst ihr uns ansprechen, Leute. In den Prittlauf, Doppelpunkt, ihr kennt das doch.
Dann sagt es nämlich, das Kolokweih, so ein Riesenfenster. Und es klingelt.
Wir können ja nicht die ganze Zeit mitlesen, während wir reden.
Pass auf, jetzt klingelt es nur noch. Okay, weiter.
Ping, ping, ping. Ja, wenn ich zu viel angeschrieben wäre, dann machen wir den Chat aus.
Wie bei so einem Flipper.
Jetzt sagt einer irgendwie, dass er es nicht hatte. Jetzt sagt einer, dass er es hat. Kann ja sein. Also, your mileage may vary. So war es bei uns. Und wie auch immer, wenn es da ist, ist ja alles gut. Wenn es nicht da ist, könnt ihr das mit dem IPCC freischalten. Und alles wird gut.
Also ich würde ja erwarten, dass wenn ich mir ein Unlock-Telefon kaufe, dass natürlich das Tethering schon sofort geht. Weil Apple meinen Provider ja nicht kennt. Und mir das grundsätzlich dann erlauben kann. Weil das ist ja mein Problem.
Kann sein, kann nicht sein. I don't know.
Würde ich, fände ich auch toll, wenn das so ginge. Geht aber offensichtlich nicht.
Ja, ist ganz schön schwach. Weil ich will mir ja demnächst neue holen. Ich hab auch schon Connections.
Ich hab auch Instabilitäten gehabt. Also ich musste mein Telefon dann auch nach kräftiger Nutzung und hin und her und anstöpseln und abstöpseln und anstöpseln und abstöpseln. Irgendwann hatte ich auch so ein bisschen Fuba. Und es war mal wieder Reboot tut gut angesagt. Weil sich das Tethering einfach nicht wieder einschalten wollte. Also obwohl ich den dann über USB rankonektet hat, ist er dann einfach nicht in den Tethering-Modus gegangen. Und nach dem nächsten Reboot hat er das dann wieder getan. Auch das mag... Also ich wäre ehrlich gesagt nicht sehr überrascht, wenn wir noch innerhalb der ersten vier Wochen ein Update sehen für die Software.
Nächste Woche.
Also da ist definitiv...
Ich glaube, es kommt nächste Woche.
Warum?
Ich glaube, letztes Jahr kam das Update auch relativ schnell, die 2.0.1. Und da ja der Gold Master, der gibt's ja schon seit der WWDC, also seit dem 9.6., das ist jetzt auch schon wieder... Wie viel? Über zwei Wochen ja, drei. Einfach zwei Wochen. Glaube ich, dass die schon nächste Woche gleich irgendeinen Update hinterher schieben. Weil die haben sozusagen schon bei der Gold Master-Phase mit den Developern bestimmt schon eine Menge Wachse gefunden. Finden jetzt gerade irgendwie noch ein paar mehr, diese irgendwie schnell hot fixen. Und dann kommt irgendwie, würde ich mal sagen, Ende nächster Woche, Anfang der Woche danach kommt irgendwie ein Update. Kleines.
Glauben heißt nicht wissen. Wir werden es sehen, aber es gibt definitiv Bugs in diesem System und da ist auch noch einiges zu holen. Ja, jetzt muss ich mal kurz mal schauen.
Was ich sehr lustig von dem Tesla Ring, ich saß irgendwo im Café, wo es keinen WLAN gab, was ich mir extra rausgesucht habe, endlich mein Café ohne WLAN, weil man kann es ja auch mal ausprobieren.
Und außerdem will man mal seine Ruhe haben, die ganzen Leute haben das Netzplatt machen.
Genau, vor allem diese Leute, die immer mit ihren Computern da rumsitzen und die ganze Zeit, nee. Und ich saß da so rum und hab meinen Kaffee geschlürft und hab da bei meinem MP3-Stream gehört und RSS-Feed gelesen, hab irgendwo von einem tollen Programm gelesen auf dem iPhone, geh auf dem iPhone in den App-Store, will das runterladen, erklärt er mir, dass ich eine 10 Megabyte-Grenze hätte und dass das Programm zu groß wäre zum runterladen. Ich glaube, während ich allein diesen Dialog gelesen habe, sind wahrscheinlich mehr als 10 Megabyte durchgegangen. Also bin ich rüber auf dem Desktop in iTunes, hab mir da das Programm runtergeladen und dann rübergespielt und danach ging's dann.
Ja, das ist so albern. Das reicht ja jetzt auch mit Podcasts. Du schließt deinen Rechner an und über dasselbe iPhone kannst du was runterladen, wo dir das iPhone sagt, das geht nicht. Und das verstehe ich auch nicht. Das war ja auch in den Developer-Versionen diese Beschränkung mit den 10 Megabyte, da war es weg und jetzt ist es wieder da.
Wahrscheinlich ist das noch eine IPCC-Einstellung.
Das wäre schön. Ich würde ganz gerne auch nochmal für das ganze Podcasting eine Einstellung haben, aber dazu kommen wir noch.
Das ist der nächste Rand, die Leute warten schon.
Ja, da werde ich nochmal richtig giftig. Aber es gibt ja auch noch gute Nachrichten. Soll ich die auch nochmal berichten?
Da hätte ich mir noch nicht vorstellen, was sollte das wohl sein?
Gute Nachrichten?
Ja, die liegen hier auf meinem Tisch. Ich habe mir nämlich einen Nokia gekauft. Bluetooth-Kopfhörer. Genau. Also ich sage es gleich dazu. Ich kann mir bessere Kopfhörer vorstellen als dieses Teil, aber das ist zumindest schon mal erträglich.
Haben die ein Mikro drinne?
Ja. Es handelt sich hierbei um das Nokia BH604.
Sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie ein BH.
Es sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie ein BH. Und es handelt sich hierbei um ein Bluetooth-Headset und Headphone. Das heißt, es unterstützt sowohl das Headset-Profil als auch das Headphone-Profil. Sprich Stichwort A2DP, Stereo, Audio in guter Qualität über Bluetooth. Zusätzlich zu dem, was schon seit langer Zeit geht, nämlich Bluetooth-Headsets, wie wir das seit Jahr und Tag von Handys kennen.
Also vernünftige Musik drüber und telefonierend drüber.
Genau, das heißt, hier ist auch ein Mikrofon drin und du kannst das Ding einfach als Telefon-Headset benutzen, aber du kannst eben auch gleichzeitig ordentlich Sound hören. Und das Teil gibt es irgendwie bei Amazon für knapp 90 Euro.
Ist schon Geld.
Ist schon Geld, aber es ist ein geschlossener Kopfhörer, also nicht das ausgesprochen geschlossener Kopfhörer, aber so einer, der um deine Ohren herumgeht. Sowas liegt mir sowieso. Sieht so ein bisschen hörnchenmäßig aus und hat auch noch so ein etwas albernes Plastesilber. Man kann die Teile hier unten, die Ohrmuscheln, kann man noch so ein bisschen quer drehen, sodass du die relativ elegant in so eine Tasche noch mit reingeschoben bekommst. Du kannst sie nicht wirklich zusammenklappen, wie das bei manchen geht, aber zumindest sind sie flach und das tut es schon mal so weit. Das Teil hat jetzt an der rechten Ohrmuschel 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Bedienungselemente plus ein Ladekabel, das ist so ein Mini-Stecker. Ich vermute, dass das dasselbe ist wie bei den neuen Nokia-Telefonen mit dem dünnen Stecker, dass sie sich da hoffentlich nichts Neues haben einfallen lassen. Sprich, es müsste auch die Möglichkeit geben, das Ding über USB zu laden, habe ich aber noch nicht gemacht. Lädt relativ schnell, also schließt es an und zwar in Windeseile, habe ich jetzt nicht gestoppt, aber es war relativ fix geladen und hält dann auch sehr lange. Ich habe das auch im Dauertest gehabt, im Zug.
Wie lange ist denn sehr lange?
12 Stunden oder so.
Also sollte für einen Tag reichen oder zwei?
Genau, sollte für einen Tag reichen und das ist schon mal ganz prima. Es gibt jetzt hier eine Taste, die auch so für Telefon annehmen gedacht ist, das heißt, wenn du einen Anruf kriegst und dann drückst du die, dann nimmst du halt an.
Funktionieren die alle auch so?
Die eine, die funktioniert.
Am iPhone auch, wir reden jetzt hier vom iPhone.
Jaja, ich rede jetzt nur vom iPhone. Also das ist ja ein standardisiertes Profil. Das hängt dann, wenn ein Telefon nicht funktioniert, dann funktioniert es halt nicht. Aber mit dem iPhone unter OS 3.0 habe ich das jetzt halt getestet.
Play-Pause-Taste, funktionieren die?
Ja, die Play-Pause-Taste funktioniert. Das heißt, du hast das Ding auf, du hörst Musik, du willst mal keine Musik hören, willst auf Stopp drücken, drückst du einfach rechts mit deiner Hand ans Ohr, machst Klick, bleibt stehen, klick, mit so einem Mini-Delay, kommt's hin. Soweit, alles gut. Die Vorwärts- und Rückwärts-Tasten, die da noch dran sind, die funktionieren über ein anderes Protokoll, was nicht durch A2DP abgedeckt ist. Das ist irgendwie das H-AV-RCD, irgendwie Audio-Video-Remote-Control-Tralala-Protokoll.
Macht Apfel nicht und deswegen geht das nicht.
Ist derzeit im iPhone nicht drin. Das heißt, die Vor- und Rückwärts-Tasten funktionieren nicht, da reagiert er einfach nicht drauf. Das wäre halt nochmal ganz gut, wenn du einen Podcast hörst mit Chapters, kannst du auch ohne ans Gerät ranzumüssen vor zurückspulen. Was ich noch viel lieber hätte, ist diese 30-Sekunden-zurückspringen-Taste, die jetzt im Podcast-Interface dabei ist. Die wäre eigentlich auch nochmal ganz prima, aber das ist natürlich so nicht zu machen.
Lauter leiser geht das?
Lauter leiser geht das. Bei dem Teil ist das unten so ein Schieberegler. Na ja, okay, schieb sie in eine Richtung, das ist ein bisschen lauter. Das ist nicht sehr filigran. Da hast du das Gefühl, dass du da vielleicht bestenfalls acht verschiedene Lautstärke-Stufen hast. Aber es passt schon irgendwie. Du kriegst das damit ausgeglichen. Ein bisschen nervig ist das immer, wenn du ans Minimum und ans Maximum gekommen bist, dass er kurz Piep macht und während dieses Pieps auch dein Audio suppresst. So eine eklige Pause.
Kriegt man ja nicht von alleine mit, dass es jetzt nicht mehr lauter wird.
Ja, eben. Ich meine, sie hätten den Piep ja machen können und trotzdem noch abspielen können. Wie das Mikrofon ist, kann ich noch nicht so richtig sagen, weil es war für mich immer etwas verwirrend. Ich hab nämlich am Anfang überhaupt nicht damit gerechnet, dass ich damit auch telefonieren kann.
Du hast das einfach abgesetzt und hast dann das...
Ich hab mich einfach auf andere Sachen konzentriert und wurde dann auf einmal angerufen. Und das hat mich dann irgendwie verwirrt, zumal der Klingelton dann auch noch irgendwie anders ist. Ich hab nicht den eigentlichen Klingelton, sondern irgendwie einen anderen gehabt. Und dann war ich so dermaßen durcheinander. Und du kannst dann halt auf dem iPhone auch sagen, womit du es annehmen willst. Ob du es sozusagen jetzt mit deinem Headset annehmen willst oder mit Lautsprecher oder eben mit dem eingebauten, also mit dem normalen Ohrmuschel annehmen willst. Und da ich in dem Moment so überrascht war und größeres Interesse daran hatte, das Gespräch überhaupt anzunehmen, hab ich in dem Moment das vielleicht jetzt nicht drauf ankommen lassen. Aber es hat schon irgendwie auch funktioniert. Ich hab auch mit dem Teil telefoniert. Bloß dann sagten die Leute, sie können mich nicht hören. Dann wusste ich nicht, ob das jetzt mit dem Mikrofon ordentlich funktioniert und ich wollte einfach telefonieren. Also hab ich noch nicht so viel Zeit gehabt, das wirklich zu testen.
Kriegt man das Ding auch an Mac dran? Ja.
Das heißt, du kannst das auch, das ist bei Leopard, ist A2DP-Support mit drin. Das heißt, wie du vorher dein Telefon über Bluetooth gepährt hast, kannst du auch den Kopfhörer damit pären. Und kannst halt mit ein bisschen Delay auch ganz prima an deinem Rechner sozusagen den Sound-Wireless übertragen. Und das ist schon echt ziemlich cool. Es taugt nicht so richtig für Audio-Schneiden. Ich hab da irgendwie so Podcasts damit geschnitten, das ist natürlich immer ein bisschen doof, weil natürlich die Linie, wo er da gerade irgendwie über dein Audio rübergeht, über die Ölkurve, ist immer schon ein bisschen davor. Aber wenn man das berücksichtigt, geht das auch. Aber eigentlich will man da schon lieber Kabel haben. Aber so für den normalen Audio-Konsum ist das prima. Knifflig wird es jetzt allerdings, wenn du dein Headset sowohl mit deinem Computer als auch mit dem Telefon gepährt hast. Weil hier fehlt dem iPhone noch ein wichtiges Feature. Du pärst das Teil ja auch. Und wenn ich jetzt... Ich versuch's gleich mal ganz praktisch zu erläutern. Ich hab jetzt mein Telefon an, die beiden sind schon mal gepährt. Das heißt, mein iPhone weiß, dieses Gerät gibt es. Wenn ich das jetzt einschalte, da drück ich hier langsam eine Weile auf diese Telefontaste, dann geht das Headphone an und macht kurz irgendwie Piep. Da ist hier irgendwie so eine Lampe, die leuchtet grün, blinkt dann irgendwie grün und ab und zu dann mal ein bisschen blau. Und bei meinem iPhone ist, wenn Bluetooth eingeschaltet ist, das Bluetooth-Symbol oben in der Menüleiste aber grau. Und jetzt, wo das Headphone angeschaltet ist, sollte es das Ding irgendwann sehen und automatisch zuschalten, wobei ich jetzt vorführeffekt unter Umständen gerade das Ding, weil ich davon mit rumexprimiert habe, wieder disconnected habe. Wenn du das sozusagen explizit herbeiführen willst, musst du eben in die Settings gehen, hier allgemein, in den Bluetooth-Bereich, da taucht dann das Teil eben auf, dann drückst du dann nochmal drauf und sagst verbinden, und dann versucht es, dich eben damit zu verbinden und sagt dann eben verbunden. Das heißt, wenn es nicht verbunden ist, kannst du vom iPhone sagen, sei verbunden. Aber du kannst es nicht rückgängig machen. Du kannst jetzt hier nicht nochmal draufklicken und es wieder entbinden. Das heißt, die einzige Möglichkeit jetzt, während mein Telefon mit eingeschalteten Bluetooth hier rumliegt, mit meinem Headset an den Rechner zu gehen und da das zu hören, was der Rechner sendet, muss ich hier entweder das Pairing komplett entfernen oder Bluetooth ausschalten. Wobei du natürlich, wo ich dann am Anfang sagte, ich bin ja ganz klug, da mach ich hier einfach Airplane-Modus an und dann ist natürlich auch noch dein 3G weg und wenn du gerade Tethering gemacht hast, ist das irgendwie doppelt bekloppt. Also das ist irgendwie alles noch ein bisschen blöd. Du musst halt dein ganzes Bluetooth ausschalten und haust ja unter Umständen dein Tethering damit weg. Weil Bluetooth ausschalten halt auch die Verbindung zum Rechner kap. Du kannst nicht einem einzelnen Gerät sagen, sei jetzt nicht mehr verbunden. Du kannst nur sagen, dieses Gerät ignorieren in diesem Kontextmenü.
Oder du kannst halt das Pairing lösen, das ist auch blöd.
Aber ignorieren heißt, dann lösche du nämlich das Pairing. Ignorieren heißt Pairing ist weg.
Ich würde ganz kurz mal gerne eine kleine Service-Durchsage machen. Und zwar der MS-Pro hat noch nicht sein iPhone runtergeschmissen, hat dabei das Display kaputt gemacht. Hat sich ein neues Display besorgt. Und lässt das jetzt gerade von Roddy einbauen. Und die sitzen jetzt gerade im Café Schmück und brauchen dringend doppelseitiges Klebeband. Also wenn jemand mal ein komplett zerlegtes iPhone sehen will und gleichzeitig eine helfende Hand geben will, einfach im Café Schmück mit doppelseitigem Klebeband aufschlagen.
Du findest immer wieder Wege hier, um irgendwie das Thema komplett auf Sachen abzulenken, die eigentlich überhaupt nichts mit unserem Podcast zu tun haben. Jetzt haben die Leute sich gerade so schön da drauf gemacht, ich schneide das raus.
Ja, kannst du ja machen, ist ja okay, dann ist es eh vorbei.
Das schneide ich raus.
So, ist eh nur für die Live-Hörer interessant. Genau. Aber dann war noch, weil ich habe ja wieder nur das alte Telefon, erste Generation, da geht es mit dem Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, das geht zwar schon, aber der schickt das über ein anderes Profil, die Musik, das ist dann wirklich nur Mono oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Weil ich kann ja zum Beispiel von meinem TomTom, da ist ja auch ein Headset dabei, das kann ich ja schon auch verbinden mit meinem iPhone.
Headset-Profil geht, aber ich glaube A2DP geht mit deiner Bluetooth-Variante noch nicht. Also der Bluetooth-Stein, der in dem ursprünglichen Telefon ist, der kann doch kein A2DP, oder?
Das heißt, wenn wir das jetzt connecten würden, was würde dann passieren? Der findet es gar nicht oder das ist andere Qualität?
Kannst ja einfach mal perren damit.
Ja, können wir mal probieren hier schnell. Aber ich glaube, es gibt schon eine ganze Menge Leute, die noch ein altes iPhone haben, oder?
Sicher, aber ich glaube 3G-Privails mittlerweile. Also ich habe ja noch mehr Erfahrungen damit gesammelt. Da ich ja irgendwie Heavy-User bin, ach so, weil der nicht im Pairing-Modus ist. Da muss man ihn irgendwie hier nochmal ausschalten.
Lange drücken und dann fängt wahrscheinlich Grün-Blau an zu blinken, oder?
So, jetzt ist er erstmal aus und jetzt muss ich vom Aus-Modus wieder anmachen, genau. Erstmal so lange, dass er sich einschaltet. Das war wohl zu früh, nochmal. Genau, und dann gedrückt halten eine Weile und dann geht er irgendwann in diesen Pairing-Modus. Genau, jetzt macht er blink, blink, blink, blink, blink.
Dann kommt schon mal ein Headset, not paired, sonst holt er gleich noch den Namen. Genau Nokia BR604. Hat er vorher gesagt, als der Name noch nicht da war. Dann klicke ich drauf, sagt er hier Pairing, dann musst du wahrscheinlich nochmal drücken bei dir.
Nee, bei diesem Turm.
Du hast ja schon gedrückt.
Der ist ja sozusagen explizit in dem Paare-Mich-Modus.
So, jetzt ist er hier connected. Okay, der da oben dreht immer weiter, das Bluetooth-Zeichen oben in der Start-Liste ist jetzt schon total blau. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier Musik abspiele, müsste es schon da drüber kommen?
Eigentlich ja. Naja, wenn es jetzt wirklich auch als Headphone erkannt ist und das macht, müsste es jetzt in deiner iPod-Applikation explizit auftauchen. Also du kannst ja mal irgendwas starten, genau. So, und jetzt kommt halt rechts unten, ist kein Bluetooth-Symbol und das sagt mir, dass er eben kein A2DP macht. Also du hättest jetzt hier rechts unten, neben dem Lautstärke-Scrabber, hättest du nochmal eine explizite Anzeige, mit dem er...
Aber er macht ja gerade gar keinen Sound hier.
Doch, er scheppert irgendwas. Genau, das heißt, erste Generation geht's nicht.
Musik abspielen geht nicht, jetzt die Frage, ob jetzt, weil es als Headset kommt, Telefongespräche würden gehen.
Vermutlich, das müssen wir jetzt halt nochmal ausprobieren, aber das müssen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt während der Sendung machen, oder?
Das ist doch auch total albern.
Ja, also als Headset, klar.
Als Stereo-iPod-Dings geht's nicht.
Jetzt bist du wieder dran. Genau. Also soweit alles super. Und an sich ist das schon mal toll. Und ich muss auch sagen, also ich kann das jetzt Leuten, die jetzt tempted sind, durchaus empfehlen. Vielleicht findet ihr ja noch ein besseres Kopfhörer-Modell, also es gibt auch noch so andere, aber ich wollte halt definitiv einen geschlossenen Kopfhörer haben. Und das Teil funktioniert soweit erstmal ganz gut. Nach einer Woche Erfahrung. Aber es gibt natürlich auch Probleme. Und das Problem, was ich vor allem habe, ist, dass natürlich im Gegensatz zu dem Standard-Audio-Ausgang dieser A2DP-Kram komplett in Software stattfindet. Mit anderen Worten, das frisst CPU. Und wenn jetzt du Heavy-Internet machst, mit deinem Tethering, also wenn du sozusagen wirklich dein iPhone gerade nutzt für Netz und dann ordentlich mal im Safari auf Reload klickst und eine fette Seite lädst, dann habe ich das halt häufig gehabt, dass dann eben anfängt, dass das Audio stottert. Also du hast durch Heavy-Usage, durch Starten von Programmen, Programme, die einfach CPU ziehen oder viel RAM brauchen oder was auch immer oder dass eben der Hintergrundprozess, der dir das Tethering macht, dass die einfach so viel an der CPU nagen, dass es eben wirklich stottert. Und ich vermute mal, dass dieses Problem beim 3GS so nicht mehr auftritt.
Oder ist das wirklich noch ein Softwarefehler und da kommt der nächste Upgrade?
Das lässt sich sicherlich auch optimieren, aber das war so, das typische Gerät ist einfach überfordert. Weil er muss ja in Realtime da die Pakete raushauen, andererseits muss er eben auch in Realtime genauso die IP-Pakete eben auch durch die Luft raushauen. Also er hat da mehrere High-Priority-Prozesse gleichzeitig laufen, die eben mehr oder weniger, also nicht Realtime, aber teilweise Realtime machen müssen. Und da überrascht mich das jetzt nicht, dass das Gerät überfordert ist und dass es dann einfach manchmal rockelt. Da ist halt einfach nicht genug Power drauf. Von daher, wer wirklich draufsetzen will, auf Bluetooth-Experience und gleichzeitig immer noch viel nutzen, dann kann das ein gutes Argument für ein neues Telefon sein.
Also ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen, dass die da noch demnächst das noch ein bisschen optimieren. Was müsste eigentlich gehen? Also so schlimm ist das jetzt auch nicht. Der ist L-Router, kann auch die wenig Megahertz haben und schaffen das eigentlich auch. Und das sogar noch mit PPP drumrum.
Ja gut, aber wie es eben so ist, dieses Telefon macht ja auch noch andere Sachen und checkt noch deine Mail, der Browser läuft im Hintergrund und so, die Hintergrundprozesse, weißt du?
Wie ist denn eigentlich, wenn das Tethering läuft, was kann man da mit dem iPhone noch in der Zeit machen?
Alles.
Alles, alles. Also telefonieren, surfen, Mails lesen, spielen zur Not.
Genau, du hast dann auch diesen permanenten blauen Balken.
So, als wenn man noch ein Gespräch on hold hat.
Da ist dann bei Tethering blau. Und beim Audiorecording ist er ja rot.
Langsam gehen die Farben aus, oder? Die sollten sich mal was aussuchen lassen, aus denken wir Hintergrundprozesse.
Das war wahrscheinlich der Hauptgrund, dass die anderen Hintergrundprozesse nicht laufen dürfen, weil sie einfach keine Farben mehr haben.
Das wird es sein. Genau, die konnten nicht mit Steve abgesprochen werden, weil er gerade in der OP war. Ich fand den gut.
Den Witz jetzt?
Ja, den fand ich super.
Na ja, dann lach doch noch ein bisschen drüber. So, fällt mir noch was ein zum Thema Tethering.
Angeblich gab es ja irgendwie Gerüchte, dass es bei AT&T 55 Dollar kostet, aber es hat sich schon als falsches Gerücht erwiesen.
Hier kommt noch die Frage im Chat, ob das jetzt auch so mit Linux und so weiter gehen müsste. Also, wenn der Rechner Pan unterstützt, dann sehe ich wenig Gründe, warum das nicht funktionieren sollte, weil es eigentlich über Bluetooth zumindest keinerlei Gründe gibt.
Da ist halt wirklich so ein Standard. Das ist nichts Apple-Gefrickel oder sonstiges, sondern wirklich so ein Standard-Ding. Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie mit einem Sony Ericsson kommt und Pan macht, geht das mit unserem Leopard?
Also ich hab zumindest keine Erkenntnisse, was da jetzt irgendwie Apple-proprietär sein soll. Und ich würde sogar vermuten, das ist aber jetzt echt nur eine Vermutung, dass es per USB auch geht, weil eigentlich sich das iPhone am Rechner, wenn Tethering eingeschaltet ist, meldet als Hallo, ich bin ein USB-Netzwerk-Device. Und da bin ich mir deshalb relativ sicher, dass das so ist, weil es einfach so sagenhaft schnell geht. Also, der muss da kein iTunes starten und da muss sich nicht noch irgendwas entfalten, sondern du steckst das Teil ran und dann macht es klabim und das Ding ist blau und macht irgendwie Tethering. Und von daher vermute ich, dass es auch mit anderen Systemen geht, so sie denn mit USB-Network-Devices was können und das kann ja Linux auch. Also, das ist eine reine Vermutung jetzt. Ich wäre überrascht, wenn es nicht geht, dann wäre es interessant auch zu sehen, was der Grund ist.
Das heißt, ich kann dieses Weihnachten, wenn ich mal wieder zu meiner Oma in die Pamper fahre, wo es ja irgendwie kein DSL und nichts gibt und ich dann mal mit einem Modem sitze, mit 33,6 die letzten Jahre, kann ich dann vielleicht dieses Weihnachten, wenn ich es bis dahin schaffe, mal so ein 3GS an Start zu kriegen, irgendwie einfach mein Telefon in meinen Rechner schieben und habe irgendwie Speeds wie meine Oma, die noch nie gesehen hat.
Ja, wenn du da UMTS hast.
Oder überhaupt UMTS gibt. Wie sehr in der Pampa ist denn das? Mit O2, also auf dem Land mit O2 ist so eine Sache, ne?
Da geht es schnell nach hinten los.
Also da hast du an vielen Regionen nicht unbedingt Netz, da musst du halt mal die Coverage anschauen.
Und angenommen du bist jetzt mit deinem Telefon, weil mit meinem geht es eh nicht, aber soweit er meint ist, bei meinem mit Edge geht es nicht, aber angenommen du bist mit deinem Telefon in der Pampa und dort gibt es kein UMTS, sondern nur Edge, dann geht das auch schon nicht, weil das nicht parallel funktionieren würde, also Sprechen und Daten.
Er schaltet dann das Tethering einfach nicht an. Wobei das ist halt wirklich noch so ein bisschen ein Fragezeichen. Also ich hatte auch noch andere Dinge zu tun, als die ganze Zeit meinem Telefon zuzuschauen, weil da war dann irgendwie immer Netz. Ich kann meine mich halt zu erinnern, dass ich irgendwann auch nochmal Netz hatte auf meinem Rechner, obwohl er mir gerade anzeigte, dass da nur Edge ist. Aber andererseits habe ich ihn auch gesehen, wie das Tethering ausgeschaltet wurde und dann war da nur Edge. Inwieweit das jetzt alles zwingend zusammenhängt, inwieweit er da für eine kurze Zeit vielleicht auch Edge noch nimmt und keine Ahnung, und wenn er dann kein 3G findet, dann wieder umschalten, ist mir unklar, auf jeden Fall problematisch. Also da muss man auch nochmal gucken, weil das natürlich auch bedeutet, dass du relativ wenig Vollwerk hast. Wenn ich jetzt einen normalen, meine zweite SIM-Card in so einem USB-Stack drin habe, die funktioniert auch mit GPRS.
Auf dem Land irgendwie, gerade da brauchen wir das ja, weil überall, überall anders gibt es Nelan, DSL und das, weiß ich nicht.
Genau. Vielleicht findet da auch jemand noch so ein Hidden Setting mit Remain Online, mit Tethering, auch wenn es nur 2G ist, so, das wäre nochmal eine ganz interessante Frage.
Auf jeden Fall.
Weil ehrlich gesagt, dann werde ich schon lieber nicht angerufen.
Ja, weil wenn man manchmal Netz braucht, braucht man Netz.
Dann braucht man halt einfach Netz. Und die können ja auch Skype benutzen. So, jetzt habe ich aber hier wirklich, glaube ich, alles gesagt zu diesem Thema. A2DP und Tethering, Bluetooth, also überhaupt denke ich, Bluetooth ist eines der mega neuen Features von OS 3.0. Beziehungsweise überhaupt mal Bluetooth. Bei dem iPod Touch gibt es ja jetzt überhaupt das erste Mal überhaupt Bluetooth. Der Stein war da zwar schon immer drin.
Aber jetzt haben sie es aktiviert.
Konnte es ja sozusagen gar nichts nutzen damit. Hier gab es ja zumindest diesen Apple Headset Support. Und jetzt ist es eben voll da. Und sie machen vor allem Bluetooth-Paren. Was ja von Anfang an auch meine Vermutung war für ihr Peer-to-Peer-Kram.
Ja, schon ein paar Sendungen her, ne?
Ja, genau. Also dass das eben nicht auf Bluetooth-Paring basiert, sondern dass du eben einfach so Netzwerk hast und dann eben sich die iPhones direkt finden können.
Das können wir mal testen eigentlich.
Und dass sie darüber auch IP machen. Gibt es denn schon eine Applikation, die das macht?
Ja, es gibt ein paar Applikationen für. Lass mal gucken, ob was kostenloses dabei ist. Also ich habe irgendeine Chat-Applikation entdeckt, mit der man so, die sah aber nicht so schick aus, gibt eine Seite. Das finde ich übrigens ein bisschen echt daneben beim Start von iPhone OS 3.0 jetzt, dass es gibt so wenig gute Software, die die neuen Möglichkeiten nutzt. Also gerade in Notifications habe ich ja, also ich habe fest damit gerechnet, letztes Jahr als iPhone OS 2.0 gestartet ist, bam bam, am ersten Tag kommt Twitterrific raus. Ganz, also damals eine tolle Applikation fürs iPhone. Und wurde auch beworben von Apple und richtig, und fettes Programm. Und ich dachte, dass dieses Jahr jetzt mit Notifications, dass da so die Chat-Clients direkt so bam bam bam rausgekloppt werden, oder eben ein Twitter-Client, der mich informiert, sobald ich eine Reply bekomme oder etwas ähnliches.
Im Chat wird berichtet, dass Apple die Applikationen noch zurückhält, die push benutzen.
Ja, und das kommt jetzt irgendwie alles nicht. Also das ist so, ich kriege hier...
Doch, es gibt schon die ersten. OmniFocus ist schon im App Store mit 3.0 Features.
Es gibt viele Programme mit 3.0 Features, aber was zum Beispiel, was...
Meintest du das nicht?
Nee, ich meinte jetzt wirklich... Ich meinte jetzt wirklich diese Push-Notification. Also da gibt es dieses AP News Ding, was, wenn man auf Amerika...
Ich glaube, es gibt derzeit noch keine einzige Applikation.
Doch, doch, ich habe einige drauf.
Und da funktioniert das auch schon.
Ich habe dir doch gerade vorhin eine Push-Notification gezeigt.
Echt, was denn?
AP Mobile, also dieses AP News Programm. Es gibt Push-Applikationen schon. Aber eben so ganz... Ich habe dir doch eine Push-Notification. Hier, guck, da ist ja an meinem AP Mobile, da ist oben so ein kleines Bläschen dran. Und vorhin kam das, gerade als ich gesprochen hatte, da habe ich dann gezeigt, guck, hier, Push-Notification.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, das habe ich nicht bekommen. War ich wahrscheinlich gerade bei einem ganz anderen Thema.
Und es gibt so ein Pollenwaren-Programm für England, was ich mir jetzt bloß installiert habe, um mal so eine Push-Notification zu sehen.
Okay, also Push-Notification ist live, aber dir fehlen noch die Anwendungen, die das machen.
Ja, genau. Also Leute, Apple knallt mal. Ich meine, kann man doch mal... Ich habe hier von...
Worüber sollen wir uns jetzt unterhalten? Dass irgendwelche Applikationen noch nicht da sind. Gut, dann kommen sie halt später.
Entschuldigt mal bitte. Ich meine, so eine Firma wie Apple, die kann es doch wohl schaffen, dass für ihre neue iPhone 3.0 Software, für eines der Hauptfeatures...
Vielleicht gibt es hier einfach noch keine.
Also guck mal, hier habe ich eine Liste von Push-Applikationen. Not live yet, update awaiting Apple approval.
Was meinste, was passiert ist, als 3.0 da war? Die haben alle ihre Programme da hochgeladen, die ganzen Updates, und Apple muss jetzt erstmal abarbeiten.
Es ist wahrscheinlich auch ein längerer Approval-Prozess, wenn die Dinger push benutzen. Das würde mich überhaupt nicht wundern. Das kann auch sein, ja. Vorher gucken sie halt nur, ist da irgendwie Titten drin, ist da Hitler drin, dann nein. Ja, ist es ein C64-Emulator, genau.
Hat auch einer dazu gefragt, wird natürlich verboten, weil es ein Interpreter ist, sozusagen. Da muss halt 64-Gekord interpretieren.
Ja, warum er das Programm überhaupt geschrieben hat, ist mir ein Rätsel.
Ich würde mal sagen, sowas ist irgendwie eine Ausnahme. Aber okay, wollten sie halt nicht, haben sie gekennzeichnet.
Warum eine Ausnahme? Es steht einfach klar und deutlich, haben sie gesagt, nein. Punkt. Wir machen keine Emulator. Naja, und grad ein C64.
Naja, aber es gibt schon ein paar Emulator, auch auf dem iPhone. Was?
So gesehen ist jede Web-App irgendwie sowas. Im App-Store?
Im App-Store? Es gibt hier, das sieht man nicht nach außen hin, aber wie heißt das, dieses alte Sega-Spiel, dieses ganz berühmte hier mit dem Igel? Wie heißt denn das, Menschenskinder? Sonic? Sonic, das ist eine Reine, hat jemand, wenn du einen Jailbreak hast, nimmst du das. Naja, aber du kannst das Programm offiziell kaufen über den App-Store und kannst Sonic spielen. Und wenn du einen Jailbreak gemacht hast, kannst du einfach die, aus dem App-File, das Rom-Fall rausnehmen von Sonic, und kannst ein anderes Rom-Fall reinpacken für den Sega. Dann hast du eben das andere Spiel.
Ach, und du meinst, dass sie tatsächlich da eine Rom-Emulation drin haben?
Offensichtlich, ansonsten würde das ja nicht...
Ach, wie heißt das?
Sonic. Das ist von Sega das offizielle Spiel. Und um da was anderes reinzupacken, brauchst du halt...
Von Sega, offiziell?
Von Sega, ein ganz offizielles Sonic. Das Spiel bieten die jetzt auch fürs iPhone an.
Wahrscheinlich dachte ich, alles klar, Commodore-Emulator, das ist doch nicht von Commodore, also verbieten wir das, weil der darf das gar nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, der ist sogar offiziell lizensiert wohl. Ich nehme an, wenn er einfach ein Spiel nehmen würde und nur dieses eine Spiel reinpacken würde in diesen C64-Emulator, wäre das überhaupt kein Problem. Wenn er es irgendwie schafft, dass man so einen In-App-Shop, und das ist gar nicht offiziell C64 heißt, sondern die besten Games für den C64 und genau die gleiche Software ist, wäre es wahrscheinlich auch überhaupt kein Problem.
Also das verwundert mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt. Und vor allem verwundert es mich deshalb, weil es sich auch noch um ein Spiel handelt, wo ich ja jetzt gesagt hätte, ach na ja, wenn das jetzt, wenn die damit spielen kommen, dann...
Ist weiterhin unklar, wissen wir nicht. Apple ist evil.
Ja, aber dieser App-Store-Prozess, ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand, wer das alles mitbekommen hat, da gab es auch ein eigentlich kleines, ziemlich banales Programmchen im App-Store. Das hat Craig geschrieben, der nun ziemlich gut mit Johnny von Spreeblick befreundet ist. Und der hat irgendwann mal vor Ewigkeiten die Minipops erfunden. Das sind so kleine Pixel-Figuren quasi. Und der wollte jetzt mit diesen Minipops ein App-Store-Programm schreiben, hat das eingereicht und dann haben wir gesagt, nee, machen wir nicht. Ist ein Bild von Hitler drin. Witze über Hitler können wir nicht ab. Diktatoren, darf man keine Witze drüber machen.
Das war wirklich der Grund.
Sie haben zurückgeschickt, weswegen das abgelehnt worden ist und das war unter anderem ein Bild von Hitler eben zu sehen, wo unten drunter der Spruch stand.
Das war lustig.
Wo unten drunter stand, hat ein für alle Mal die Toothbrush-Bärte unbrauchbar gemacht oder so was in der Richtung. Und dann war noch ein Bild von der Familie Obama, wie sie am Abend ihrer Ernennung dasteht, mit Kindern usw.
Mit diesem hässlichen schwarz-roten Kleid.
Mit diesem schwarz-roten Kleid und irgendein netter Spruch dazu. Und das Programm ist, du kriegst diese Minipops zu sehen und kannst dann raten, wer könnte das wohl sein. Und das hat Apple dann abgelehnt. So und dann hat jemand gesagt, nee, mit Diktatoren wollen wir nicht usw. Also gibt es eine offizielle Ablehnungsmail.
Deswegen haben sie den Obama nicht genommen?
Dann hat er die rausgenommen, irgendwas kritisiert haben, hat es nochmal eingereicht, dann haben sie gesagt, nee, wir nehmen es immer noch nicht. Diesmal ohne Begründung.
Das ist ja alles schon Wochen her.
Das ist schon alles Wochen her. Und jetzt ist er extra auf die WWDC gefahren, um vor Ort jemanden, per E-Mail kriegt man da ja niemand, er hat Geld in die Entwicklung gesteckt, oder was weiß der Teufel was, oder Aufwand. Und war dann auf der WWDC und hat da mal direkt vor Ort nachgefragt, wie es denn aussieht, wie es denn sein kann. Und da haben sie ihm weiterhin keine Antwort gegeben, außer, naja, da steht doch in der Mail drin, das war nicht approved, wir approven das halt nicht.
Ich hab auch gelesen, dass die sich bei der WWDC nach irgendeiner Veranstaltung, wo es über Apps in den App-Store stellen, wie man das alles so macht und so, dass dann das vorbei war und normalerweise kommt immer so eine Q&A danach. Und die gab's aber bei dem Vortrag nicht und die Developer haben sich schnell verdrückt, weil sie wussten, was kommt.
Jaja, hab ich auch gehört.
Apple, bring das mal endlich in Ordnung, die Scheiße.
Na ja, das ist wirklich ein schwieriger Fall. Das ist echt ein schwieriger Fall.
Das ist halt der Nachteil von unserem World Garden, ne? Also, dass die Wächter halt auch immer nicht...
Ja, aber wirklich ohne Begründung. Und dann wirklich mit der Begründung, weil wir es so sagen, ist es halt so. Also, vorher gab es wenigstens immer noch, wenn auch alberne Begründung ja oftmals. Aber da hatten wir wenigstens so einen Ansatzpunkt gehabt, ok, da muss ich dieses Alken entfernen oder da muss ich dafür sorgen, dass bei Twitter das Wort so und so nicht mehr auffällt oder dass das Kamasutra nie geschrieben worden ist, was jetzt auch schon alles mal ziemlich alberne Gründe sind. Aber einfach zu sagen, ne, wir machen es nicht, finde ich dann doch schon eigentlich ziemlich brüskierend, peinlich.
Ja, das ist sicherlich streitbar, aber am Ende des Tages ist es halt deren Produkt und die entscheiden, ob sie dich mitspielen lassen. Aber ich finde es auch extrem unfair, dass man die Entwickler so im Unklaren darüber lässt, warum. Dann können sie sich selber überlegen.
Spätestens bei dem Programm gibt es keinen Grund mehr. Da hat sich dann wahrscheinlich der interne Prozess festgefressen. Die wollen sich dann nicht eingestehen, dass sie einen Fehler gemacht haben.
So viel Schokolade fressen während des Podcasts ist gar nicht so eine gute Idee.
Du kannst das nicht alles hier alleine fressen.
Hier, nimm die Toblerone. Du wolltest noch Toblerone haben.
Das war Unblock Me. Und zwar habe ich ja vor Ewigkeit mal erzählt von diesem Traffic-Spiel, was es für ein Palm gab. Mit den Steinchen, die man aus dem Weg räumen konnte. Und dieses Unblock Me ist jetzt tatsächlich das... Hättest du gesehen, es ist beim Rüberschieben wieder verloren gegangen.
Das ist jetzt Spotlight, man kann jetzt suchen.
Genau, ich suche jetzt mal.
Was kann man da unblocken?
Das ist so ein Auto-Rennen. Jetzt hat das mir runtergeschmissen, weil ich es gerade mit meinem... Ich hab heute Nacht... Das ist eine ganz andere Story, muss ich auch noch erzählen. Ich musste heute Nacht meinen Rechner neu aufsetzen. Jetzt hat er die iTunes-Verbindung vergessen. Und jetzt hat er ein paar Programme gelöscht, weil ich zum Tesserang ausprobieren...
Jetzt nicht noch mehr neue Themenkarten aufmachen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall ist das ein sehr schönes Programm, wo man so autofrei arbeiten kann. In dem Fall eben kein Auto, sondern Holzsteine. Sehr hübsch gemacht, geht... Angeblich gar nicht drauf.
Ich hab mir auch mal wieder nach 8 Wochen gedacht, ich kann nicht mehr ein neues Programm installieren.
Oh, wie du hast eins gekauft?
Nee, das sowieso nicht. Aber ich hab mir diese Telefonbuch-App runtergeladen, weil ich dachte, ich brauch mal eine Nummer.
Was?
Gelbe Seiten?
Nee, nicht gelbe Seiten, oder? Gelb ist nicht gelb, ist rosa. Das Telefonbuch-App. Das ist rosa, mal gucken.
Ach, von der Tele kommt das Telefon, dieses 600 Megabyte-Teil, oder was?
Nee, ich hab das per GPS runtergeladen. Das war 10 Minuten da oder so.
Dann haben sie es irgendwie geändert. Da gab es ja die erste Ausgabe, die war ja irgendwie riesig.
Nee, der fragt auch nur online ab, der Scheiß hier. Jedenfalls, wer telefonbuch.de kennt, der weiß, wie gut dieses Programm ist.
Es ist einfach die Webseite in Form eines Programms und ein bisschen noch mit ein paar Warnungen, dass dieses Programm nur mit Internet Explorer funktioniert, oder?
Nee, es ist so ein Internet Explorer, aber es taugt so gar nichts.
Das gelbe Seiten ist ganz okay.
Da kriegen sie auch was dafür, dass die Nummern da reinkommen.
Na ja, ja.
Wie machen die bei Bits und so jetzt auch schon wieder Leistung, während wir unseren Livestream machen? Nee, oder?
Nee, glaub ich nicht.
So, Zeit kann leisten, wie was für eine Zeit informieren sie sich bitte bei rfönix.de? Okay, ist doch alles Fernseh, verheer.
Nein, die haben ja schon Freitag irgendwie hier sich ausführlich ausgelassen zu den ganzen Thematiken.
So, was haben wir noch bei iPhone 3.0?
Naja, zum Thema Bluetooth muss man auch mal erwähnen, was nicht dabei ist. Es gibt halt immer noch keinen Keyboard-Support, was ich sehr schade finde.
Was du jetzt mal endlich probiert, ja?
Naja, ich hab's noch nicht selber probiert, weil ich derzeit kein Bluetooth-Tastatur habe, aber es...
Hat jemand gesagt.
Es haben mir mehrere Leute bestätigt, dass sie es nicht gepaart bekommen. Und ich find das eigentlich sehr schade, weil das wäre schon cool. Zumal die Bluetooth-Tastatur von Apple ist eigentlich wirklich geil für unterwegs. Die macht man sich in so Schlüpfer rein, die kriegst du in eine Tasche rein, die ist flach, die ist klein. Und würde man halt wirklich so das iPhone auf den Tisch legen und dann die Tastatur davor und man könnte das perren, das wär's einfach zum Schreiben von E-Mails und so und von längeren Texten. Dann gäbe es noch einen Grund weniger, einen Rechner mitzunehmen. Also das...
Ich glaub, das fällt denen bei Apple auch noch ein. Oder das ist genau der Grund, warum sie es nicht machen. Die wollen wenigstens noch ein bisschen Computer verkaufen.
Ja, ach, weiß ich nicht so recht. Ich meine, sie machen ja... Sie verkaufen ja so viele iPhones. Also das ist ja für sie auch so ein Riesenmarkt. Und ich glaub, am Ende des Tages spielt das jetzt nicht so die Rolle.
Und die Verrückten, die sich für ihr iPhone eine Bluetooth-Tastatur kaufen, die haben auch sowieso einen Rechner.
Ja, du brauchst ja dann ihr noch einen Computer, um es zu sünden. Irgendwann muss man sich das MacBook nur noch dazu kaufen, damit man sein iPhone überhaupt in Betrieb nehmen kann.
Die Sync Station für zu Hause, ja.
Genau. Das MacBook Sync.
Vielleicht kommt irgendwann noch mal so eine Headless Station aus.
Ah, das ist das Missing Product.
Das ist das neue MacBook, genau.
Nur ein USB-Anschluss und kein Display.
Und wie laden? Und anstatt der Batterie, weil die brauchen wir natürlich auch nicht. Die Leuchten für die Batterie sind für den Füllstand da, wie viel Backup noch drauf geht.
Ja, so, was hab ich denn hier noch? Also, was ein echtes Problem ist, was ich festgestellt habe, insbesondere jetzt mit, also was mir jetzt richtig, richtig aufgefallen ist mit dem Bluetooth-Audio, ich bin halt im Zug gefahren und permanent bricht dir das Netz weg. Sonst kommt wieder uns weg. Sonst kommt wieder uns weg. Und das doofe iPhone zeigt mir jedes Mal, wenn das Netz weg ist, so ein Dialog. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das abschalten kann, hab ich da irgendwas übersehen?
Auf dem Rechner oder auf dem Telefon?
Auf dem Telefon. Bei euch ist das doch auch. Wenn das Netz weg ist, kommt dieser, das Netz ist weg Dialog, oder?
Beim Tethering oder ohne?
Nee, überhaupt so, generell.
Wenn das Netz weg ist, nee, dann ist einfach das Netz weg.
Hab ich da irgendwas eingeschaltet, was man nicht hätte einschalten sollte? Nee, nee, ich hatte das auch schon vorher.
Echt? Ne, hab ich nicht. Hast du deinen, wie hast du deinen Provider eingestellt? Man kann den ja fest nageln und man kann ihn auf Automatic stellen. Ich glaube, wenn man ihn nicht auf Automatic stellt, dann kommt da so ein Pop-Up. Bei mir ist der auf Automatic und dann kommt auch nichts.
Da muss ich noch mal gucken. Das kann natürlich sein. Ja, der Chat meint auch gerade, dass das wohl der Grund sei. Weil, okay, verstehe. Weil dann ist es nämlich richtig elend. Im Zug hast du halt die ganze Zeit, kommt, kommt nicht, kommt, kommt nicht. Und dann kommt dann der ganze Zeit dieser Dialog hoch und der frisst dann so viel Aufmerksamkeit von dem OS, dass halt dein Audio ruckelt. Echt? Weil er die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund versucht, manisch sich wieder in dieses Netz einzubuchen und dabei irgendwie so viel rumblockiert, dass das eben Auswirkungen hat auf das Bluetooth-Audio-Streaming. Das war richtig nervig. Stimmt, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, okay, alles klar. Ich muss meinen Netzbetreiber auf automatisch schalten, dann ist das weg. Ach, wie schön. Na, haben wir das ja gleich geklärt. Schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Ich hab generell das Gefühl, dass alles so ein bisschen snappier ist eigentlich bei dem, insbesondere im Webbrowser, also nicht mega groß, aber es ist schon alles ein bisschen runder und das merkt man ja auch mit dem Suchen, also und vor allem Listen, also lange Listen, meine, meine Adressbuchliste da mit über 1500 Einträgen, also das war schon extrem zäh und wenn du das so gestartet hast, bist du dann in der Lage warst oben zu sagen, geh mal ins Suchen, das war weg. Und check, finde ich auch, dass in allen Listen jetzt ein Suchfeld mit drin ist, das ist ja auch echt.
Ja, wenn man ein bisschen runterscrollt, dann kommt er oben, ist eigentlich versteckt, aber es ist oben da. Die haben, wenn man, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt noch unter NDA ist, aber ich glaube es ist auch Public Knowledge, die haben dieses ganze Table Views, also so wie die Kontaktliste halt so angezeigt wird, ist bei dem 3.0 auch, hat ziemlich viele Updates und ein paar alte Methoden sind irgendwie deprecated, also die haben das so ein bisschen aufgeräumt und neu gemacht und das ganze Cellmanagement und so haben sie ein bisschen umgestaltet. Es kann sein, dass dadurch eventuell, wenn die Leute es demnächst auch anfangen zu benutzen, noch ein paar Speedgains kommen.
Ich glaube das SDK-NDA ist jetzt auch weg.
Komplett?
Also, hab ich so mitbekommen. Ich meine, was ist denn da das Prinzip gewesen und welches Prinzip verfolgt man jetzt? Also ändert sich sozusagen die Art und Weise, wie man die Listen aufbaut oder was?
Na vorher waren viele, also ein paar Calls für den Accessory-Button zum Beispiel. Der war in das Table-View rein, sozusagen ich bin Zeile oder Row 15 und gib mir mal, was ich für einen Accessory-Button hab. So soll es halt eben nicht mehr sein, sondern jetzt hat jede Zelle schon, also muss man beim Erzeugen der Zelle schon sagen, was sie für einen Accessory-Button hat. Das heißt, es wird nicht jedes Mal abgefragt, wenn das dargestellt wird, sondern es ist halt gleich schon beim Erzeugen der Zelle mit drin. Das ist einfach ein anderer Weg. Aber da haben sie ja ziemlich viel aufgeräumt und alte Methoden gesagt, so bitte nicht mehr. Und sie haben gesagt, dass zum Beispiel auch die Höhenangabe der Zelle, das soll man auch nicht mehr über TableView so machen, sondern das soll man auch direkt in die Zelle schreiben, wie groß oder die Zelle soll ihre Größe angeben. Also so lauter Änderungen hier und da, wo ich denke, dass die da sich das nochmal genau angeguckt haben. Und man kann jetzt auch, früher gab es halt eigentlich nur eine Default-Optik der Zelle, nämlich einmal vorne in den Bild, Text und hinten so verschiedene Buttons, also den blauen oder das Häkchen oder so ein Größerzeichen, dass da was kommt. Und jetzt gibt es, glaube ich, drei verschiedene, also so normaler Text und dann darunter nochmal so ein Detail-Text, irgendwie ein dicker Text und dünner Text. Und da kann man sich jetzt aussuchen, was man für eine Zelle haben will und muss das nicht alles mehr so sehr über zusammenpopeln, zumindest nicht für so einfache Sachen. Also ich denke mal, in dem Bereich ist was passiert, weil Scrollen soll halt schnell sein.
Ja, hat sich schon gezeigt, dass das wirklich ein Flaschenhals ist. Und dass auch wirklich viele Programme ja davon auch Nutzen machen.
Ja, ansonsten ist mir aufgefallen jetzt hier, Safari ist ja auch eine schnellere Version, ist ja auch der 4.0er oder in Richtung 4.0, ich weiß nicht, welchen sie genau genommen haben, kann man ja intern nicht so sagen, aber das iPhone hat mit irgendwie 98 oder 97 Asset-3-Punkten, und das ist ja nur released jetzt, also es ist nicht mal beta, ist sozusagen nach dem Desktop-Safari der zweitbeste Browser im Asset-3-Test. Das iPhone.
Und warum haben sie da nicht alles irgendwie?
Na, da hatte ich diesen einen Programmierer schon mal irgendwie, als das iPhone rauskam, gefragt und er meint, weil durch das Drehen und so sind da irgendwie so ein paar Sachen von den Koordinaten irgendwie anders und deswegen geht's nicht so ganz. Hab ich auch nicht so ganz verstanden eigentlich, warum er mir das erzählt hat, aber muss ich erst mal hinnehmen, weil das war dieser Dave Haney selbst, oder wie hieß der Dave Haney? Hyatt, genau. Und ja, aber ich meine 97 Punkte oder 98 auf dem iPhone. Es kriegt irgendwie der Firefox irgendwie noch nicht hin. Explorer brauchen wir gar nicht reden. Und Opera, glaube ich, hat jetzt gerade die 100 Punkte erreicht.
Firefox 3.5 hat noch kein Asset 3, irgendwie doch.
Ja, aber nicht 100 Punkte.
Also ich hab's grad mal laufen lassen. Da hat er 93 angeblich.
Du hast auch ein Browser und musst da 100 haben. Da ist dann bei dir irgendwas nicht ok.
War's das iPhone jetzt oder was? Oder der Firefox?
Achso, der Safari, nee. Firefox hat 93, ok.
Die aktuelle Release-Kandidate von 3.5.
Genau.
Aha, echt?
So, also der Safari hat 100, rattert da durch und hat es. Das iPhone macht 97 oder 98. Dauert halt ein bisschen, ist halt langsam und so, das muss man schon einsehen.
Ja, man muss mal, aber wenn man ehrlich ist, muss man mal sagen, dass die Seite auf dem iPhone total viel scheißiger aussieht, als auf dem Firefox aussieht.
Ja, das stimmt, kommt natürlich auch auf den Fehler an.
Ja, das heißt ja, also diese 93, das ist ja nicht so, das ist 93 von 100 Tests. Genau, das können andere sein, das ist nicht wirklich durchnummeriert. Und da kann natürlich ein einzelner Fehler eine ganz signifikante Auswirkung haben, dass irgendwas total scheißer aussieht.
Aber dann gucken wir doch mal, dass die Konkurrenz von Google kann.
Und noch besser als Firefox sind.
Was ich ja ganz lustig fand, das geht jetzt. Safari 4 kann jetzt was, nämlich, es gibt ja diese visuellen Effekte, dieses CSS-Animations. Und da gab es einige, die kann das iPhone schon seit Version 2.0 oder 2.1 Effekte. Die kann Safari jetzt erst mit 4. Also es gab ein Jahr lang, hat man auf dem iPhone CSS-Animationen einsetzen können, die es auf dem Desktop einfach nicht gibt. Also so ein Dreh-Effekt.
Auf dem normalen Safari, auf dem Web-Kit dann schon, ne?
Ne, auch auf dem Web-Kit erst jetzt. Aber jetzt geht's. Seit Safari 4 geht's auch. Mal gucken, wie viel Punkte Android erreicht. Asset 3.
Pass the asset test. Ja, ich würd ja noch ganz gern jetzt noch mal meinen Lieblingsrand zum Thema iPhone nochmal aktualisieren.
Oh, ich glaube, ich weiß, was jetzt kommt.
Lehn wir uns zurück.
Ja, wir lehnen uns zurück.
Ich wollt ja schon länger mal einen längeren Block-Eintrag machen zum Podcasting. Als ich das dann mit iPhone OS 3.0 abgezeichnet hab, hab ich dann da noch mal auf die Bremse gedrückt und mir gedacht, mal gucken, was kommt. Tatsächlich haben sie einige Sachen eingebaut, die ich in meiner Liste hatte. Ist natürlich jetzt toll, einfach von mir zu behaupten, aber müsste jetzt einfach mal so fressen. Unter anderem hatte ich halt hier dieses 30 Sekunden-Zurückspringen, das war ein Wunsch-Feature von mir. Und das haben sie auch wirklich gut gemacht. Ah, da fällt mir übrigens auch ein...
Das ist eigentlich bei allen Songs, also auch so im iPod jetzt, wenn man so einen Song hört, war irgendwie mit länger draufhalten, ne? Auf dem, das ist ja so ein Button, wo man bestimmen kann, wo man gerade was hört, ne? Und da kann man jetzt länger draufhalten und dann poppt irgendwas auf, oder war das so? Ich hab's nämlich schon vergessen.
Das ist bei Podcasts ist das.
Bei normalen Musik hören nicht?
Nee, da ist da dieser komische Genius-Button an der Stelle. Na bei Musik willst du nicht 30 Sekunden-Zurückspringen.
Was hat sie jetzt gleich gesungen?
Ja, gut, also... Nicht, dass ihr mir nicht vorstellen könnt, aber ihr wisst, wie das ist, ja.
Ja, ich wollte nur wissen, wo denn was ist.
Ich finde ja, das war eigentlich auch eine meiner Hauptforderungen, dass sie Podcasts anders behandeln als Musik, denn es ist einfach keine Musik. Und das haben sie getan. Also das muss man schonmal anerkennen, sie haben zumindest Verbesserungen versucht zu bringen. Und es ist ja noch teilweise gelungen. Und das ist auf jeden Fall gut. Also an der Stelle ist es wirklich toll. Die zweite Sache, die sie eingebaut haben, ist halt dieses Scrubbing. Beim iPod, und das ist nach wie vor meiner Meinung nach eigentlich die großartigste Funktion überhaupt und warum der iPod eigentlich für Podcasting so wunderbar war. Also der normale Classic iPod, der mit dem Rad. Du konntest halt, wenn du was hörst, drückst du einmal in die Mitteltaste rein und danach konntest du halt mit dem Rad vor und zurück scrollen. Und wie schnell du scrollst, hast du einfach in der Geschwindigkeit mit dem Rad gemacht. Das konntest du in der Rosentasche machen. Es war super smooth, super anambig. Also es hat einfach immer funktioniert. Und das war das Killer-Feature. Und das wäre eigentlich nicht meines iPods verlustig gegangen. Ich würde mir überlegen, ob ich nicht auch für Podcasts immer noch ein iPod benutzen würde. Ich kaufe mir jetzt nicht extra nochmal einen neuen dafür. Aber ich finde einfach Podcast hören geht auf dem iPod immer noch besser als auf dem iPhone. Diese 30-Sekunden-Zurückgeschichte ist jetzt mal ein echtes Feature. Das habe ich auch schon mehrfach zum Einsatz gebracht. Das ist gut und 30 Sekunden ist auch eine sehr sinnvolle Größe. Trotzdem, manchmal will man einfach an eine bestimmte Stelle zurückspringen. Und jetzt haben sie halt eine Lösung gebracht. Und das ist halt dieses Scrubbing. Und das funktioniert eben so. So wie vorher kannst du halt auf diesen kleinen Button da draufklicken in der Timeline. Und den nach vorne und nach hinten schieben. Wenn du allerdings mit dem Finger dann weiter nach unten gehst, dann bewirkt das Vor- und Zurückschieben eben ein langsameres Vor- Na ja, also ich meine, schön, dass es da ist. Aber ich finde, es ist eigentlich Apple nicht würdig. Also das ist wirklich nicht konsequent zu Ende gedacht. Da sind so viele Sachen falsch damit. Also erstmal ist das Problem, bei Default ist es schnell. Das heißt, um es so langsam zu machen, musst du deinen Finger mehr oder weniger gerade über die gesamte Höhe deines Tits... Sonst springst du schon, und zwar schon richtig viel, und du verlierst ja im ersten Moment sofort den Kontext, wo du warst. Das heißt, auch nur das kleinste Zittern, und wenn man im Bus sitzt und so weiter, ist es einfach nicht zu machen.
Das heißt, das kann Apple auch gar nicht ändern, weil sich die Leute jetzt schon genau daran gewöhnen und dann können sie das bei Apple ja nicht eigentlich umdrehen, außer sie machen es sofort und ganz schnell im nächsten Update. Weil wenn sie es jetzt erstmal 3 Monate drin lassen, können sie es nicht mehr ändern.
Doch, das müssen sie ändern. Steve kriegt hell von mir.
Du klopst dir noch die zweite Leber raus.
Zwei Hälften.
Gibs auf dem Popo, sag ich mal. Also das ist einfach nicht elegant. Also elegant ist wirklich anders. Das versteht irgendwie erstmal keiner. Das ist irgendwie falsch rum. Und ich muss auch sagen, es ist vom User-Interface auch überhaupt nicht konsequent. Weil du kannst damit auch nicht das machen, was du mit dem iPhone wunderbar, mit dem iPhone wunderbar machen konntest. Ich konnte nämlich so lange wie ich will, so schnell wie ich wollte in eine Richtung. Das heißt, wenn ich einfach so auf Double Speed vorspulen wollte, dann konnte ich das wirklich so eine Minute lang machen. Hier ist das dadurch begrenzt, wie viel Platz ich habe. Ist der, befinde ich mich sowieso schon fast am Ende. Und ich will dann in den letzten 3 Minuten langsam nach vorne gehen, weil so ein Podcast der 2 Stunden ist. Dann muss ich da oben drauf gehen, dann gerade nach unten, damit er nicht schon mal irgendwas scrollt. Und dann hab ich halt noch einen Zentimeter Bildschirm nach rechts, wo ich überhaupt noch meinen Finger machen kann und wenn ich da am Ende bin, kann ich nicht weiter. Dann muss ich loslassen und das Ganze noch mal vorne machen.
Also bei Videos geht das auch, stell dich gerade fest.
So schlecht fand ich das gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich könnte mir eine bessere Lösung vorstellen, ohne Frage.
Du kannst es nicht blind machen, du musst da wirklich genau hinschauen, du musst das Ding rausnehmen, musst es anlocken.
Aber du willst das doch sowieso. Also wofür brauchst du das? Ich dachte man braucht das eh nur, wenn man zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt springen will und dann kann man so grob hinrutschen zu der Stelle und dann kann man die Feinjustierung machen, indem man den Finger nach unten zieht.
Bei meinem Podcast, ich höre und ich will zurück zu dem, was vorhin gesagt wurde, über hm. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich jetzt habe ist...
Also ich meine, wie hast du das auf dem iPod gemacht?
Ich hab in meine Hosentasche gegriffen, ich hab auf den Mittelknopf gedrückt.
Und damit Pause ist?
Nein, da ist nicht Pause. Dann ist er in dem Scrubbing-Modus.
Ah, okay.
Und dann hab ich das Rädchen benutzt und zurückgescrollt. Ich hab einfach das Rädchen gedreht.
Ach so, also in dem Scrubbing-Modus.
Genau, und dann ist er einfach zurückgegangen. So. Und das ist...
Und um wie viel bist du dann zurückgegangen? Einfach blind in irgendeinem Zeitraum?
Ich hör's ja währenddessen.
Ach so, weil er weiterhin weiter...
Ja, ich hör, bis ich an der Stelle bin, wo ich hin will. Und da ich das richtig langsam und smooth machen konnte, aber auch ganz schnell, konnte ich also da intuitiv hingehen. Und weder geht es derzeit intuitiv, noch ist es bequem, noch ist es einfach zu benutzen. Man trifft dieses Ding auch immer nicht. Und der kleinste Fehlverhalten führt schon dazu, dass du unter Umständen deinen Q-Point komplett verlierst. Und damit ist es dann richtig scheiße. Und dann nervt's einfach mal total, weil du ja auch keine Möglichkeit hast, wieder an diese Stelle zurückzuspringen, wo du warst. Die einzige Sache, die du jetzt machen kannst, ist, du kannst halt 30 Sekunden zurückspringen. Und das ist ganz okay so, ja? Weil du hast irgendwas nicht mitbekommen, du willst es nochmal hören. 30 Sekunden zurück, okay, du wolltest eigentlich nur 10, dann hörst du halt nochmal 20 Sekunden, dann bist du irgendwie mit drin, okay. Oder du bist durch irgendwas abgelenkt worden, kannst eine Weile nicht hören, dann kannst du relativ schnell einschätzen, okay, das war jetzt ungefähr eine Minute, vielleicht auch mehr, und dann gehst du halt ein, zwei oder dreimal mit dieser Taste zurück und dann bist du wieder safe, hörst ein bisschen was doppelt und bist aber wieder drin. Also das funktioniert schon an sich ganz gut, aber das Scrabbing als solches ist einfach user-interface-technisch miserabel und geht auch wirklich von an. Also das ist einfach doof. Warum nicht einfach in der Mitte so ein Gummiband-Geschwindigkeitsslider, wie du ihn in jeder Video-Applikation hast, wo du einfach, ich gehe mit dem Finger nach rechts, umso weiter ich nach rechts gehe, umso schneller spielt er. Und wenn ich loslasse, schumm, springt er wieder auf normal Playback.
Oder einfach ein virtuelles iPhone-Wheel. Also das Rad einfach.
Hab ich auch drüber nachgedacht, aber das kann unter Umständen knifflig sein, wo dann so die Mitte ist und so, also das...
Das soll er dynamisch machen. Ich muss einmal auf die Richtung schälen.
Ich könnte mir das auch vorstellen, so ein Wheel wäre auch interessant.
Du fängst an in der Mitte, du hast in der Mitte...
Also wenn man das nicht macht, was könnte man machen, was besser funktioniert? Und sowas wäre zum Beispiel ausreichend. Sie haben den ganzen Platz während irgendetwas abspielt. Ich meine, guck dir das an, der Bildschirm ist überhaupt nicht genutzt. Das ist wirklich bekloppt.
Aber wahrscheinlich habt ihr das Recht. Das ist was, was auch funktionieren sollte, wenn du im Video-Modus bist. Insofern hast du nicht den ganzen Bildschirm.
Was?
Das soll ja auch im Video-Modus gut funktionieren.
Im Video-Modus funktioniert das sowieso alles anders. Also da hast du bestimmte Funktionalitäten nicht. Da gibt es dieses 30 Sekunden-Zurückspringen gibt es bei Video zum Beispiel nicht. Das hast du nur bei Audio. Und ich kann ja hier nochmal...
Aber Scrubbing, hat man das?
Guck mal, also das ist der normale...
Das sehen noch uns sowieso nicht.
Nein, ich beschreibe das jetzt mal. Normalerweise, wenn der Podcast abspielt, da siehst du, 80% des ganzen Bildschirms ist von dem Icon. Von dem Podcast-Icon. Was sich über 2 Stunden in der Regel nicht ändert. Warum muss nur 80% des Screen Estate für etwas, was sich 2 Stunden lang nicht ändert, geopfert werden? Da muss ich jetzt wirklich nicht die ganze Zeit drauf gucken. Ich sehe jetzt hier HR2 der Tag. In einer Stunde steht da immer noch HR2 der Tag. Das ist für mich an der Stelle einfach keinerlei Information. Für mich ist das Icon wichtig, wenn ich den auswähle, wenn ich ihn in der Liste finden will. Aber während ich zuhöre, muss ich doch nicht die ganze Zeit auf dieses bekloppte Icon drauf schauen. Also Fail.
So.
Also kann man das auch nutzen. Tatsächlich nutzen sie das auch. Drücke ich halt einmal in der Mitte drauf, dann kommt erst die Timeline. Das ist also noch bekloppter. Das heißt, wenn ich spulen will, dann muss ich das Ding erstmal anlocken, komme in diesen Modus.
Aber wenn einmal in dem Modus bist, dann bleibt er auch in dem Modus. Dann ist er ja per Default on.
Mit dieser Timeline? Ja, aber warum ist er nicht immer da? Warum ist die Timeline nicht immer zu sehen?
Du musst einmal, wenn du das iPhone kaufst, musst du einmal ins Display reingreifen, dann ist sie von da an immer zu sehen.
Die Timeline? Ja.
Die schaltet sich ja nicht von alleine wieder ab zwischen den Podcasts oder so.
Bist du sicher?
Ziemlich, ja. Also nicht hundertprozentig, aber... Ich fang jetzt einfach mal irgendwas an zu spielen. Und da guck, da ist sie.
Muss man nur einmal klicken für...
Nee, die ist einfach da. Wenn man sie einmal anmacht, ist sie da.
Das ist aber neu. Das war jetzt bei der 2.0 nicht so...
Doch, doch, ziemlich sicher.
Doch, die war schon immer da, die Timeline. Man muss nur einmal aufs Eigen klicken damit und dann kommt die.
Für immer. Solange bis man sie explizit wieder abschaltet.
Geht sie da weg?
So, haben wir schon wieder ein Tim-Problem gelöst.
Ja gut, aber du kommst häufig auch mal da drauf und dann ist es halt weg. Warum ist es nicht immer da? So, was haben wir da jetzt? Das haben wir so einen E-Mail-Button. Gut, diesen 30-Sekunden-Button. Und dann gibt es halt diesen Geschwindigkeitsabspiel. Habe ich noch gar nicht erwähnt. Man kann halt jetzt halbe Geschwindigkeit machen, normale Geschwindigkeit, doppelte Geschwindigkeit. Schön. Warum nicht die Geschwindigkeit noch feiner einstellen können? Doppelt so schnell ist mir meistens zu schnell. Also anderthalbfach wäre das eigentlich gewesen. Wenn sie schon feste Schritte machen, dann hätten sie 1,5 auf jeden Fall noch mit reinnehmen müssen. Also bei Faktor 2, gut für Blinde, geht sogar Faktor 6. Das muss noch konfigurierbar werden. Aber nochmal zu diesem Scrubbing-Interface. Warum sollte man jetzt nicht hier auch noch in diesem verbleibenden 50%-Screenest-Tale auch noch so einen Scrubber reinmachen? Dass ich hier einfach in die Mitte reingehe und wenn ich den Daumen nach rechts ziehe, dass er dann schneller vorspult, nach links entsprechend schnell zurückspult. Das wäre intuitiv. Solche User-Interfaces gibt es ja auch in zahlreichen Programmen.
Was ich sehr schade finde, dass man die 30-Sekunden-Zurückspult-Taste noch nicht hat, wenn man im Log-Screen ist. Im Log-Screen kann man nur Pause machen und Play und lauter leiser. Aber man kann nicht zurückspulen oder vorspulen. Oder eben diese 30 Sekunden zurückspulen. Weil ich kriege mit, ich hab was vertrieft, hol das Ding raus, mach einen Doppeltipp drauf, wird jetzt gerne einfach, wie ich normalerweise Pause mache. Und muss dann aber extra entriegeln und wahrscheinlich noch die Applikation wechseln, weil ich eh gerade nicht im iPod-Programm bin, um dann irgendwie die 30 Sekunden zurückspulen zu können. Wahrscheinlich muss ich zu dem Zeitplanpunkt dann sogar schon zweimal die 30 Sekunden zurückspulen drücken, weil es so lange her ist. Ja, da könnten sie... Also mit dem Log-Screen könnten sie sowieso noch mal viel mehr anfangen, ganz ehrlich, oder?
Das stimmt. Im Chat wird uns gerade behauptet, dass die doppelte Abspülgespannigkeit tatsächlich anderthalbfach wäre.
Naja, ob das stimmt?
Bei mir macht er 30 Sekunden Spielzeit in 20 Sekunden.
Mit anderen Worten, ich hab nur das Fall zum Icon dahinter.
Das ist mir aber trotzdem zu schnell. Also ich hätt's gerne variabel, weil es hängt extrem von den Sprechern ab. Du möchtest einfach das Software einstellen können.
Also 1,5 probier ich mal. Ich hab früher mal die Tage schon.
Also ich hab's jetzt mit zahlreichen Podcasts probiert, so was wie HL2 der Tag, wo sie wirklich schon relativ ruhig und bedächtig sprechen, kann ich mir auf doppelte Geschwindigkeit nicht geben. Das ist mir dann einfach zu schnell.
Das kannst du nicht machen.
Da kann man keine Argumente mit.
Muss man einfach Mobile Max hören, da gibt's eh keine Argumente.
Klar ist es eine Übungssache, aber mal ist man auch konzentrierter, mal ist man weniger konzentriert, mal hätte ich es einfach nur gern etwas schneller und 10, 20, 30 Prozent schneller würde mir das schon eine Menge bringen und das bringt ja dann auch in der Hörzeit eine Menge.
Wie könnte eigentlich ein Zweit-iPhone brauchen, das nichts weiter hat als Einstellungselemente für das Haupt-iPhone, wie das den iPhone abschiebt?
Manchmal muss ich es auch nur, also eigentlich möchte ich es normalerweise immer nur auf normaler Geschwindigkeit hören. Ich merke aber, dass ich zu wenig Zeit hab. Du hast noch eine Stunde Podcast, aber eine Dreiviertelstunde Fahrzeit.
Du meinst, man müsste einstellen können, wann man fertig sein will?
Genau.
Ich dachte, heute ist die Time Machine-Funktion.
Das wäre genau das richtige Feature für Mobamex.
Und eigentlich könnten sie irgendwann noch ein bisschen...
3 Stunden? Ja, das höre ich mir gerne an, aber ich möchte in 10 Minuten fertig sein.
Es gab doch mal bei irgendwie, das ging nur für englische Texte, dass einem ganz versteckt im Mac OS X, ich weiß gar nicht schon, seit Ewigkeiten drinnen, eine Funktion, die einem Texte zusammenfasst. Du hast einen Text und dann hast du einen Schieberegler und dann kannst du es auf Minimum reduzieren. Das wäre für uns ganz sinnvoll.
Aber was wir machen könnten, ist das, wenn man längere Lücken lässt und dann weiter redet, dass die Lücken sozusagen weggekürzt werden, dann spart man was, ohne dass es einem zu schnell vorkommt. So wie jetzt gerade, da war wieder eine Sekundenlücke, da können sie irgendwie eine halbe draus machen und so addiert sich das ja zusammen.
Ja, aber gerade bei uns sind die Lücken ja durchaus ein wichtiges Element des Podcasts.
Kann auch sein, dass die Betonung geradet, muss man gucken, aber man könnte mal mit experimentieren. Warum soll man Sachen beschleunigen, die man hört? Man kann ja auch Sachen beschleunigen, die man nicht hört. Die toten Phasen dazwischen halt.
Ja gut, aber das ist natürlich dann so eine adaptive Geschichte, das erfordert dir permanente Einsatz von Software, die über dein Audio rüber analysiert. Das frisst natürlich enorm viel CPU.
Klar, muss ja auch nicht jetzt kommen, komm nächstes oder übernächstes Jahr, aber es wird alles kommen. Ich meine, die iPhones sind drei Jahren, die werden so schnell sein wie unsere Laptops jetzt.
Wird es eigentlich auch ein iPhone 3GSS geben?
Ist da auch nicht erlaubt.
Ja, da kann dann hier Craig dann aus der Napsixation...
Dann läuft das jetzt gleich nicht drauf.
Okay, gut, ich beruhige mich und leide hier schon wieder unter den Notes, ist Landscape-Modus jetzt auch möglich. Was hätte ich denn lieber gerne gehabt?
Jetzt gibt es ja die erste.
Achso, und was auch wieder richtig kacke ist, dadurch dass sie jetzt dieses User-Interface-Element, dieses Audio-User-Interface-Element für Podcasts geändert haben, ist halt auch dieser eigentlich sinnlose Random-Shuffle-Button weg. Der hat da eigentlich auch nichts zu suchen gehabt. Das Problem ist, jetzt hast du gar keine Möglichkeit mehr, dem Telefon zu sagen, dass du bitte nicht automatisch in den nächsten Podcasts rübergehen willst. Weil er spielt jetzt nach wie vor das wie eine Playlist ab, auch Sachen, die du schon gehört hast. Und das habe ich 40.000 Mal schon beklagt, wenn du sowas hast wie Hintergrundpolitik, weißt du, so ganz kantig geschnittene Sachen, wo du gar nicht merkst, dass die Dinger zu Ende sind, weil es mit irgendeinem Zitat endet, und das nächste, wenn wir mit dem nächsten Zitat anfangen. Du merkst überhaupt gar nicht, wann du irgendwas zu Ende gehört hast. Und wunderst dich dann erst mal 5 Minuten, warum jetzt die Kulturszene in Kasachstan, was das jetzt mit den neuesten Forschungsergebnissen der Botanik zu tun hat. Und das geht nun wirklich überhaupt nicht. Also das müssen sie ändern. Das nervt mich wirklich sehr. Und wenn das jemand im Jailbreak fixt, dann wäre das für mich wirklich ein Jailbreak.
Jetzt piept aber irgendwie anders hier die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das ist hier der Computer, den hab ich hier irgendwie. Wenn ich angeschrieben werde, macht's kurz Piep.
So, was haben wir noch, iPhone 3.0?
Von Navigon gibt's die erste Navigationssoftware. Und jetzt kommt's. Habt ihr gekriegt, was die Scheiße kostet? 85 Euro. 75 Euro.
Ja, das ist auch so meine Erwartungshaltung für alle anderen. TomTom wird bestimmt auch so 100 Euro kosten.
Ich hoffe mal, dass die mal halbwegs realistische Preise machen.
Ich hab ja so TomTom und die Karten alleine. Wenn ich die jetzt updaten wollte, müsste ich alleine dafür 80 Euro zahlen. Nur für die Karten, ohne Programm, weil das hab ich alles schon bezahlt.
Warum kostet der Scheißdreck so viel?
Weil das teuer ist.
Und die Karten halt, ganz Europa und so.
Ja, ich geh in die nächste Tankstelle und hol mein Atlas für 5 Euro. Das sind die gleichen Karten.
Den klappst du dann auf und der Atlas sagt dir, wo du langfahren musst oder was?
Nein, aber die Karten sind offensichtlich nicht das Teure.
Die Karten sind doch im Wesentlichen das Teure. Und natürlich in der Navigationsgeschichte auch. So ist derzeit der Markt. Das wird sich hoffen. Die ganze PDA-Software, was kosten Navigationssystemen, wenn du es heute im Laden kaufst? Das kostet so zwischen 100 und 400 Euro, je nachdem, wie schick du es gerne hättest.
Genau, da hab ich aber ein Gerät für.
Mein Europa-Zone hat 500 Euro gekostet.
So, und die PDA-Versionen, die kosten auch alle so 100 Euro. Es ist so. Sie probieren es jetzt. Aber Navigationssoftware hat natürlich einen hohen Usagewert und ist definitiv im Bereich Oberklasse-Software.
Was? Also ich würde sagen, Navigationssoftware so 10 bis 20 Euro sollte ja scheiß kosten. Also dann hätte ich es sofort gekauft. Weil, ich meine, wie oft braucht man Navigationssoftware?
Na, wenn du das in deinem Auto installierst, dann jedes Mal, wenn du fährst. Na, wenn du es nicht häufig brauchst, dann brauchst du auch keine Navigationssoftware.
Doch, hin und wieder brauch ich eine Navigationssoftware. Aber ich weiß ja nicht mehr, ob der Scheißdruck funktioniert. Und, ähm, zum anderen...
Ich hab da ein ganz anderes Problem mit. Nämlich, wenn du halt ein Auto hast, dann hast du es vielleicht so in der Familie. Und wenn ich ein Navigationsgerät kaufe, dann installiere ich das im Auto. Und dann kann das jeder benutzen. Aber wenn ich das auf meinem iPhone installiere, dann geht das halt nur auf meinem iPhone, was ich ja wieder mitnehme. Und wenn jemand anders das Auto fährt, dann muss er das auf seinem eigenen iPhone haben.
Ist auch egal, gibts ja nix.
Und selbst wenn die Karten so sauer teuer sind, dann bietet mir Karten für eine Stadt an und ich kauf mir die anderen Karten dazu, wenn ich sie brauche.
Was machen die halt eben nicht? Es ist ja auch die Aktualisierung.
Dann würden sie ja kein Geld verdienen.
Das sind ja alles aktuelle Daten.
Die sind ja nicht doof.
Wenn sie Geld verdienen wollen, dann sollen sie Google etwas entgegensetzen, die wahrscheinlich in dreieinhalb Minuten mit einer kostenlosen Navigationslopfer ankommen wären.
So eine dreieinhalb Minuten, die gibt es schon seit einem Jahr. Wenn ich mir die Kartensuchergebnisse von Google im Mittel anschaue, und ich würde darauf navigieren, da findet er manchmal einfach Straßen gar nicht.
Das ist bei TomTom aber auch nicht besser. Ich hab jetzt eine Karte, die ist jetzt irgendwie anderthalb Jahre alt. Wenn ich jetzt durch die Gegend fahre, da gibt es schon eine ganze Menge, die irgendwie nicht stimmt.
Weil sie out of date sind? Ja, gut, aber bei Google sind Straßennamen falsch geschrieben und findet sie nicht, obwohl es sie gibt. Der Kartenbestand von Google Maps ist mit dem Kartenbestand von TomTom noch nicht zu vergleichen.
Ja, aber die Karten können offensichtlich die Linie des Teures sein, ansonsten würden Atlanten ein paar Geld kosten.
Es ist auch die laufende Pflege. Du zahlst ja auch noch ein bisschen mehr. Du hast ja diese IQ-Geschichte. Sie erfassen ja nicht nur, wo die Straßen sind, sondern du hast ja dann auch die Information darüber, wie da tatsächlich gefahren wird. Die sammeln über mit Vodafone zusammen, hatten wir doch glaube ich hier auch schon mal gesprochen, sammeln die halt wirklich auch die Information darüber, wie schnell du wirklich auf einer Straße bist. Klar, billiger kann ja sein, vielleicht kostet sie nur 79 Euro. Ich sagte nur, don't hold your breath.
Die melken natürlich jetzt den Markt, ist doch klar.
Da gibt es auch nicht viel Konkurrenz.
Hoffen wir mal, dass auf dem iPhone ein bisschen was losgeht und dass sie dann sehen, für 75 Euro werden wir unseren Scheiß treten. Wahrscheinlich werden sie erstmal jammern, dass so viel Raub kopiert wird.
Und die Navigationssachen auf dem iPhone, Raub kopiert.
Weil sie so teuer sind.
Klar, alle die Instalos und Hekolos benutzen, die werden es demnächst sich einfach da drauf spielen. Aber ich meine, bei den anderen PDAs gibt es auch die TomTom Software ohne Ende im Netz.
Ich glaube, das wird am Ende für die kein Problem sein. Die werden genug von dem Scheiß verkaufen. Ich frage mich halt nur, wie benutzbar das wirklich ist. Außerdem denke ich mir, sie haben doch gesagt, dass bei ihrer Halterung nochmal ein GPS-Enhancer mit dabei ist. Das kann ja wohl nichts anderes sein als ein eigener GPS-Stein. Also eine Antennenverlichtung kann es nicht sein.
Da wollen sie halt nochmal richtig Geld verdienen und das ist auch Geld, was sie selber verdienen, weil da müssen sie halt an Apple nix abtreten. Weil es wird ja wahrscheinlich einzeln verkauft.
Ich könnte mir nur vorstellen, dass es halt auch mit dem iPod Touch geht.
Dann machen sie die ab, wahrscheinlich relativ billig. Dann müssen sie nicht so viel an Apple abgeben und dieses Zusatzteil machen sie relativ teuer.
Die ab kostet 75 Euro, was ich nicht für relativ billig halte.
TomTom gibt es noch gar nicht.
Wenn dieses Time im iPod Touch funktioniert, dann wäre das sozusagen eine interessante Alternative zu einem normalen Navigationsgerät. Du kaufst diesen Touch nur dafür. Was kostet der Touch? 250?
Das ist auch ganz schön eine Menge.
Na gut, aber das Ding kann ja noch mehr als nur Navigation. Dann hast du ja auch ein vollwertiges Internet-Terminal sozusagen in deinem Computer. Aber du hast auch die Navigationssoftware, die benutzt du halt.
Aber Internet-Terminal hat ja unterwegs kein Netz, kein Nix.
Ja, stimmt.
Nur WLAN, also kannst du auch knicken. Ist doch nicht so spannend.
Spiele, Medien abgucken.
Ein altes, gebrauchtes 3G kaufen ohne Vertrag.
Schön auf der Autobahn mit 250 und dann irgendwie Matrix Revolutions. Ich krieg sie, ich krieg sie, links, rechts.
Klingt ein bisschen nach der Untergang.
Ja. Der Untergang?
Mir ist jetzt gerade kein anderer Katastrophenfilm eingefallen. Ich weiß, das war kein. Aber es endet in der Katastrophe.
Hallo, ist das kein Katastrophenfilm?
Du weißt, dass das so ein Internet-Meme befestigt ist. Ich sah uns schon jetzt irgendwie so eine Mobile-Max-Version davon.
Das wäre mal Zeit.
Sind wir jetzt immer noch bei iPhone 3 neu?
Ich stelle dir das vor, Adolf Hitler in seinem Bunker, der über iPhone die Qualität von Mac OS X und das Verhalten von Steve Jobs handelt.
Hitler, Twitter, wollen sie den total?
Immer noch kein Tessering mit dem Mobile möglich.
Dieser Steve Jobs, der soll immer in den Bunker kommen.
Dem werde ich zeigen, wie man mit solchen Sachen umgeht.
Wie soll ich ein 1000-jähriges Reich erreichen ohne Hintergrundprozesse?
So, Jungs, reicht wieder?
Also was steht auf der Liste? Haben wir noch iPhone 3.0 oder haben wir jetzt andere Sachen noch?
Haben wir noch iPhone 3.0.
Weil die 3 Stunden nähern sich langsam.
Was? Okay, also ich hab jetzt so, davon nix mehr dazu.
Dann können wir jetzt ein bisschen in den Freestyle-Mode übergehen und wenn dir noch Sachen einfallen, schiebst du die einfach nach. Das war jetzt Kühe und jetzt kommt Freestyle.
Okay.
Ja, dann mach ich zum Thema Freestyle, ich möchte ein hohes Lied auf die Time-Maschine noch mal singen. Gestern Abend hab ich festgestellt, dass meine Platte, oder eigentlich krieg ich das schon seit ein paar Tagen mit, dass mein Rechner hin und wieder mal ziemlich lange hing und ich nix machen konnte und ich ziemlich verzweifelt war.
Oh warte, du hast da die Platte drin, die ich auch hab, diese 500er?
Das ist die 500er, ja. Ist da in einem Arsch oder was?
Nee, nee, noch nicht, deswegen frag ich.
Nee, nee, also bisher sieht es so aus als ob es... Ich muss das aufbauen.
Diese 500er im neuen MacBook.
Nee, das ist die extra gekauft. Das ist die 500er, die ich schon im alten MacBook hatte.
Das ist kein neues, oder?
Du hast ja jetzt ein vorletztes. Du hast ja noch ein Wechselakku, ne?
Ich hab noch ein Wechselakku, ja.
Du bist doch der Arsch, du warst doch zu früh, oder?
Ich bin der Gearschte, nicht der...
Genau, so wollte ich es sagen. Kein SD-Krat und so. Express-Log, yeah!
So, das müssen wir jetzt nicht rausschneiden, den Mittelfinger ging kann man nicht hören. Und plötzlich wollte Adium nicht mehr starten.
Gibt es übrigens ein Update gerade?
Ich hab auf Adium geklickt und bamm, war es vor meinem Rechner ein und danach war Adium wieder unerwartet beendet. Und zwischendurch so ganz merkwürdiges Verhalten, so irgendwie mit Tim gechattet und jedes Mal, wenn Tim eine Nachricht geschickt hat, hat es bei mir vor meinem Rechner ein für mehrere Minuten. Vielleicht ist dir aufgefallen, dass ich relativ langsam geantwortet habe im Chat, aber Tim hört eh nicht zu. Und dann habe ich gedacht, ok, Adium löschen, neu installieren. Und dann ließ ich Adium einfach nicht mehr löschen und in dem Moment ahnte ich, dass meine Festplatte nicht sauerlich gut geht. Habe es das Festplattendienstprogramm drüber laufen lassen. Das hat gesagt, hey, deiner Festplatte geht es nicht gut. Danke für den Hinweis. Mit Apple S gebootet, FSCK-Check drüber laufen lassen. FSCK-Check hat gesagt, du, deiner Festplatte geht es nicht gut und ich kann da nicht viel machen. Okay, also wollte ich zuerst nochmal einen Backup machen, aber das war zu dem Zeitpunkt schon alles so unglaublich langsam, dass das wahrscheinlich drei Tage gedauert hätte. Also geguckt, wann hatte ich das letzte Mal meine USB-Platte dran? Das war am Freitagabend. Ich hab dann gesagt, okay, drauf geschissen, Platte neu formatiert, System neu drüber gebügelt und das Backup wieder eingespielt. Und ich war heute Morgen wieder in einem Zustand, dass ich problemlos weiterarbeiten konnte. Es fehlten zwar so ein paar Kommando-Zahlenprogramme und so ein Zeug, die man sich im Laufe der Zeit eben dazu installiert gerne, so ein Port oder sowas.
Also das kommt gleich neu formatiert?
Ich hab neu formatiert, hab System verzippt.
Hast du eine Partition oder zwei?
Eine.
Eine ganz, okay. Und ohne File Vault?
Ohne File Vault. Das könnte ich ja auch nach und nach noch einschalten. Mit File Vault hab ich mal schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht.
Ja, ich hätt schon noch mal so eine Ebene mehr, kann natürlich auch mehr schief gehen.
Also ich hatte mit File Vault hatte ich das Problem, dass ich irgendwann ein File Vault-Volum hatte, was unglaublich groß ist und dass ich's dann abschalten wollte wieder, weil das immer mehr gewachsen ist. Und er mir irgendwann gesagt hätte, du bräuchtest, dass ich irgendwie 5,5 Terabyte bräucht, um mit File Vault wieder abzuschalten, weil ich gesagt habe, spinnst du noch, du Scheißkiste? Und das war dann auch gar nicht so leicht.
War das noch unter 10,4?
Das war noch unter 10,4.
Bei 10,5 ist ja dieses File Vault so einzelne in der Datei und der kann viel schneller das schrumpfen lassen.
Ah, okay. Also File Vault ist besser geworden mit 10,5, ist nochmal ein Versuch wert.
Also das Image, wo das File Vault gespeichert wird, ist jetzt nicht mehr ein riesengroßes File, sondern ist ein Ordner mit vielen Files drin und wahrscheinlich die Ordner sind einzelne Files oder wie auch immer und wenn irgendwas weg ist, dann löscht er das entsprechende File und muss nicht das ganze Image irgendwie neu schreiben.
Das ist natürlich dann viel besser.
Die sogenannten Bands, wie das aufgeteilt ist.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen kein sparse Image mehr, sondern ein sparse Bundle.
Gut, das ist der Grund, warum ich Fileboard nicht so gesonderlich mochte. Aber vielleicht kann man ja in dem Zusammenhang das dann nochmal ausprobieren bei der Gelegenheit. Ja, und auf jeden Fall hab ich dann System neu installiert. Dann hat er beim ersten Hochfahren gefragt, hey, hast du vielleicht schon irgendwo eine Festplatte rumliegen, auf der du noch Daten drauf hast, die jetzt zurückgespielt werden sollen? Da hab ich gesagt, ja, hier, nimm. Hat er irgendwie eine Stunde gebraucht. Er hat behauptet, dass er ungefähr eine Stunde brauchen würde. Ich hab's nicht gestoppt, ich bin einfach schlafen gegangen. Und am nächsten Morgen, also heute Morgen bin ich, guck ich meinen Rechner an und alle Daten sind wieder da. Das war dann doch ein sehr, sehr schönes Erlebnis. Das ist schön. Also, liebe Kinder, macht Backups und nehmt dafür Time.
Backups machen das immer toll.
Ja, und mit dem iPhone genau dasselbe. Jetzt auch mit Krypto. Wobei, wahrscheinlich bei mir sich das gar nicht lohnt, weil ich mein Filevolt ja schon hab. Ich denk mal, da könnte man sich's eigentlich sparen. Aber ich hab's heute mal aktiviert. Und dann ist im iTunes, wo man sich die Devices mit Backup angucken kann, da ist ein kleines Schloss davor und dann ist alles prima. So, ich hab ja auch noch was Kleines, bevor Tim wieder losliegt. Er holt schon wieder Luft, ich seh's schon. Und zwar saß ich letztens neben einem Kumpel und der hat auch hier so ein, nicht ein SD-Card, 15 Zoll MacBook Pro, sondern auch noch das, was hier Max auch hat. Und der meinte irgendwie, bei ihm geht der Hibernation-Mode nicht, also dass auch der Rechner wirklich auf die Platte speichert. Da haben wir bei ihm ein bisschen rumgefummelt mit diesem PM-Set, da gibt es ein Command Line Tool, das ist dabei, da muss man irgendwie Mode 3 nehmen oder so, wenn nicht guckt man noch ein bisschen in die Doku. Haben wir es bei ihm eingeschaltet, ging dann auch. Und weil wir gerade schon mal bei dem Thema waren, haben wir mal ein bisschen gegoogelt, weil es gibt ein Tool, das heißt Smart Sleep. Das ist so eine Preference-Erweiterung, genau, hat hier Max auch am Start, Tim nickt auch schon. Und da kann man einstellen, zum Beispiel, dass man möchte, dass, wenn man noch über 50% Batterie hat, dass er dann einfach nur in den Sleep-Mode geht, ohne was auf die Platte zu speichern. Und wenn er aber schon unter 50% Batterie ist, dass er dann doch bitte auf die Platte speichert und dann in den Sleep-Mode geht. Und das ist schon ganz cool, weil wenn ich über 90% irgendwie Batterie hab, dann muss er bei mir jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwie noch auf die Platte speichern. Ist zwar schon ein Stück riskanter, wenn er dann doch zwei Tage rumsteht, der Rechner oder was auch immer passiert, dann wäre der Strom weg. Oder falls halt einer irgendwie die Batterie rausfällt. Aber ich denke mal, das ist eine gute Zwischenlösung.
Vor allen Dingen, er geht dann viel, viel schneller schlafen dadurch.
Genau, außer man hat Transmission an.
Genau, da wird sich der Patrick wieder freuen. Das ist nämlich derselbe Autor, der ja auch Jollies Fast VNC macht. Was Max ja hier auch schon in höchsten Tönen gelobt hat.
Das schreibt gute Software.
Patrick Stein, ja?
Genau, der war auch bei dem Hörer-Treffen in München da und so.
Ach so, nicht bei uns.
Nee, weil er ja in München wohnt. Nächstes Mal bist du da.
Es ist hier mehr Einsatz. Und Schoki nicht vergessen.
Wir loben jetzt deine Software so lange, bis du hier aufkreuzt. Dann musst du sehen, was du davon hast.
Viel gelobte Software, glaube ich.
Ja, wo wir gerade bei irgendwie coole Tipps, die man auch hätte vorher schon wissen können, betrifft, hier über Twitter werde ich gerade aus gut hinterrichteten Kreisen darauf hingewiesen, was der Grund sein könnte für dieses Login-Dingsbums bei dem Hotspot-Detection von dem iPhone. Was ich vorhin noch gerätselt habe. Der Standard heißt Whisper. Whisper, Wireless Internet Service Provider Roaming.
Ach so, die haben sich da alle mal geeinigt.
Die haben sich jetzt mal auf was geeinigt. Und ich vermute, es gibt da irgendeine Autodiscavriese, dass die Dinge halt sagen, ich bin da Whisper-kompatibel usw.
Das sind ja wirklich nur Einträge auf der Webseite. Das ist auch so ein Standard, der ist nicht international abgesegnet, sondern die haben sich da einfach mal irgendwie so geeinigt. Das ist so ein de facto Standard, so ein entstandener, oder?
Genau, die Wi-Fi-Alliance und so. Und dann machen sie da halt irgendwie Radio-Server. Da geht es halt vor allem ums Roaming, dass man eben auch in anderen Hotspots mitromen kann. Also das ist sozusagen, was da technisch dahinter steckt. Wobei ich glaube, dass Apple noch ein bisschen mehr eingebaut hat als nur das. Also einerseits erkennen sie halt auch Hotspots, wenn die jetzt so ein spezifisches Protokoll da nicht fahren. Wie man eben bei den T-Mobile-Hotspots, die eigentlich nichts anderes machen, als einem bekloppte Webseiten vor die Nase zu hauen. Ich schätze mal, sie haben da so eine... Ja, also sowas wie, wenn du halt auf ungültige IP-Adressen gefordert wirst, die im Netz eigentlich nicht sein dürfen, wie 111 und so, oder die reserviert sind, dann geht er davon aus, dass ein Hotspot sowas ist zum Beispiel.
Ist ja auch, also ich meine, bei Safari klingt es jetzt erst mal relativ sinnlos, da ist ja die Weiterleitung kein Problem, aber in anderen Programmen, wie zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt gerade in Mail ist und probiert, seine Mails abzurufen, weil bisher einfach immer das Ergebnis ist, dass man... Wieso passiert denn nichts?
Genau, und das ist ja auch total übel, weißt du? Irgendwelche Programme im Hintergrund fangen an, ihre HTT-Perikes zu machen und kriegen dann halt alle solche redirects auf diese bekloppten HTML-Seiten, was sich natürlich auch schnell mal ein Programm furchtbar durcheinanderbringen kann.
Bei NetNewsWire war das früher immer so ein Drama. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, in welchem Netz ich das ständig hatte, das Problem. Auf jeden Fall war das... NetNewsWire hat dann die Weiterleitung, also hat dann probiert, du hast deinen Rechner aufgeklappt, NetNewsWire hat probiert, Feed zu aktualisieren. Wurde weitergeleitet, hat NetNewsWire gesagt, ah, der Feed hat eine neue URL.
Genau das.
Zack, zack, zack, schon war die gesamte Abonnentenliste mal eben komplett im Arsch. Das war so eine widerliche Scheiße.
Exakt, genau das. Er hat da so ein bisschen AI eingebaut, wie diese Redirects sind. Wobei, ich glaube, der Fehler war, dass er auf Temporary Redirects reagiert hat, anstatt auf Permanent Redirects. Das ist natürlich ein wichtiger Fehler gewesen.
Das muss mich aber ehrlich gesagt auch nicht wundern, wenn einige so einer Route auch einen Permanent Redirect schicken, statt einen Temporary.
Ja, aber das muss ein Ende finden mit diesen Http-Redirects. Mir hat das schon immer nicht behakt und das ist einfach evil. Und man muss sich da einfach einigen im Internet um einfach so was, Zugänge, die unter Umständen erst eine Authentication brauchen, bevor es weiter geht und so. Und wenn sie diese Detections ins iPhone eingebohrt haben, können sie es auch gleich in den Mac anbauen. Es sind sowieso wieder so einige Sachen im iPhone gelandet, die sie jetzt ganz gut auch gleich mal zurückporten können. Ein Beispiel hat man ja schon hier. Das war kein gutes Beispiel, denn das war ja schon vorher schon im Mac drin. Das hatte ich irgendeinem Beispiel, das fällt mir gerade nicht ein. Wie auch immer.
Safari gibt es übrigens ein hübsches kleines Feature, was hoffentlich auch ins New Leopard dann drin sein wird. Und zwar Safari auf dem iPhone unterstützt als Geolocations. Gibt es einen HTML5?
Hast du das schon mal zum Laufen bekommen?
Das habe ich schon mal zum Laufen bekommen.
Wurde denn auf Flickr?
Nein, ich habe selber eine Testsite dafür geschrieben.
Achso, weil mir wurde versprochen, hier im Internet, dass es auf Flickr ginge, aber offensichtlich geht das nicht, wenn man aufs deutsche Flickr kommt.
Ja, da ist es irgendwie ganz doof. local.adwin.net habe ich einfach mal. Das ist so ein Beginn eines Projekts, das ich gerade gestartet habe. Auf jeden Fall müsste jetzt... Jetzt müsste er zeigen, wo wir gerade sind.
Was ist das dann im Browser? Was musst du da tun? Du lieferst JavaScript aus in der Seite und der macht lokal im Browser eine Anfrage auf irgendeine Library.
Ich schicke einen Befehl an navigator.geolocation.irgendwas und gebe eine Callback-Funktion an. Ich habe mehrere Möglichkeiten. Ich kann entweder sagen, gebe mir einmalig ein Ergebnis zurück. Das scheint bisher nicht 100% zu funktionieren. Das liefert nicht 100% konsistente Ergebnisse. Aber es gibt eine Watch-Funktion. Es gibt mir immer ein Update, wenn sich etwas geändert hat an meiner Position. Das ist natürlich ganz geil. Du könntest die Seite offen lassen und mittracken lassen, wo ich mich gerade hinbewege. Das funktioniert. Damit kriege ich immer Longitude zurück. Was ganz cool ist daran, dass Google dieses Google-Gears entwickelt hat. Für Firefox und Safari und weiß der Teufel was. Die ein paar HTML5-Features implementieren. Das sind zwar nicht die gleichen Befehle, aber die sind so weit kompatibel, dass man mit einer kleinen Abfraktionsschicht exakt dieselbe Seite auch auf dem Android-Telefon laufen kann. Sie läuft auch in Firefox 3.5, weil der auch diese Geolocation-RP hat. Wenn man Google-Gears installiert hat, läuft es auch in Safari auf dem Mac. Das wäre natürlich noch schicker, wenn es in Safari auch ohne Google-Gears laufen würde. Dann könnte man immer schön rauskriegen, wo man gerade ist, innerhalb seines Browsers. Da bieten sich ganz neue Applikationen.
Call Location muss sowieso ins OS, aber da ist auf der WWDC nichts zugesagt worden, oder?
Ist doch drinne. Also, ist doch... Ist drinne?
Ich hab jetzt noch nichts weiter dazu gehört, was das bekräftigt vermutet, wurde ja schon lange.
Was für mich ein deutlicher Hinweis ist, wenn man in Snow Leopard die Zeitzone einstellt, hat man einen Button unten drinnen, stellt automatisch die Zeitzone ein.
Beruhigend, wie schön.
Und ich hoffe, dass es dann auch in Safari kommt. Das ist meine nächste Hoffnung. Aber Leute, das kriegt ihr schon auf die Reihe.
Tja, haben wir eigentlich schon darüber geredet, dass kein ZFS kommen wird erst mal? Aber was mir jetzt auch noch aufgefallen ist, es gab doch neulich dieses Update für diesen Java-Security-Bug.
Es gab ein Update, stimmt, sie haben ihn gefixt.
Was du letztes Mal noch so beklagt hast. Und das ist jetzt gefixt worden, was ja schon mal ganz gut ist. Ich war ja insofern davon betroffen, weil ich ja tatsächlich regelmäßig eine Webseite benutze, wo mir ein Applet runtergeladen wird und so, wo ich dann theoretisch für dieses Problem wöhnere gewesen bin. Und das Interessante war, dass ich nach dem nach dem Runterladen und Installieren dieses Updates tatsächlich ein neues Behaviour feststellen konnte. Na ja, also wie? Also ich muss jetzt mit Einschränkungen sagen, dass ich nicht genau weiß, ob die jetzt, das muss ich nochmal hinterfragen, das Zertifikat geändert haben und jetzt geht's. Das hat gar nichts mit dem Update zu tun. Auf jeden Fall wurde mir vorher irgendwie das Zertifikat als ungültig angezeigt, wo es das jetzt nicht ist. Und jetzt kommt halt so ein neuer Dialog hoch, den ich so vorher noch nicht hatte. Und ich kann halt jetzt pro Domain sagen, dass ich hier das freischalten will, dieses Applet. Pro Domain, wohlgemerkt. Also Herkunft des Applets. Sprich, die Änderung, die jetzt mit diesem Bugfix einhergekommen ist, geht über einen reinen Bugfix hinaus.
War ja auch nicht nur ein Bugfix, es war ja ein neues Java-VM-Dings-Update, ne?
Ja genau, also man könnte ja sagen, da ist jetzt was, was ich in Semikolon vergessen worden.
Und sie haben auch eine neuere Version der Java-VM abgegradet.
Durch das Update.
Ja, ich glaub schon.
Das weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist klar, da ist jetzt auf einmal ein Dialog im Browser, wenn ich so ein Applet runterlade, den es vorher so nicht gab, wo ich halt sagen kann, willst du immer für dieses Domain das freischalten? Und er hat mir halt jetzt auch das Zertifikat, wo er vorher immer rumgemeckert hat, als richtig angezeigt. Ich kann jetzt nicht sicher dafür garantieren, dass jetzt nicht genau zeitgleich das Zertifikat auf dieser Seite geändert wurde und das jetzt auf einmal in Ordnung ist. Aber es könnte eben auch was damit zu tun haben. Gut, ist einfach nur so eine Beobachtung, die ich gemacht habe. Mal wieder ein sehr unqualifizierter Kommentar von mir.
Die unqualifizierten Kommentare von dir?
Ja, meine unqualifizierten Kommentare waren auch schon mal besser. So, jetzt gehen wir langsam die Dinger aus. Was ich aber auch noch gesehen habe, ist, dass der Cisco VPN Client jetzt ins No-Lab hat mit drin ist, was sie sich bisher geschenkt haben. Das dürfte natürlich hier Freundenschreie bei den ganzen Studenten in Berlin bringen und wahrscheinlich auch noch an vielen anderen Universitäten.
Weil die extra Software mehr brauchen.
Genau, weil das nämlich sehr verbreitet war und diese Software von Cisco, die du ja installieren konntest, war halt sehr eklig.
Und das ist das Gleiche, was es auf dem iPhone auch gibt. Das heißt, man kann sich jetzt irgendwo eine Cisco VPN Gegenstelle irgendwo besorgen und kann mit seinen Geräten irgendwie verschlüsselt...
Kannst du sagen, mit MacBook out of the box einfach an der Uni online gehen, wo Cisco VPN zum Einsatz kommt. So weit die Behauptung, das wird man halt sehen, ob das dann auch tatsächlich stattfindet.
Cisco 4Pan an der TU Berlin, Set 08 abgeschafft.
Ach so, echt, haben sie abgeschafft. Durch was ordentliches ersetzt. Steht da, wo steht das? Im Chat? Aha, wusste ich noch nicht. Treib mich da nicht so häufig rum. Aber in der HU gibt es das auf jeden Fall noch. Tja, dann überlege ich noch, ob ich mir so ein 15 Zoll MacBook kaufe. MacBook Pro.
Wegen Audio In und Audio Out?
Ja, das 13er hab ich ja letztes Mal schon ausführlich dargelegt, kommt ja leider nicht in Frage. Aber es gibt halt jetzt ein Feature, was ich halt echt cool finde. Also wo ich sagen würde, da hab ich jetzt... Geben wir weg.
Die Battery Life.
Ja, die Battery Life.
Ja, die soll schon eher Hammer sein, oder?
Also so 7 Stunden oder 8 Stunden. Das ist ein Statement. Also darauf hab ich eigentlich immer mal gewartet, dass ein Rechner so lange hält. Ich bin jetzt auch schon manchmal wirklich überrascht, eigentlich wie lange ich schon arbeiten kann, aber trotzdem nie so richtig zufrieden. Aber so wirklich eine komplette Zugfahrt von Berlin nach München auf Akku arbeiten zu können. Das ist schon interessant. Also das fände ich ganz interessant. Und das 15-Zoller ist definitiv auch das Most Complete-Gerät, wenn man jetzt mal von dem Missing Expansion absieht.
Ich hab ja eine Wette am Laufen, jetzt nachdem der Jailbreak draußen ist. Und zwar, dass innerhalb von zwei Wochen, nachdem der Jailbreak raus ist, draußen ist auch mit dem alten iPhone 3G möglich sein wird, Videos aufzunehmen. Dass irgendjemand den Schalter findet, den man umlegen muss, damit auch das alte iPhone Video kann. Ja, darum ja Jailbreak.
Na, die gibt's doch schon in den Programmen.
Nein, einfach, dass die Funktionalität, dass im Betriebssystem, also ich behaupte einfach mal, dass die Video-Funktionalität fürs neue iPhone auf dem alten iPhone entwickelt haben. Und dass das alte iPhone auch von einer, vielleicht nicht in ganz so toller Qualität wie das neue iPhone, aber auch in der Lage ist, dieses Video aufzunehmen und die hochzuladen. Und ich glaube, das wird irgendwo einfach ein Switch sein, den man irgendwo in der Hand schiebt.
Ich glaube, dieser neue VR-Stein, dazu haben wir noch gar nichts gesagt. Also in dem neuen 3GS ist ja die neue Generation, die fünfte Generation von diesem PowerVR drin. Das ist eine vollkommen neue, die fünfte Generation von der PowerVR-Architektur. Und das Ding erlaubt natürlich erst dieses ganze H264-Encoding, da bin ich mir sicher. Und das macht halt eben diese Performance-Steigungen, von denen du ja vorhin schon gesprochen hast, Dennis.
Na, ich bin mal sehr gespannt.
Mal 2, mal 4 in den OpenGL-Tests. Da ist das Ding. PowerVR SGX heißt das jetzt. Und das ist zusammen mit diesem Cortex 7. Generation Armstein das Geheimnis, warum das Ding so fix ist. Und ich bin mal gespannt, wenn ich das neue iPhone in der Hand habe, ob mir das zusagt. Also diese Bluetooth-Rucke-Geschichte, das wäre für mich schon der erste Incentive, wirklich über ein schnelleres Telefon nachzudenken. Man kann es übrigens jetzt in Italien kaufen.
Von hier aus als Geschenkoption bei Apple 699. Zwei Tage Lieferzeit fürs 32er, inzwischen schon sieben Tage Lieferzeit für die 16GB Version. Was vorgestern noch zwei Tage war, also es steigt schon, das 16er verkauft es anscheinend wie blöd. Wobei man will natürlich 32er, weil das Ding kann Videos aufnehmen, das sagt ja eigentlich schon alles, baumann viel Platz. Aber die liefern halt nur nach Italien.
Das heißt, man braucht irgendeine Adresse in Italien, wo jemand zuverlässig ein und das weiter schickt.
Also man kann nicht von hier klicken per Kreditkarte, man braucht nur jemand, der in Italien sitzt, das dort dann in Empfang nimmt.
Man kann irgendwelche Italiener. Ja, dann kannst du dir wahrscheinlich auf Ebay dann Italiener klicken, der dir das dann schickt.
Wahrscheinlich, ja toll.
Ja, schicke mir dein neuer iPhone, ich schicke dir sofort zu. Sehr zuverlässig.
1, 2, 3, wo ist?
Ja, ich hätte da auch Möglichkeiten. Ich glaub, ich hab da ne Adresse. Ich weiß bloß noch nicht, ob ich die Option wirklich ziehen will, weil das ist natürlich ganz schön teuer. Dann müsste man so sein altes Telefon gewinnbringend verkaufen können.
Na also ich will 1, 2. Die Option für mich...
Du willst ein was, ein neues oder ein altes?
Neues.
Ne, da 1 will ich nicht.
Na wenn, dann würden wir da Sammelbestellung machen. Kann ja auch nicht permanent irgendwie.
Dann eine große Lieferung, 10 iPhones in einem großen Karton.
Naja, will man natürlich schon versicherte Versand und Pipapo haben.
Und einmal in schnell.
Und in schnell genug, ja. Na gut, wenn das dann versichert ist.
Na wenn's mehrere sind, dann geht's wahrscheinlich vom Preis her. Wenn's nur eins ist, ist's wohl relativ teuer.
Ich bin Ende August auf dem Prager Flughafen.
Aber ansonsten hab ich von einem unserer Hörer schon die Option im August.
Wie weiß der in Italien wohnt oder was?
Ne, der da irgendwie Urlaub macht oder wie auch immer.
Wir haben ja auch Hörer in Italien.
Haben wir Hörer in Italien?
Ja, also auch vielleicht deutsche Hörer, was weiß ich. Ich glaub jetzt nicht, dass wir bei italienischsprachigen McIntosh-Community der meistgehörte Podcast sind. Aber es ist ja immer wieder erstaunlich, wo die Leute alle so sitzen.
Ja, aber in Italien sind doch schon die Deutschen auch öfter mal.
Auf Urlaub.
Auch. Und auch so, weiß ich nicht. Also arbeitsmäßig, so in Bayern, ist ja bis Italien auch nur ein Katzensprung, oder?
Genau, fahr doch mal rasch rüber nach Italien.
Nee, das hilft ja nicht, du brauchst ja eine Adresse oder du brauchst ja jemanden, der da... Aber ich denke, das wird sich schon irgendwie alles einregen. Ich will das Ding erstmal in der Hand haben und will mir mal da ein Bild von machen. Apropos Bild machen. Da habe ich noch eine Sache, die ich noch nicht erwähnt habe. Was ja auch der Fall ist, dieser Kompass, diese Kompass-Information, die steht auch in den Fotos mit drin. Das heißt, wenn du mit dem 3G-S ein Foto machst, dann ist die Blickrichtung im Bild mit gespeichert in den Metadaten.
Sehr gut.
Hauptsache, die machen es diesmal richtig.
Ja, vor allem weißt du, was das bedeutet?
Nee, noch nicht.
Na, du hast die Blickrichtung, du hast. Die Position, du hast die Blende, also den Öffnungswinkel, den hast du auch mit drin, also mit anderen Worten. Du weißt, an welcher Stelle auf dem Planeten, in welche Richtung geguckt wurde und mit welcher Linsenöffnung fotografiert wurde. Sprich, du kannst mehr oder weniger genau tatsächlich so einen Blickwinkel bestimmen, allein auf Basis der Metadaten des Bildes. Das ist zum Beispiel genau das, was Google braucht, um so ein Bild in 3D in Google Earth einzubetten. Diese spezielle Funktion gibt es ja auch mit diesen Gigapixel-Bildern zum Beispiel, dass du in so ein Foto reinzoomen kannst, so wie auch mit ihrem Street View, wie sie das ja im Prinzip auch machen, könntest du im Prinzip die Daten, die Fotos von dem neuen iPhone mehr oder weniger automatisiert direkt in so ein Google Earth Modell mit einbauen. Hat bestimmt schon irgendeiner gemacht. Fällt mir nur gerade so ein. Also diesen Kompass finde ich auch sehr interessant, einfach so als Hilfe, auch so dieses...
Genau, dass er die Karte gleich...
Genau, diese Maps-Karte, das ist immer wieder so ein Ding, wenn du irgendwie aus der U-Bahn kommst, dass du nie weißt, wohin du gehen sollst und so.
Dieses Karte gleich drehen, das ist... Also das Magic hat ja so einen Kompass schon eingebaut, den ich genau einmal nutzen kann, und zwar wenn ich mal mit Street View... Ich weiß, aber ich meine, das ist nicht die erste Wiederholung. Warum ist das nicht eingebaut?
Das bringen wir jetzt einfach in jeder Folge von MOBA MAGIC, würde ich sagen.
Genau, Kompass ist super.
Ja, mal schauen, was sich bei Android tut. Haben wir es?
Ja, glaub schon.
Der Chat beschwert sich noch über irgendwas.
Eine Kleinigkeit kann ich noch erzählen. Ich war das erste Mal in meinem Leben im Bundestag. Ich hab als diese ganzen Zensursula-Gesetze erlassen wurden, über die jetzt wahrscheinlich auch jeder Bescheid weiß. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir darüber noch so wahnsinnig viel lesen müssen, außer, oh mein Gott, hoffentlich wird das vom Bundesverfassungsgericht möglichst bald gekippt. Ich wollte mir das Ganze mal angucken, wie läuft eigentlich so ein Gesetz, Abschlussverfahren, wenn so was, und war im Bundestag und hat mir das mal angeguckt. Und was mir bei der Gelegenheit aufgefallen ist, also es gibt...
Es sind alles PC-Nutzer, sag's gleich.
Nee, außer Taus, hatte niemand im Plenarsaal ein Laptop. Die hatten alle so Aktentaschen und Papier, das sah aus wie in den späten 50ern. Nur ein bisschen gestört von einem Haufen Blackberries und wenigen iPhones. Ich konnte keine Steckdosen entdecken, irgendwo.
Akku sei nicht so lang.
Und die haben auch keinen WLAN. Es gibt keinen WLAN im Bundestag.
Das ist ja ein Sicherheitsproblem.
Da kann man auch ein WLAN-Passwort drauf... Also ich meine, keinen WLAN oder auch keine Netzwerkschnittstellen auf den Tischen oder sowas.
Man hat doch alle keine Ahnung von Computern. Du willst überhaupt gar nicht, dass die einen Computer benutzen.
Doch, ich will, dass die einen Computer benutzen, damit sie langsam mal Ahnung von dem ganzen Scheiß kriegen.
Aber die haben doch das Internet in der Aktentasche.
Meinst du, das hat die Kollegin für sie ausgedruckt?
Naja, klar.
Also ich weiß natürlich, dass die da nicht den ganzen Tag rum sitzen und arbeiten, sondern dass die eigentlich ihre Büros haben und dass sie da durchaus ihr Computer haben. Aber das ist in diesem Plenarsaal... Also ich meine, dass es keinen WLAN gibt, das hat mich wirklich so ein bisschen sprachlos stehen lassen.
Aber dafür haben die doch ihren Rechergebüroangestellten. Die können das gar nicht selber.
Ich glaube auch in den Presse-Räumen ist es nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich, da sich ein Internet schalten zu lassen. Also kein WLAN, das scheitert schon an kein Internet.
Und ich hab probiert zu... Also ich wurde erst bei ungefähr 48... Also fotografieren durfte ich nicht, natürlich wegen der Sicherheit. Klar, keine Frage. Haben sie mich extra noch mal... Oder nee, ich hab so halb nachgefragt und dann haben sie gesagt Nee, auf keinen Fall. Im Plenarsaal muss man das Telefon abschalten, was ich nicht gemacht habe, sondern ich hab nur einen Ton abgeschaltet und hab dann nebenbei getwittert, was ich gerade so vor mir sehe, und bin dann nach einer Weile ziemlich rüde von einem der Saalordner zusammengeschissen worden. Musste noch meinen guten Platz aufgeben, weil ich hatte einen relativ guten Platz. Den muss ich dann verlassen, weil...
Warum?
Weil ich getwittert habe. Weil ich mein Telefon benutzt habe.
Du hast ihm nicht gesagt, dass es kein Telefon ist?
Ich hab mit dem dann einfach nicht großartig rumdiskutiert, sondern...
Na ja, ich meine, wenn sein Problem war, dass man kein Telefon bedienen soll, dann kann man ja sagen...
Das ist ein Computer, mit dem man auch telefonieren kann.
Nein, damit kann man nicht telefonieren. Das ist einfach mein MP3-Player.
Computer darf man sowieso nicht mit rein, und MP3-Player wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Keine elektronischen Geräte.
Du darfst eigentlich gar nichts mit reinnehmen. Also Computer musst du auch abgeben.
Das ist wie mit einem Flieger. Die verstehen es nicht und verbieten deswegen alles.
Die haben Angst, dass es abstürzt.
Und warum die alle keinen Laptop haben, das habe ich mich auch bei Twitter darüber aufgeregt. Dann hat mir irgendjemand geantwortet, ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich stimmt, dass Laptops im Plenarsaal explizit verboten seien.
Aber Taus hatte doch einen.
Ich glaube, dem ist mittlerweile alles relativ wurscht. Aber er hat auch so ein kleines Netbook. Ansonsten scheinen Laptops echt verboten zu sein. Und das ist doch wirklich mal was. Leute, ändert das doch endlich mal?
Denken ist ja auch verboten. Also das passt ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Die verbieten alles, was sie nicht verstehen. Oder ist es eigentlich, wie es schon immer auf der Welt war?
Ist alles ganz furchtbar und grausam. Aber Herr Taus ist ja jetzt Pirat. Und dann wird alles besser.
Aber insofern brauchen wir uns nicht über die Entscheidung zu wundern, die daherkommt, dass die alle vom Internet ganz furchtbar Angst haben. Weil sie kennen das wahrscheinlich wirklich.
Na ja gut, also ich meine, ob das nun davon abhängt, dass es WLAN im Plenarsaal gibt. Da rennen die da irgendwie ab und zu mal rein alle paar Wochen und halten die Hand hoch. Das ist jetzt nun wirklich nicht der Ort. Ich bin ja schon froh, wenn sie sich in ihrem Büro vielleicht ein bisschen damit beschäftigen oder noch besser zu Hause.
Ja, also es hat sicherlich nicht die allerhöchste Priorität. Aber für dich war das auch ein WLAN. Für mich ist es ein selbstverständliches Arbeitswerkzeug, das ich ins Internet kommen kann. Und dass es da, dass die Menschen, die mich regieren, nicht mal Zugriff auf dieses Arbeitswerkzeug haben in einem ihrer wichtigsten Arbeitspunkte, fand ich dann doch schon ein bisschen bizarr. Aber vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach nur zu internettig.
Du bist definitiv zu internettig.
We're done here.
Wollen wir jetzt noch irgendwie... Wollen wir jetzt das Thema noch...
Gibt es da noch... Im Moment gibt es doch nichts Tolles zu sagen, oder?
Die Frage ist, ob wir jetzt noch einen Polit-Talk aufmachen.
Nö.
Wir können höchstens ein ganz kurzes Update geben, oder? Wie der Stand der Dinge ist. Irgendwann haben wir schon mal über Zensur erzählt.
Da gibt's ja jetzt nichts mehr zu erzählen, oder?
Und jetzt ist es beschlossen.
Ja, das ist klar.
Was für ein Update? Vielleicht hast du ja was, was ich noch nicht weiß.
Nö, das bestimmt nicht, aber diese TAUS verlässt die SPD und geht zur Piratenpartei-Nummer. Das war übrigens auch, ich war.
Was ist da? Ich war nicht auf der Demo, die hab ich leider verpennt. Als er am Bundestag seine letzte Rede gehalten hat, da hat...
Wie seine letzte voraus?
Nein.
Da finden nicht mehr allzu viele Sitzungen in dieser Legislaturperiode statt.
Ja, da ist jetzt im Wesentlichen Sommer Pause.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass man allzu viele Termine hat, an denen man was sagen darf. Und insofern hat er nochmal so quasi Abschlussfazit gehalten. Und die Einzigen, die geklatscht haben, waren die Paaren von der FDP, die noch da waren. Ansonsten hat er seine eigene Fraktion halt nicht geklatscht. Das fand ich wirklich... Ja, auch ein bisschen würdelos. Oder wie auch immer beschämt. Mit den Piraten? Na, ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Die brauchen jetzt erstmal, bevor sie... Die brauchen nochmal sowas wie ein Profil. So ein richtiges...
Ich halte mich da raus.
Ein Profil?
Naja, ein bisschen mehr als nur... als das, was sie bisher haben, als...
Also angeblich war jetzt gerade... Was heißt angeblich? Jetzt ist wohl gerade die Phoenix-Sendung mit so einem Interview mit den Jungs.
Mit welchen Jungs?
Na, mit CD Piratenparteien.
Irgendeiner von der CDU.
War es in diesem Moment oder was?
Vorhin, jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Achso.
Und die wurden wohl ganz schön zerpflückt.
Von Phoenix?
Jaja, klar, die wurden jetzt halt vorgeführt. Ist ja auch klar, da sind irgendwie so ein paar 19. Parteier aufgemacht.
Die können halt noch nicht so reden oder so. Das ist ja...
So sieht's aus. Wenn sie schlau gewesen wären, hätten sie gesagt, unsere Presseabteilung ist noch nicht aufgebaut. Das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Nö, die müssen sich mal ein bisschen die Finger schmutzig machen. Das ist okay. Also das...
Muss ich mir mal anschauen. Ich meine, das ist jetzt eine Third-Party-Aussage.
Und Mitternacht kommt wohl eine Wiederholung. Wo kommt die Wiederholung, Movie-Mack?
So Tim, deine Ovo-Martine war voll lecker.
Das ist nicht meine, das ist unsere. Du hast es, du bist schuld. Du hast gesagt, du willst Schoki und jetzt baden wir hier in Schokolade.
Geil, oder?
Ja, das ist mehr, als man irgendwie auch nur mental aufnehmen kann. Von Essen will ich gar nicht reden.
Was wollen wir nächstes Mal essen?
Na, davon können wir uns glaube ich noch mehrere Folgen ernähren, wie das hier so aussieht.
Also ich guck mal, hier ist noch...
Ja, wir haben noch ungeöffnete Aspekte.
Das meiste ist noch ungeöffnet, oder?
Ja, wobei ich hier diese kleinen, die werde ich mal für meinen Sohnemann irgendwie...
Ja, die kannst du dem alle geben. Und den Rest hier, den kannst du ja auch mal in die Kisse schmeißen.
Genau. Wir bedanken uns auf jeden Fall für so viel Zufriedenung.
Schade, dass man keine Schnitzels bestellen kann oder so.
Das finde ich auch schön. Also dass die Leute das so wertschätzen, das finde ich echt toll.
Wir werden gerade gefragt, ob wir Bier trinken.
Achso, und den Podcast gibt es sogar als Videopodcast. Noch nicht die Folge von heute.
Unter den Linden ist die Sendung bei Phoenix oder was?
Genau. Aber die scheint immer einen Tag zu kommen nach dem Design. Also am nächsten Tag scheint sie immer online zu sein.
Da ist ja Mobile Max schneller. Na gut.
Die Frage gerade, wo die Leute die Schokolade geschickt haben, wo die die Adresse herbekommen haben, wo sie die Schokolade hingeschickt haben. Oder willst du so eine Tims Podcast Studio Adresse?
Also wenn noch weiteres Interesse daran besteht, uns irgendetwas zu senden, Telefone. Dann könnt ihr mir gerne eine E-Mail schicken. Dann sag ich euch, wohin ihr das schickt.
Ganz kleines Abschlussding noch, es haben sich ja alle letzte Woche, oder nicht alle, aber es haben sich ja viele, die sich ein neues MacBook gekauft haben, so furchtbar darüber aufgeregt, dass es langsamer ist. Das SATA, was da drin ist.
Das ist schon noch ein kleines Thema, aber das verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber weißt du, was jetzt lustig ist? Gerade während wir die Sendung machen, jetzt wo wir es angesprochen haben, gibt es ein EFI-Update von Apple auf die Version 1.7 und die wird es wieder herstellen.
Also es war wirklich nur ein Softwareproblem.
Es war wirklich nur ein Softwareproblem.
Das ist doch mal eine gute Nachricht, damit können wir die Sendung schön prima zu Ende gehen lassen, weil mich hat es ein bisschen gewundert und dachte mir eigentlich schon, es kann eigentlich nicht sein, dass es jetzt noch irgendeinen Baustein gibt, der kein SATA 2 kann. Und deswegen müsste es eigentlich eine Softwaregeschichte sein. Und wie man sieht, ist es eine.
Gut, dann sind wir ja zum Ende der Sendung sogar nochmal auf unser Kernthema gekommen.
Wir haben ein Kernthema?
Weil das hat mich jetzt schon so ein bisschen abgehalten, mir so ein Ding irgendwie, also es ist so ein kleiner... Ja.
Du hast Angst gehabt, dass Leute auf dich zeigen und sagen...
Ja, genau. Das geht nicht. Wenn ich das kaufe, muss das irgendwie cool sein.
Na dann kann ich ja weiter darüber nachdenken, ob ich mir so ein Gerät kaufe, aber ich glaube, mein nächster Macintosh, den ich mir kaufen werde, wird ein iMac sein.
Ja, aber das baust du dann hier nicht auf, das kann ich dir aber jetzt schon sagen.
Damit er endlich Dennis nicht mehr sehen muss.
Ich hoffe auch. Es wird auch nicht mehr so lange dauern, und dann werden wir die Sendung auch nicht mehr hier machen.
Verstehe, du planst dann ein Studio. Ja, dann kannst du da die Schoki dann zukünftig schicken und alles andere.
Das ist bald, dass Brittlaff Tonstudio geben wird.
Ja, die Send-Sosala-Song ist wirklich grauenerregend.
Nee, den spielen wir jetzt nicht.
Der ist echt furchtbar.
Ja, nee, wir machen jetzt hier keine breiträumige Send-Sosala-Diskussion. Das verschiebe ich auf andere Podcasts. Es gibt noch genug zu diskutieren. Und...
Wir schmeißen jetzt Schoki-Papier weg und wünschen euch einen schönen Abend, oder?
Genau. Und das war's erstmal, wa?
Bis zum nächsten Mal!